Hello and welcome. My name is William and
I'm super excited to bring to you this video
series focused on graph theory. graph theory
is one of my absolute favorite topics in computer
science, we're going to see a lot of very
awesome algorithms. The whole field is very
diverse and hugely applicable to real world
applications. I think everybody should be
able to learn, love and enjoy graph theory.
These first few videos are going to be a ramp
up the dose to introduce the topics of how
we store represent and traverse graphs on
a computer. By the way, this whole video series
will be taking on a computer science point
of view of graph theory rather than a mathematical
one. So we won't be covering proofs, and so
on per se. Instead, we'll be looking at algorithm
implementation details and code. So what is
graph theory? In essence, it is the study
of properties and applications of graphs,
which common folk or non mathematical folks
call networks. This is a very broad topic,
and my goal with this video series is to teach
you how to apply graph theory to real world
situations. graphs can be used to represent
almost any problem which makes them so interesting,
because they pop up absolutely everywhere.
A simple problem that can be phrased as a
graph theory problem might be given the constraints
in this picture, how many different sets of
clothes Can I make choosing an article from
each category? Of course, this could be phrased
and solved using only mathematics. But the
advantage to graph theory is that it allows
us to visualize the problem using nodes to
represent an article of clothing and edges
to represent relationships between them. Another
canonical example of a graph theory problem
is a social network of friends. A graph representation
enables us to answer interesting questions
such as how many friends this person x have,
or how many degrees of separation are there
between person x and person y. Now, we have
talked about different types of graphs. There
are many different types of graph representations.
And it's really important, I mean really important
to be able to recognize what type of graph
you're working with, and especially when you're
programming and trying to solve a particular
problem. This first type of graph is an undirected
graph. It's the most simple kind of graph
you'll encounter. And it is where edges have
no orientation. That is, if there's an edge
from node you to node v, it is identical to
the edge from V to U. For instance, in the
following graph, nodes are cities and edges
represent bi directional roads. Since if you
drive from one city to another, you can always
retrace your steps by driving the other way.
In contrast, to undirected graphs, there are
also directed graphs, sometimes called die
graphs. In these graphs, you've guessed it,
the edges are directed. So if we have an edge
from u to v, then you can only go from node
to node v, not the other way around. In this
graph, you can see that the edges are directed
because of the arrowheads on the edges between
nodes. This graph could represent people who
bought each other gifts. So an incoming edge
represents receiving a gift and an outgoing
edge represents giving a gift. Therefore,
person e in this graph bought person d a gift,
Person A bought themselves and Person B a
gift, and person F, about nobody any gifts
and received none. So far, we've only seen
unweighted graphs, but edges on graphs can
contain weights to represent arbitrary values
such as cost, distance, quantity, you name
it. weighted graphs come in both directed
and undirected flavors. As a side note, I
will usually denote an edge of a graph as
a triplet u, v, w to indicate where an edge
is coming from, where it's going to and what
its weight is. Of course, with this notation,
I also need to specify whether the graph is
directed or undirected.
Next up, I just want to have a quick chat
about special types of graphs and graph theory.
There are so many different types of graphs
that I only had to Select a few which will
be most relevant for this upcoming video series.
The most important type of special graph is
definitely the tree. A tree is simply an undirected
graph with no cycles. There are several equivalent
definitions of a tree such as a graph with
n nodes and n minus one edges. All the graphs
below are trees. Yes, even the leftmost one
since it has no cycles. A related but totally
different type of graph is a rooted tree.
The distinction here is that a rooted tree
has a designated root node, where every edge
either points away from or towards the root
node. When edges point away from the root
node. The graph is called an ABA ressence,
or an outreach and an anti arborescens or
entry otherwise, out trees are by far more
common than entries. From what I've observed.
It is also fairly common for people to refer
to a rooted tree simply as a tree instead
of an in or out tree. But there is an important
distinction there. Next are directed acyclic
graphs. These are graphs with directed edges
and no cycles. these graphs are very important
and fairly common in computer science, actually,
since they often are present structures with
dependencies, such as a scheduler, a build
system, a compiler, maybe, or perhaps more
relatable University class prerequisites.
There are several efficient algorithms that
we'll be looking at to deal specifically with
directed acyclic graphs, such as how to find
the shortest path and produce a topological
ordering of nodes. A topological ordering
of nodes is an ordering of nodes that tells
you how to process the nodes of the graph
so you don't perform a task before first having
completed all its dependencies. For example,
a topological ordering of class prerequisites
would tell you to take intro biology and intro
chemistry before taking a class on say genomics.
This next type of special graph is a bipartite
graph. It is one whose vertices can be split
into two independent groups, u and v such
that every edge connects between u and v.
This is just a fancy way of saying that the
graph is two colorable or that there are no
odd length cycles and graph often, a problem
we like to ask is what is the maximum matching,
we can create on a bipartite graph? Suppose
white nodes are jobs and red nodes are people
then we can ask how many people can be matched
to jobs. In this case, there are a lot of
edges in each graph. So I think the answer
for both is four. But in general, it's not
so easy if there are less edges, tougher constraints
and more conflicts. bipartite graphs also
play a critical role in the field of network
flow, which we will talk about later. This
last type of graph is a complete graph is
one where there is a unique edge between every
pair of nodes in the graph. A complete graph
with n vertices is denoted as the graph K
sub n, I have listed k one through k six on
the bottom. And you can easily see how this
scales when we add more notes. Complete graphs
are often seen as the worst case possible
graph you can possibly encounter, because
of how many edges there are. So if you want
to test your algorithm for performance, a
complete graph is an easy way to start. One
thing we're going to have to be really cognizant
about is how we're actually representing our
graphs on the computer. This isn't just what
type of graph it is, but what type of data
structure it
but what type of data structure are we representing
our graph with. And this can have a huge impact
on performance. The simplest way is inside
a 2d adjacency matrix. The idea is that the
cell MI j represents the edge weight of going
from node i to node j. So in the graph below,
there are four nodes. So I create a four by
four matrix and populate the graph with the
edge weights. If you look at the edge weight
from node C to know D, you'll see that Hasn't
agitative to. So in a row three and column
four of the matrix there is a value of two.
Note that is often assumed that the edge of
going from a node to itself has a cost of
zero, which is why the diagonal of the matrix
has all zero values. This matrix form has
several advantages. First, that it's very
space efficient. For dense graphs. Those graphs
with a lot of edges, the ED Jwi lookup can
be found in constant time, which is quite
nice. And lastly, I would argue that it is
the simplest form of graph representation
you can have. On the downside however, the
main reason people don't go for the adjacency
matrix as their first pick, is because it
requires v squared space, which is, well a
lot of space. In practice graphs with 10,000
nodes or more started to become infeasible
very quickly. The other issue with the adjacency
matrix is that it requires v squared work
to iterate over all the edges of your graph.
This is fine for dense graphs with lots of
edges. But it isn't so great for sparse graphs,
since most cells will be empty. The main alternative
to the adjacency matrix is the adjacency list,
which is a way to represent a graph as a map
of nodes to list of edges. The idea is that
each node tracks all of its outgoing edges.
For example, node C has three outgoing edges.
So the map entry for C will track the edge
from C to A with costs for the Add from C
to B, with cost one, and edge from C to D.
with cost to notice that, in the list of edges,
we only need to track two things, the node
we're going to and the cost to get there,
we don't need to keep track of where we came
from, because that's already implicitly known.
The nice thing about adjacency lists is that
it is great for sparse graphs, because it
only tracks the edges that you have, and doesn't
allocate additional memory that you might
not use like the adjacency matrix does. This
also means it's efficient when iterating over
all the edges. The main disadvantage to using
an adjacency list is that it is less space
efficient on denser graphs. Another subtle
disadvantage is that it takes big O of E time
to access a specific edges weight, although
in practice, you rarely or if ever actually
need to do this.
The last representation
I want to talk about is the edge list. an
edge list is a way to represent a graph simply
as an unordered list of edges. Basically,
it's exactly what it sounds like a list of
edges. Assume that the notation for any triplet
u, v w means the cost from node u to node
v is W. So for this graph, the edge list is
simply a list of six edges represented has
those triplets. This representation is very
simple. However, it lacks structure. And that's
why it is seldomly used. advantage to the
Angeles is is great for sparse graphs. iterating
over all the edges is super easy, and the
structure is simple. The downside is that
edge lookup can be slow, and you can run into
memory issues on large graphs. Today, I'm
going to talk about common problems in graph
theory. A lot of problems you will encounter
can often be reduced to a famous or well known
problem or some variant thereof. So it's important
to be able to familiarize ourselves with common
graph theory problems and their solutions.
Just before getting started falling off from
what we learned in the last video about representing
graphs, I want you to think about how you
would store and represent the graphs. And
the upcoming problems I'm going to describe,
in particular, is the graph and the problem
I'm describing directed or undirected, are
the edges of the graph. weighted or unweighted
is the common use case, a graph that is likely
to be sparse or dense with edges? And lastly,
should I use an adjacency matrix and adjacency
list and edge lists or some other structure
to represent my graph efficiently? So one
of the most if not the most common common
problem in graph theory is the shortest path
problem. Given a weighted graph, find the
shortest path of edges from node A to node
B. So if we pretend this graph represents
a road system, and were at node A and want
to get to note H, our shortest path algorithm
should be able to find us a list of edges
to follow that will lead us from A to h with
a minimal cost. Lucky for us, many algorithms
exist to solve the shortest path problem,
including a breadth first search for unweighted
graphs. Dykstra is algorithm Bellman Ford,
a star and many more. As simple as it sounds,
connectivity is a big issue in graph theory.
The problem can also be simplified to does
there exist a path from node A to node B in
this scenario, we don't care about the minimum
costs, we just want to know. Can one node
reach another node? A typical solution to
this problem is to use a union find data structure,
or do a very basic search algorithm such as
a depth first search or a breadth first search.
Another common problem is detecting negative
cycles in a directed graph. Sometimes we're
dealing with graphs that have negative edge
weights. And we need to know if a native cycle
exists, because if there does, it can throw
everything off. In this graph nodes One, two
and three form a negative cycle. Because if
you cycle through all the nodes, you end up
with a cost of negative one if you add up
all the edge weights, in fact, you can cycle
endlessly getting smaller and smaller costs.
In the context of finding the shortest path
a negative cycle is like a trap that you can
never escape. However, there are some contexts
where negative cycles are beneficial. Suppose
we're trading currencies across an exchange
or multiple exchanges. Currency prices try
to remain consistent throughout the day across
exchanges, such as trading USD to euros or
Canadian t yen. But sometimes there are in
consistencies in the currency exchange prices.
This makes it possible to do something called
an arbitrage, which cycles through multiple
currencies exchanging one currency for another
and coming back to the original currency with
more money than you originally started, at
a risk free gain. This is something we can
use graph theory for, because it uses detecting
negative cycles. There are two well known
algorithms that can detect negative cycles.
And those are Bellman Ford and Floyd warshall.
Some thing that comes up now and again is
finding strongly connected components within
a graph. This is analogous to finding connected
components of an undirected graph. But for
directed graphs, when looking at strongly
connected components, we're looking for self
contained cycles within the graph where every
vertex in a given cycle should be able to
reach every other vertex in that same cycle.
This is very useful in many algorithms as
usually an intermediate step. So it's important
to know how to find these strongly connected
components. And there are many very elegant
algorithms to do so such as Tarzan's algorithm,
you probably won't go through your computer
science career without hearing about the traveling
salesperson problem. The tsp problem is the
problem of having n cities and the distances
between each of them and finding the shortest
path that visits each city and comes back
to the original city at minimum cost. For
example, if your graph is the one on the left,
a possible tsp solution is the graph on the
right, which has a cost of nine. The tsp problem
is NP hard, meaning it is computationally
challenging problem. This is unfortunate because
the TSP problem has several very important
applications. Some famous algorithms we can
use to actually solve this problem or the
healed Karp algorithm with dynamic programming
doing some kind of branching and bounding
algorithm or you can use one of many many
approximation algorithms such as the ant colony
optimization. This next problem I want to
talk about is finding bridges in the graph,
which is something of a fascination to me.
bridges are edges which if removed, increase
the number of connected components in a graph.
And this graph the edges highlighted in pink
are bridges.
bridges are
important in graph theory because they often
hint at what points, bottlenecks or vulnerabilities
in a graph, think of your graph as a telephone
network or a set of bridges between islands,
you can immediately see the usefulness of
detecting bridges related to bridges, but
not the same articulation points, which are
nodes that if removed, increase the number
of connected components in the graph. In this
same graph, you can see the three articulation
points highlighted in pink. Next problem is
finding the minimum spanning tree of a graph.
A minimum spanning tree is a subset of the
edges that connects all the vertices together
without any cycles and with minimal possible
cost. So in summary, it's a tree meaning it
has no cycles, and it spans the graph at a
minimal cost. Hence why we give it the name
minimum spanning tree. For example, in the
graph below, one of the possible minimum spanning
trees is this graph with a least cost of 12.
Note that all minimum spanning trees of a
graph have the same minimal cost, but are
not necessarily identical. minimum spanning
trees are seen in lots of different applications
in computer science, including designing and
least cost network circuit design, transportation
networks, you name it. There's also several
approximation algorithms which rely on minimum
spanning trees, which is pretty interesting.
If you want to find a minimum spanning tree
of a graph, I recommend using one of Kuru
schools prims, or beruf cause algorithm. This
last problem, I think, is the most fascinating
and it is about finding the maximum flow
through
a special type of graph called a flow network.
Flow networks are networks where edge weights
represent capacities and some sense capacities
might be things like the maximum amount of
cars that fit on a road, or the maximum amount
of volume that can flow through a pipe, or
even the number of boats a river can sustain
without destroying the environment. And these
types of flow networks, we often find ourselves
asking the question, with an infinite input
source, that is cars, water boats, whatever,
how much flow? Can I push through the network?
Assuming we start at some source and try and
make it to some sync node? This question is
important, because at some point, there is
bound to be a bottleneck somewhere in our
flow graph that limits the amount of stuff
we can have traveling on the network, making
it from point A to point B, the maximum flow
would then represent things like
the volume
of water allowed to flow through the network
of pipes, the number of cards, the roads consisting
and traffic or the maximum amount of boats
allowed on the river. With these maximum flow
problems, we can identify the bottlenecks
that slow down the whole network and fix the
edges that have lower capacities. We're moving
on to talking about the depth first search
algorithm, which plays a central role in several
graph theory algorithms. So what is the depth
first search? A depth first search is a core
algorithm in graph theory, that allows you
to explore nodes and edges of a graph. So
it's a form of traversal algorithm. The nice
thing about a depth first search is that it's
really easy to code. And it runs in time complexity
of big O of a V plus e,
that is vertices plus edges, which is directly
proportional to the size of your graph. By
itself. A depth first search isn't all that
useful. But when argumented to perform other
tasks, such as count connected components,
determine connectivity between nodes, or find
bridges and articulation points, the depth
first search algorithm really shines. So let's
look at an example. As the name suggests,
a depth first search plunges depth first into
a graph without regard for which edge it selects
next, until it cannot go any further at which
point it backtracks and continues its exploration.
So a depth first search has to start on a
node. And I'm going to start our depth first
search on node zero. And now we arbitrarily
pick a node to go to some from node zero,
we're going to go and do nine. Then from no
nine, we only have one choice, which is to
go to node eight, at node eight arbitrarily
picking edge. So we're going to To go outwards
to node seven, node seven, we have plenty
of edges to choose from. So let's go to node
10, node 10, to node 11, and 11 to seven.
So we don't want to revisit already visited
nodes or nodes that are currently being visited.
So we have to backtrack to indicate backtracking,
I'm going to label edges and nodes as gray,
so backtrack all the way back to node seven.
So we're not finished exploring node seven,
because there are still edges to be picked.
So I'm going to go to node three, and node
three, I'm going to go node to node two is
a dead end. So we backtrack, then go to node
four, node four is also a dead end. So backtrack
from node four, back to node three, then pick
node threes last edge to go in Node five,
five to six, and six to seven, can't go to
seven, because we're visiting seven currently,
so backtrack all the way back to node eight.
from node eight, we still need to visit its
last edge, which goes to node one, node one
back to node zero, we can't go to node zero,
because we're currently exploring it, then
backtrack all the way to zero, which completes
our depth first search traversal of this graph.
So this was one particular depth for search
traversal. But as you saw, it could have gone
a lot of different ways. So now let's look
at some pseudocode. For this depth first search,
to get a deeper understanding of how it works.
The first thing we need to do is initialize
these three variables, which are n the number
of nodes in our graph, g the adjacency. List,
representing the graph and visited a Boolean
array containing true or false at index i
depending on whether or not node i has been
visited. In the beginning, this array should
have all false values because we have not
visited any nodes in the graph. Once that
is set up. At the bottom, I define our starting
node to be node zero and then called the depth
first search method to do the exploration.
The depth first search itself has one argument,
the current node we are at which I have conveniently
named at this method is recursive. So I checked
the base case, which is whether we have already
visited this node, if so we have no business
here and can return otherwise, let's visit
this node by marking it as true and exploring
all of its neighbors to explore all the neighbors
of the node, reach into the adjacency list
and pull out all the neighbors of this node
and explore them depth first by looping over
each and recursively calling the depth first
search method. And that's all a depth first
search really is in a nutshell, let's look
at another simple use case. For a depth first
search. I want you to discuss finding connected
components in a graph. First, let's understand
what we mean by connected component. Sometimes
the graph is split into multiple disjoint
components, and it's useful to be able to
identify and count these components. One way
to identify these components might be to color
them so we can tell them apart. But what does
coloring nodes really mean to a computer
coloring nodes
is equivalent to labeling each node is a component
with the same ID value. For example, every
node in the purple component gets an ID of
one, and every node in the green component
gets an ID of three, we can use a depth first
search to identify components this way. First,
make sure all the nodes are labeled from zero
to n non inclusive, where n is the number
of nodes, the basic algorithm is to start
a depth first search at every node, except
if that node has already been visited, and
mark all reachable nodes as being part of
the same component using the same ID. So if
we start at node zero, then we do a depth
first search here and then every node in this
component gets an ID of zero. So we go to
eight, giving it an ID of zero, 14 gets zero
13 or so label it with a zero then backtrack
like you do a depth first search, then explore
note for given an idea of zero and then finish
exploring. That component and then move on
to the next node in order. So go to node one
next, then node one, so depth for search there.
So go node five, label it with a one, five
goes to 17, label it with a one, backtrack,
go to 16, also label it with a one, we're
finished exploring this component, then we
would go on to node two, wherever node two
is, then explore that component, then node
three, explore node three is component unless
node three has already been visited, and so
on. So you do this for every component. Eventually,
we get to label all the components, and we
use a depth first search to do that. Awesome.
So that's how we find connected components
using a depth first search.
Now let's look
at some pseudocode. For how we do this, first,
we'll need a couple of things. We'll need
everything from the previous code we looked
at so n, the number of nodes in our graph,
G, our adjacency list, and our visited array,
but additionally, we'll also need a variable
called count that tracks the number of connected
components and components an integer array
that holds the integer value of which component
a node belongs to. Inside the find components
method, we loop over every node and check
if the current node has been visited or not,
and then execute some logic. This depth first
search variant differs slightly from the previous
in that we execute a depth first search for
every unvisited note, why do we actually do
the depth first search, we visit nodes and
mark them as visited. So we never revisit
the same node more than once we either skip
over a node because it's been visited in this
for loop or start a depth for search there.
If we start a new depth first search, we increment
the count variable and keep track of how many
depth first searches we have done. Inside
the depth first search method itself, the
two things we do are mark the current node
as visited, and set the current node to be
part of the component equal to the value of
count, then simply iterate over every neighboring
node that has not yet been visited, and call
the depth for search method to explore them
as well. Back inside the find components method,
simply return the number of components and
the components array that contains the information
about which component each node belongs to.
So we've covered two of the things you can
use the depth for search for doing a simple
traversal and determining connected components.
But we can argument a depth first search to
do so much more, such as computer graphs,
minimum spanning tree, detect and find cycles
in the graph. Check if a graph is bipartite
find strongly connected components topologically
sought your graph. Find bridges and articulation
points find augmenting paths in the flow network
generate mazes, and many many more applications.
So a depth research is super versatile, and
can be extended to do a whole ton of things.
Today's topic is the breadth first search
graph traversal algorithm. Alongside the depth
first search the breadth first search algorithm
is another one of those fundamental search
algorithms used to explore nodes and edges
of a graph. It runs in a time complexity of
big O of v plus e that is vertices plus edges,
and is often used as a building block in other
algorithms. It differs from a depth first
search in the way that explores the graph.
The breadth first search algorithm is particularly
useful for one thing, finding the shortest
path on an unweighted graph. A breadth first
search starts at a node in the graph and explores
its neighbor nodes first before moving on
to explore the next level of neighbors in
the sense of breadth first search explores
nodes in layers. So if we start breadth first
search at zero, we would visit zero first,
then visit all zeros neighbors, then we would
visit all zeros neighbors, the nodes in yellow
before moving on to the next layer of notes,
then we would visit all their neighbors and
so on.
So as you saw a breadth first search expose
a graph in a layered fashion, it does this
by maintaining a queue of which node it should
visit next, this is most easily seen with
an example. Let's begin a breadth first search
at node zero once more. So let's add zero
to the queue on the left. I will denote the
current node. in red. This zero is the current
node and we want to add Explore all zeros
unvisited neighbors and add them to the queue.
So we would add nine to the queue seven to
the queue and 11 to the queue. So zero has
no more unvisited neighbors. So we move on.
So nine is next up in the queue. So we add
all of nines unvisited neighbors to the queue.
So that is 10, and eight, then there are no
more neighbors of nine to visit. So we move
on to the next node in our queue, which is
seven, then we add all of sevens unvisited
neighbors to the queue. So we try and visit
node 11. But note 11 is already in the queue,
so we don't want to add it again. So we skip
it, then we will add six to the queue and
three to the queue. Then this process goes
on and on until we run out of nodes in the
queue. So I will let the animation play.
And that's how you do a breadth first search
in a nutshell. In the previous animation,
we relied on a queue to help us track which
node we should visit next. Upon reaching a
new node, the algorithm adds it to the queue
to visit it later. The queue dish structure
works like a real world queue, such as a waiting
line in a restaurant, people can either enter
the waiting line that is get in queued or
get seeded D queued. Let's look at some pseudocode
for the breadth first search. First things
first, we'll need to variables and the number
of nodes in our graph, and G the adjacency
list representing our unweighted graph. This
breadth first search function takes two arguments
s and E the start and end node indices of
the search. The return value for this function
is the shortest path of nodes from S to E.
I've divided the function into two methods
for simplicity. First, we solve the problem
by executing the breadth first search and
then we reconstruct the path from S to E.
So let's take a look at the solve method.
So here we are inside the solve method. The
first thing I do is initialize the queue data
structure that we'll need and add the starting
node to it. This queue should support at minimum
the end q n dq operations I just talked about,
then initialize a Boolean array with all false
values and mark the starting node as visited.
This array tracks whether or not node AI has
been visited. If the value at index is true,
then the node has either been visited or is
being visited and is on the queue. And the
animation this corresponds to the gray and
yellow nodes. The last thing we'll need is
an array called prev, which will help us reconstruct
the shortest path from the start to the end
node. Initially, this array should be initialized
with all null values. This array tracks who
the parent of node i was, so we can reconstruct
the path later. Let's loop while the queue
is not empty and plot the top node from the
queue by issuing a dq operation, then reach
inside the adjacency list and get all the
neighbors have this node loop over each unvisited
node. Once we find a next unvisited node and
queue it to the queue market as visited and
keep track of the parent node of the next
node in the prev array. Once the queue is
empty, and our breadth first search is complete,
simply returns the prev array. Back inside
the breadth first search method take the output
of the solve method which gave us the prev
array and call the reconstruct path method.
Here we are inside the reconstruct path method.
The first thing we do is actually reconstruct
the path by looping backwards from the end
node and making our way back to the start
node. That is assuming we can reach it. The
reason the prep array had to be initialized
to all null values is because that is the
way and checking whether or not the for loop
should stop since we loop through the prev
array backwards, starting With the end node,
we need to reverse the order of the nodes
so that the path starts at the start node
and ends at the end node. Last but not least,
we actually have to make sure the path between
nodes s and E exists, it might not be possible
to reach node II from node s. If the graph
is disjoint. If this is the case, then simply
return an empty path. Today we're going to
talk about using a breadth first search to
find the shortest path on a grid. This is
going to be a really fun video because we're
going to solve a problem. And I'm going to
teach you a bunch of handy tricks when doing
graph theory on grids. The motivation behind
why we're learning about grids in this video
is that a surprising number of problems can
easily be represented using a grid, which
a lot of the times turns into a graph theory
problem. grids are interesting because they're
a form of implicit graph, which means that
we can determine a nodes neighbors based on
our location within the grid. For instance,
finding a path through a maze is a form of
a grid problem you're trying to get from one
side of the maze to the other. Well, you need
to find a path that's a pathfinding problem.
Or perhaps you're a person trying to navigate
your way through obstacles such as trees,
rivers, and rocks to get to a particular location.
And this can be modeled using a grid, and
in turn, we end up using graph theory to navigate
around. A common approach to solving graph
theory problems on grids is to first convert
the grid to a familiar format, such as an
adjacency list or an adjacency matrix, so
we can easily work with them. However, this
isn't always the most efficient technique,
but we'll get to that. Suppose we have a grid
on the left, and we want to represent it as
both an adjacency list and in the adjacency
matrix, what do we do first, first, you should
label all the cells in the grid with the numbers
zero through n non inclusive, where n is the
product of the number of rows and columns.
So in this grid, on the left, there are six
cells. So I labeled each cell with the numbers
zero through six not inclusive, then we actually
want to construct an adjacency list and an
adjacency matrix. Based off this grid, the
adjacency list doesn't require any setup because
it's simply a map that we initialize, but
the adjacency matrix requires us to initialize
a matrix of size six by six to represent our
graph, there are six rows and six columns
in the new adjacency matrix, because it's
how many nodes that are in the grid we're
trying to represent. Assuming edges are unweighted,
and cells connected left, right up and down.
Node zero connects with node one and node
two, which we reflect in the adjacency list,
and adjacency matrix on the right, then node
one connects to node zero and node three,
node two to node 03, and four, node three,
with nodes one, two, and five,
and so on. And that's basically how you convert
a grid to an adjacency list or an adjacency
matrix. Once we have an adjacency list or
an adjacency matrix, we are able to easily
run whatever specialized graph algorithm we
need to solve our problems such as finding
the shortest path finding connected components,
etc. However, transformations between graph
representations can usually be avoided due
to the structure and the nature of a grid.
Let me explain. Suppose where the red ball
in the middle and we know we can move left,
right up and down to reach adjacent cells.
Well, mathematically, if we're the red ball
at the row column coordinate r comma C, we
can add the row vectors minus 101 comma 00,
comma one and zero comma minus one to reach
all the adjacent cells. If the problem you're
trying to solve allows moving diagonally,
then you can also use the row vectors minus
one minus one minus 1111 and one minus one.
Using row vectors makes it easy to access
neighboring cells from the current row column
position. First, define the direction vectors
for north south east and west broken down
into their row column components. Then what
we want to do is loop over each direction
vector and add it to the current position
here I iterate I from zero to four non inclusive
because we only have four directions, then
add the Row direction to the current row to
make
our our
the variable representing the new row, and
then add the column direction to the current
column to make cc the new column position.
So the new position on the grid, our comma
cc is an adjacent cell. However, it might
not be an adjacent cell if we're on the border
of the grid, and the new position is out of
bounds. So we check that the new coordinate
is within our grid by making sure that the
new row column position is greater than or
equal to zero and doesn't exceed the number
of rows and columns of our grid respectively.
So if those two checks pass, then we know
that the new position r r comma CC, is a neighboring
cell of our current position where the red
ball was our car seat. So in summary, this
technique is really nice, really easy to code
and actually naturally extends to higher dimensions.
So let's solve a shortest path problem on
a grid using the direct Shin vector technique
we just learned about. So here's an abridged
problem statement that you might encounter
during an interview or in a programming competition.
And it goes as follows suppose you're trapped
inside a 2d dungeon and need to find the quickest
way out. The dungeon is composed of unit cubes,
which may or may not be filled with a rock.
It takes one minute to move one unit north,
south, east, or west, you cannot move diagonally
and the maze is surrounded by solid rock on
all sides. This problem statement is an easier
version of the problem Dungeon Master on the
caddis online judge see the problem link in
the description. The dungeon is a grid of
size R by C and you start at the node with
an S character. And there's an exit at the
cell with an IE a cell full of rock is indicated
by a pound sign or a hashtag, and empty cells
are represented using a.in. This particular
setup it's possible to escape the dungeon
using this particular route highlighted in
green. Remember that we want the shortest
path to escape dungeon, not just any path,
our approach is going to be to do a breadth
first search from the start node until we
reach the end node and count the number of
cells we traverse during that process. However,
it might not be possible to exit the dungeon
if we cannot reach the exit, so we'll have
to be mindful of that. So like in any breadth
first search, we need to start by visiting
our start node and adding it to the queue.
Assuming we've already found the coordinate
of our starting node within the grid we've
added to the queue. Then we visit the adjacent
unvisited neighbors and add them to the queue
as well. And continue this process all the
while avoiding adding rock cells to the queue.
So I'll let the animation play And meanwhile,
try and predict which cells will be visited
next. All right, after we find our end cell,
we know how many steps it takes to get from
the start to the end. Notice that we didn't
even visit all the cells in the grid. The
bottom right cell is still unvisited, so it's
possible that we terminate early. If you're
interested in actually finding the path itself
rather than just the number of steps it takes
to escape the dungeon, then you'll need to
keep track of the previously visited node
for each node. Go in and re watch the last
video. If you need a refresher on how to do
that. I want to talk a little bit about the
way we are representing states in our breadth
first search. So far, we have been storing
the next x y position in the queue as an XY
pair. This works well but requires an array
or an object wrapper to store the coordinate
values. In practice, this can require a lot
of packing and unpacking of values to and
from our queue. Let's look at an alternative
approach which also scales well in higher
dimensions, and in my opinion requires less
setup and effort. So the alternative approach
I'm suggesting is to use one cue for each
dimension. So in a three dimensional grid,
you would have one q for each of the x, y
and z dimensions. Suppose In queueing the
coordinate x one y one Zed one, then we would
simply place each coordinate in their respective
queues. So the x coordinate goes in the x
q, the y goes in its own y, q, and so on.
As we need to keep in queueing different positions,
we simply keep filling up these queues this
way. This contrasts the approach of simply
having one queue with each of the components
packed away inside an object. The one thing
we have to be mindful about, however, is that
when we either end keyword dq elements, you
need to mq and dq elements from each of the
queues all at the same time. So when I dq
or pull elements from the queue, I need to
remove an element from each of these queues.
I prefer this representation when working
with multi dimensional coordinates, which
is why I want to share it, try it out and
see if it works for you. So now that we have
all the knowledge we need, we can solve the
dungeon problem, let's look at some pseudocode.
Assume that I have already read in the input
matrix into memory and did some pre processing
to find the coordinate of the starting node.
The first two variables are the constants
R and C the number of rows and columns in
the input matrix following this is m, the
input character matrix of size R by C. Next
are two variables s, r and s
see
the row column position of the starting node.
We'll need this to start our breadth first
search our Q and c q r to Q data structures
that represent the row Q and the column q
will be enqueuing and D queuing elements from
during the breadth first search. This next
set of variables is to keep track of the number
of steps taken to reach the exit move count
will actually track the number of steps taken
nodes left in layered tracks how many nodes
we need to dq before taking a step and nodes
in next layer tracks how many nodes we added
in the breadth first search expansion so that
we can update nodes left and layer accordingly.
In the next iteration, this will make more
sense soon reached and tracks whether or not
we have reached the N cell marked with an
E. We're also going to make use of a visited
matrix the same size as the input grid to
track whether or not a cell has been visited
since we do not want to visit a cell multiple
times. And lastly, I defined the north south,
east and west direction vectors. To solve
the dungeon problem. This is all the code
we'll need to execute our breadth first search
and reach the exit. The first thing I do is
add the start cells row and column values
to the row Q and column Q, then don't forget
to mark the start cell as visited because
we don't want to go there again, we're not
done our breadth first search until both of
our cues are empty. I checked the size of
the row q is greater than zero, but you can
also check the size of the column q is greater
than zero since their sizes should always
be in sync. Then since I know the queues aren't
empty, I can dq the current position from
the queues as the row position R and the column
position C, then I check if we've reached
the dungeon exit by checking if the current
character in the grid is an eat. If it is
then mark that we've reached the exit and
break out early. Otherwise, we're not done
exploring and we want to add all the valid
neighbors of the current node to the queue,
I wrote a function called explore neighbors
they'll do just that. Let's have a look. Here
we are inside the Explore neighbors method.
This is where we'll be using the direction
vector technique we learned about earlier.
Since cells have four directions we care about
north south, east and west I loop I from zero
to four non inclusive, compute the new coordinate
r comma CC by adding the direction vector
to the current position, make sure the new
position is actually within the grid because
we could end up with positions like zero comma
minus one which is out of bounds. Even if
the new position is within the grid that does
not guarantee that is a valid position. The
position might already have been visited previously,
or it could be a blocked off cell such as
a cell that isn't traversable and full of
rock. If both of those conditions aren't true
then we can en que the new position to visit
it later. When en que a new position we are
going to visit Make sure to mark it as visited
now, so that it doesn't get added to the queue
multiple times in the future. Also increment
the number of nodes in the next layer, which
we'll be needing shortly. This next block
of code is used to track the number of steps
we took. Getting to the dungeon exit. Every
time we finish a layer of nodes, we increment
the number of steps taken, we know how many
nodes are in each layer. Because we kept track
of that in the Explore neighbors method. When
the number of nodes in the current layer reaches
zero, we know to increment the move count.
At the end, if we are able to reach the exit,
we return the move count, otherwise, we return
minus one to indicate that the dungeon exit
was not reached. So in summary, things we
learned in this video are how to represent
a grid as an adjacency list and an adjacency
matrix, how to use direction vectors to visit
neighboring cells, we explored an alternative
way of representing multi dimensional coordinates
with multiple queues. And lastly, we looked
at how to use a breadth first search on a
grid to find the shortest path between two
cells. Today's topic is topological sort,
also called
top source for short, we're going to discuss
what is top sort where it's used, and how
to find a topological ordering with some animation.
The motivation for top sort is that many real
world situations can be modeled as some graph
of nodes, and directed edges where some events
have to occur before others. Some simple examples
include school class prerequisites, program
dependencies, event scheduling, assembly,
instruction ordering, and much, much more.
Let's begin with an example. Suppose you're
a university student, and you really want
to take class Ah, well, before you can enroll
in class H, you must first take classes D
and E. But before taking Class D, you must
also take classes A and B which have no prerequisites.
So in some sense, there appears to be an ordering
on the nodes of the graph. If we needed to
take all the classes, the top sort algorithm
would be capable of telling us the order in
which we should enroll in classes, such that
we never enroll in a course, which we do not
have prerequisites for another canonical example
of an application of top sort is for program
build dependencies. A program cannot be built
unless all its dependencies are first built.
For example, consider this graph where each
node represents a program. And the edges represent
that one program depends on another to run.
Well, if we're trying to build program j on
the right hand side, then we must first build
program H and G. But to build those we also
need EMF. But to build those we also need
and so on. The idea is to first build the
programs without dependencies and then move
on with from there. How do we find a valid
ordering in which to build all the programs?
Well, this is where top sword comes into play.
One possible ordering might be to start by
building a then building C, B, the F, E, G,
H, and then J. Notice that there are unused
dependencies in this case, and that will happen
from time to time which is fine. So in conclusion,
top sort is an algorithm which will give us
a topological ordering. On a directed graph.
A topological ordering is an ordering of nodes
for which each edge from node A to node B.
node A appears before node B in the ordering.
If it helps, this is just a fancy way of saying
that we can align all the nodes in that line
and have all the edges pointing to the right.
An important note to make is that topological
orderings are not unique. As you can imagine
there are multiple valid ways to enroll in
courses, such that you can still graduate
or to compile a program and its dependencies
in a different order. Than you previously
did. Sadly, not every type of graph has a
topological ordering. For example, any graph
with a directed cycle cannot have a valid
ordering. Well think of why this might be
true. There cannot be an order if there is
a cyclic dependency. Since there was nowhere
to start, every node in a cycle depends on
another. So any graph with a directed cycle
is therefore forbidden. The only graphs that
have valid topological orderings are called
directed a cyclic graphs, that is grass directed
edges and no cycles. So a natural question
to ask is, how do I verify that my graph does
not contain a directed cycle? One method is
to use Tarzan's strongly connected component
algorithm which can detect these cycles. Another
neat thing definitely worth mentioning is
that every tree has a topological ordering.
Since by definition, trees do not have any
cycles.
and easy way to find a topological ordering
with trees is to iteratively pick off the
leaf nodes. It is like you're cherry picking
from the bottom it doesn't matter the order
you do it. Once the root of a subtree has
all grayed out children, then it becomes available.
This procedure continues until there are no
more nodes left. So we know how it works with
trees. But how about general directed a cyclic
graphs? Well, the algorithm is also simple,
just repeat the following steps. First finding
unvisited node, it doesn't matter which from
this node, do a depth first search exploring
only reachable unvisited nodes. On the recursive
callback, add the current node to the topological
ordering in reverse order. And that's it.
Let's do an example. And things will become
much clearer. Here's a directed acyclic graph
that we want to find one of many topological
orderings for as the algorithm executes, I'll
be keeping track of the call stack on the
left hand side. And in case you're curious,
I will also be posting the current topological
ordering at the bottom of the screen. The
first step is going to be to pick in an visited
note, I'm going to pick node h arbitrarily.
Now we do a depth first search out towards
from H and all possible directions exploring
where we can. Let's go to node j. Now that
I might know j, I'm going to keep exploring.
And so let's go to
m.
Now that we're at, there's nowhere left to
go so we backtrack and add as last element
to the topological
ordering
still at j and we still need to explore L.
Now we're at L. Now backtrack because there's
nowhere left to go. Also backtrack j and add
it to the ordering. Notice that the stack
frames getting popped off the call stack as
I recurse. Now we're at h and we still need
to visit node i. So now we're at node i and
from node i, we try and visit node L. But
then we figure out that note L is already
visited so we don't go there, backtrack, backtrack,
again add AI to the ordering and mark it as
explored. And finally we're back at h
as you saw
selecting a random unvisited node made us
visit a subsection of the graph. We continue
this process until all nodes are visited.
The next node I'm going to randomly pick is
going to be node E in the interest of time
and simplicity. I will let the animation run
and you can follow along. Note that if you
try and predict the next few values and topological
ordering, he may not get the same values as
me. Because topological orderings are not
unique. However, this does not mean you are
incorrect. All right, I will let the animation
play and try and follow along
So that's it for that sub section of the graph.
The next note I'm going to pick is going to
be node C to visit. So we start node C and
explore this sub section of the graph.
Now that all nodes are visited, we have a
valid topological ordering at the bottom of
the screen. So now that we understand how
the algorithm works, what does the code actually
look like? Here's some pseudocode. For top
sort. Let's walk through it real quick. The
first thing I do as I get the number of nodes
from the graph, which I assume is passed in
as an adjacency list from the function, that
I declare an array called v short for visited,
which tracks whether a node has been visited
or not. The next array called orderings, is
the result that we'll be returning from this
function. This is equivalent to the ordering
at the bottom of the screen. In the last slides
associated with the orderings array is the
index i, which tracks the insertion position
of the next element the topological ordering.
As you have been seeing in the slides, we
insert elements backwards, which is why I
start at n minus one. Next, we're ready to
enter a for loop to iterate over all the nodes
in our graph. The loop variable called at
tracks the ID of the node we're currently
processing. I then check if we're on a visit
and node, because those are the only ones
we care about. Then I started depth first
search, notice that before I do, I initialize
an array called visited nodes, which I pass
into the depth first search method to add
nodes as we find them. Then, after that's
done, after the depth first search is finished,
I look at the notes we found in our visited
nodes array and then add them to the ordering.
Now the last bit we need to look at is the
depth first search method itself. The depth
first search method is very simple. All I
do is I mark the node we're currently at to
be visited. Then for each edge going outwards
from the node we're at, I make sure the destination
node is visited, then call the method again.
But this time on the destination node. On
the callback when the method returns. This
is when we're stuck and need to backtrack.
So this is where I add the current node to
the visited nodes array, which is essentially
the output for this method. Back to the top
sorting method, now that we understand how
the top sort algorithm works, there's a neat
optimization we can do to prove the performance
in terms of both time and space. Notice that
every time we enter the inner if statement
block, we need to allocate memory for an array,
that array gets filled with node IDs and then
we iterate over them to place them inside
the orderings array. But how about we just
directly insert found node inside the orderings
array, instead of allocating memory and doing
this additional work? Well, that's exactly
what we're going to do. Here I got rid of
the unnecessary array and modify the depth
for search method to return the next valid
insertion position in the orderings array.
Now we need to pass in the index i and the
orderings array so that it can be filled directly
inside the depth first search method inside
the new depth first search method, one thing
that changed is that now we have a return
value, and we're passing in some additional
variables. Notice that instead of adding the
current node to the visit and notes array
as we were doing before, now, we simply insert
that note directly inside the orderings array.
The last thing to do is to return i minus
one, because the index of the current insertion
position is no longer index i index i minus
one. So related to the topic of topological
orderings is the topic of shortest and longest
path. On directed a cyclic graphs, recall
that a directed acyclic graph is a graph with
directed edges and no cycles. By definition,
this means that all trees are automatically
directed acyclic graphs, since they do not
contain any cycles. Here is a graph. My question
to you is, is this graph a directed acyclic
graph? And the answer is yes. But what about
this structure? I'll give you a moment to
think about it.
The answer is no. Because this graph has undirected
edges as opposed to directed edges. The graph
may be a tree, but directed edges are a requirement
for a directed acyclic graph. What's really
great about working with directed acyclic
graphs is that the single source shortest
path problem can be solved very efficiently.
In fact, in linear time, the next fastest
single source shortest path algorithm is dextrous
algorithm, which may not work if there are
negative edge weights. This algorithm I'm
about to show you is faster and doesn't care
about positive or negative edge weights. The
essence of the algorithm is that it finds
a topological ordering on the graph using
the top sort algorithm we saw in the last
video, and processes each node sequentially
to get the shortest path by relaxing each
edge as it is seen. Relaxing edge simply means
updating to a better value if a shorter path
can be obtained using the current edge. Suppose
this is the graph we're working with, you
can verify that it is in fact a directed acyclic
graph. What we wish to do is find the shortest
path from node A to all other nodes in the
graph. In order to do this, the first thing
we'll want to do is generate a topological
ordering of the nodes of this graph. Using
the top sort algorithm. Below I have selected
and arbitrary topological ordering, which
is the order we will process the nodes in
this graph. I'm also displaying the current
best distance to each node and bond the screen,
which are all currently set to infinity, the
first step of the algorithm is to set the
distance to the starting node to be zero.
In this case, since a is the starting node,
its initial distance is zero, because we're
already there. From a we want to visit all
reachable nodes starting with node B, and
update the value to be if it is better than
what was already there. This is the edge relaxation
step of the algorithm, we noticed that
a value of three
is better than infinity, so we update the
best value of b to be three, then the best
value to see to be six. And now we've explored
of his edges and want to move on to the next
node node topological ordering which is B
and explore all of its edges. So the first
edge brings us to node E and we update its
best value to 14. Because the best value add
node B was three plus the edge weight to get
e was 11 for a total of 14. Notice that edges
get grayed out as they're being processed.
Next, we update the best value to D to B seven.
Now, we've reached the first instance where
it is best and not to update the value of
the destination node, since a better path
already exists to where we want to update.
Now we move on to the next known or topological
ordering and keep repeating the same steps
where we explore all the nodes trying to relax
each edge and then move on to the next node
and the topological ordering. If we repeatedly
do this the right way the bottom of the screen
will contain the shortest path from node A
to each node. I will let the animation play
and you can try and determine the shortest
path to all the remaining nodes which have
not yet been processed. Okay, we're done processing
all the nodes and know the shortest distance
to every note, let's verify our algorithm
computed the correct values by finding the
shortest path to node H. Indeed, if we look
at the path and some of the values along the
edges, you will find that they do indeed sum
up to 11, which is the shortest path in our
array for node H. There's a similar problem
to the shortest path problem, which is finding
the longest path in the graph. This problem
is actually NP hard on general graphs, but
can actually be solved in linear time on a
directed acyclic graph. The trick is going
to be to multiply each edge by minus one,
find the shortest path, and then multiply
all the edge values by minus one again, to
take the previous graph, we had to find the
longest path, simply negate all the edges,
then find the shortest path and multiply the
answer by minus one. And there we go. That's
all you need to do. Okay, now let's have a
look at some source code, you can find the
code I'm about to show you on github@github.com.
Slash William is that slash algorithms. Here
I am on GitHub, and we're looking at some
code for the shortest path on a directed acyclic
graph. Here's our method directed acyclic
graphs shortest path, and it returns the distance
to each node, stored in an integer array.
For some starting node, and as input, we give
it the graph we're working with as an adjacency
list. Of course, the starting node and lastly,
the number of nodes in our graph. So what
we do is find the topological ordering for
our nodes, I covered this in the last video,
then initialize our distance array, and then
set the starting nodes distance to be zero.
And all we do is we loop through each node,
starting at the first node, looking at what
our node index is Four Tops or so this is
the first node we need to visit and then check
if that node is not equal to No, and then
grab all the edges for that node, so we reach
in our graph, and then pull out all the edges
for the node index.
Make sure there actually are some edges. And
then for each edge, in the edges that we got,
which were the adjacent edges, then all we
do is the relaxation step, which is just this.
So we compute the new distance. So this is
the distance to the node, we're currently
at plus the edge weight. So this is like the
competing distance the distance we were trying
to improve upon, then we check, okay, has
there ever been a distance set to where we
want to go? This is basically the equivalent
of infinity. And if so then we just want to
give the new distance. Otherwise, we're going
to take the minimum of the distance that's
already there, and our new competing distance,
which is
this over here, and then we just do this over
and over again, processing nodes and topological
order, because we're pulling them out of the
top sorted array. And at the end, we just
return that distance array. And we can get
the distance from our starting node to any
other node in the graph, just through a lookup
and this array. And guys, this is super simple
algorithm. And that's all there is to shortest
paths on directed acyclic graphs. Today, we're
going to tackle Dykstra shortest path algorithm.
This is one of the most important algorithms
in graph theory for finding the shortest path
on a graph. So without further ado, let's
dive right in. The first thing to mention
about Dykstra algorithm is that it is a single
source shortest path algorithm for graphs.
This means that at the beginning of the algorithm
you need Specify a starting node to indicate
a relative starting point for the algorithm.
Once you specify the starting node and execute
the algorithm, Dykstra can tell you the shortest
path between that node and all other nodes
in your graph, which is pretty sweet. So depending
on how you implement your Dykstra s and what
data structures you use, the time complexity
is typically big O of E log V, which is fairly
competitive against other shortest path algorithms
we see around. However, before we go crazy,
trying to find shortest paths on various graphs,
you need to know which graphs we are allowed
to run dextrous algorithm on the one main
constraint for Dykstra is that all edges of
the graph need to have a non negative edge
weight. This constraint is imposed to ensure
that once a node has been visited, it's optimal
distance from the story node cannot be improved
any further by finding a shorter path by taking
edge with a negative weight. This property
is especially important because it enables
the extras algorithm to act in a greedy manner
by always selecting the next most promising
note. For this slide deck. My goal is to help
you understand how to implement dichos algorithm
and also how to implement it very efficiently.
We're going to start by looking at the lazy
implementation because it's by far the most
common and then we'll look at the eager implementation
of Dykstra has algorithm which uses an indexed
priority queue alongside the decrease key
operation. And lastly, I want to briefly mention
how we can use other types of heaps in particular
the D airy heap to further boost performance
of the algorithm. At a high level, these are
the steps required in executing Dykstra algorithm.
Note that there are two bits of information
we'll need. The first is an array called dist
that keeps track of the shortest distance
to every node from the start node. Initially,
this array can be populated with the value
of positive infinity, except for the index
of the starting node, which should be initialized
to zero. Additionally, we'll also need to
maintain a priority queue of key value pairs,
the key value pairs will be node index distance
pairs, which tells us which node to visit
next, based on a minimum sorted value. At
the start of the algorithm, we will begin
by inserting the key value pair s comma zero
into the priority queue, then we'll loop while
the priority queue is not empty, pulling out
the next most promising node index distance
pair as we go. After that, for each node we
visit, we will want to iterate over all the
outwards edges and relax each edge appending
a new node index distance key value pair to
the priority queue upon every successful relaxation.
We do this until our priority queue is empty,
at which point the shortest distance to each
node will be stored in the disk array we are
maintaining. So that explanation may have
sounded a little bit abstract. Now let's look
at an example with some animation to put all
the pieces together. In all these examples,
assume node zero is always the starting node.
Although any node is perfectly fine. boxed
in red is the distance I will be using it
to track the optimal distance from the start
node to every node in the graph. In the beginning,
the distance to every node is initialized
to have the value of positive infinity. Since
we assume that every node is unreachable if
at the end of the algorithm, there's still
a value of infinity at a certain index, then
we know that that node is unreachable. On
the right I will be maintaining key value
pairs corresponding to a nodes index and the
best distance to get to that node. This priority
queue will tell us which node we should visit
next, based on which key value pair has the
lowest value. Internally priority queues are
usually implemented as heaps, but I'm not
going to show that visualization here. To
start with assign a distance of zero to the
start nodes index, which is index zero in
the distance array. Also insert the key value
pair zero comma zero into the priority queue
to indicate that we intend on visiting node
zero with a best distance of zero, then the
algorithm actually starts and we look inside
the priority queue for the first time and
we discover that we should visit node zero
from node zero we can visit node one by using
the edge with a cost of four. This gives us
a best distance of four so we can update the
best distance from infinity to four and the
dist array. Also add this information to the
priority queue. Next, we can visit node two
from node zero Just like the last note, we
can update the optimal distance to reach no
to from infinity to one. Additionally, add
that node to is reachable with a distance
of one to the priority queue. So that concludes
visiting all the edges for node zero. To decide
which node we should visit next day shows
always selects the next most promising node
in the priority queue. To do this, simply
pull the next best key value pair from the
priority queue. node two is the next most
promising node because it has a distance of
one from the start node, while node one has
a greater value of four. from node two, if
we take the upwards edge, we can improve the
best distance to node one by taking the current
best distance from node two, which is one
plus the edge cost of two to get to node one
for a total cost of three, this is better
than the previous value of four. For every
time we find a better distance like this,
we insert that information into the priority
queue, then we improve the best distance to
node three to be six.
The next most promising node is node one,
we can improve the best distance to node three
by taking the edge from node one to node three
with a cost of one. The next most promising
node is node one with value four, but we have
already found a better route to get to node
one. Since the disk array at index one has
a value of three. Therefore we can ignore
this entry in the priority queue. Having these
duplicate key entries in the priority queue
is what constitutes to making this implementation
of Dykstra is the lazy implementation because
we leisurely delete outdated key value pairs.
Next up is no three, update the best distance
to node four to be seven. We already found
a better route to node three, so skip this
entry in the priority queue. Finally, visit
node four. And that's all for the lazy implementation
of dynatrace. There are only a few moving
parts, but enlarge the only things to really
keep track of is the distance array, which
contains the best distance so far from the
start node to every other node and the priority
queue which tells us which node we should
visit next, based on the best value found
so far. Let's look at some pseudocode. For
how this works. I'll be covering the real
source code in the next video. For those interested,
this pseudocode runs a Shor's algorithm from
a start node and returns the distance array
which tells us the shortest distance to every
node in the graph. However, it will not tell
you which sequence of edges to follow. To
achieve that optimal distance, this is something
that we will need to maintain some additional
information for which I will cover as well.
So in terms of the variables we'll need in
the function definition, I specify three things
first is G, the adjacency list of the weighted
graph and the number of nodes in the graph.
And s the index of the start node inside the
function I begin by initializing two arrays
to keep track of the information we'll need
first is a Boolean array I called V is short
for visited which tracks whether node AI has
been visited or not. Then I initialize dist
the distance array which will be the output
of the function make sure you feel the distance
array with positive infinity except for the
start node which should be set to zero after
this initialize a priority queue that will
store the node index best distance pairs sorted
by a minimum distance, you should be able
to use the built in priority queue in whatever
programming language you're using. Remember
to insert the start nodes index paired with
a distance of zero into the priority queue
to kickstart the algorithm. If you're wondering
why there are two sets of brackets, that's
because the pair x comma zero is meant to
represent a tupple or an object with two values
a key and a value. So while the priority queue
is not empty, remove the next most promising
index minimum distance pair and mark that
node as visited then loop over all the neighbors
of the current node and skip visited neighbors
so that we don't visit them again. Then simply
perform the edge relaxation operation. First,
compute the distance to the new node which
is calculated by adding the best distance
from the start node to the current node which
is found the distance array plus the edge
cost of getting to the next node. Once you
know that compare it against the best distance
for the next node I update the value if it's
better. Then finally insert a new key value
pair inside the priority queue. So we visit
that node in the future. So in practice most
standard priority queues do not support a
decreased key operation for the built in barbecue.
You can think of a decreased key operation
as an operation which updates the value of
a key and the party cue. A way to get around
this is to add a new note index best distance
pair every time we need to update the distance
to a node. As a result, it's possible though
have duplicate node indices in the priority
queue like we saw in the animation. This is
not ideal. But inserting a new key value pair
in logarithmic time is much faster than searching
for the key, we want to update in the priority
queue, which actually takes linear time. Yes,
searching for a key in a priority queue takes
linear time because the heap is sorted by
the keys values, not the keys themselves.
So effectively, it's like searching in an
unordered list for a particular element.
And neat optimization we can do which ignores
stale, outdated index min distance pairs in
our priority queue is to skip them immediately.
As we pull them from the priority queue. We
can do this by checking if the value in the
distance array is better than the value in
the priority queue. And if it is, then we
know we have already found a better path routing
through other nodes before we got to processing
this note, I'll let that sink in for a little
bit. But this is definitely a neat optimization
you'll want to keep around. Now I want to
talk about finding the shortest path itself
and not just the shortest distance to get
there. And to do that, we'll need to keep
track of some additional information. In particular,
we'll want to keep track of the index of the
previous node we took to get to the current
node. The way to do this is to maintain a
previous array I call prev. In this slide,
this array tracks the index of the node you
took to get to node I initially the previous
array should be filled with a sentinel value
such as now or minus one. But as you perform
edge relaxation operations, you want to update
the previous array to say that the node you're
going to came from the node you're currently
at, then at the end instead of returning the
distance right also return the previous array
which we will use soon. In another method
of perhaps called find shortest path provide
all the same arguments with the addition of
the end node index and execute Dykstra has
to obtain the distance array in the previous
array with these two bits of information,
we can reconstruct the shortest path first
check that the end node is reachable by checking
that its value in the distance array is not
infinity, then start at the end node and loop
backwards through the previous array until
you make it back the start node. You know
you made it back to the start node when the
value of null is reached. Since the start
node does not have a parent node index from
which came from the resulting path of node
indices to follow for the shortest path from
the start node to the end node will be in
a reverse order because we started at the
end node and worked backwards. Therefore,
we want to make sure we reverse this array
before returning the result.
Now I want to talk about a few optimizations
we can use to make dexterous algorithm more
efficient. Sometimes we know the index of
our destination node and don't necessarily
need to know the optimal distance to every
node in the graph, just that one particular
node. So the question is do we still have
to visit every node in the graph just to figure
out the distance of that one particular node
we want to get to? The answer is yes, we do.
But only in the worst case, which depending
on your graph can be somewhat rare the key
realization will need to make is that it is
possible to stop early once we have finished
visiting the destination node. The main idea
for stopping early is that tech shows algorithm
processes each next most promising node in
order. So if the destination node has already
been visited, its shortest distance will not
change as more future nodes are visited. In
terms of code, all we have to do to stop early
is check if the current node index is the
end node and return early. This can prove
to be a very substantial speed up depending
on how early you encounter the end node while
processing the graph. Our current implementation
of dices is what we call the lazy implementation
because it inserts duplicate key value pairs
and leisurely deletes them. This is done because
it's more efficient to insert a new key value
pair in logarithmic time into the priority
queue than it is to update an existing keys
value in linear time. The lazy approach works
but it is inefficient for dense graphs because
we end up with all these stale outdated key
value appears in our priority queue. The eager
version of dank shows aims to solve this by
avoiding duplicate key value pairs and supporting
efficient value updates in logarithmic time
using an indexed priority queue. And index
priority queue is a priority queue variant
which allows access to key value pairs within
the priority queue in constant time, and updates
in the log time if you're using a binary heap.
This type of priority queue is extremely useful
in many applications, and I highly recommend
you watch my video on the index priority queue
to become enlightened. I'll make sure I leave
a link in the description. But in the meantime,
we'll just assume that we have access to an
indexed priority queue. Now we're going to
take a look at the eager version of dichos
algorithm where we don't have duplicate keys
and priority queue. So to start with, assign
a distance of zero to the start node at index
zero in the distance array. Also insert the
key value pairs zero comma zero into the priority
queue to indicate that we intend on visiting
node zero with a best distance of zero, then
the algorithm starts and we look inside the
priority queue for the first time and we discover
we should visit node zero. from node zero,
we can visit node one by taking the edge with
cost five, this gives us a distance of five
so we update the best distance from infinity
to five and the distance array also add this
information to the priority queue. Next, we
can visit node two node zero just like the
last node, we can update the optimal distance
to reach node two from infinity to one. Additionally
add node two to the priority queue with a
distance of one. That includes visiting all
the edges for node zero to decide which node
to visit next dextra selects the next most
promising node in the priority queue. So pull
the next best key value pair from the priority
queue. node two is that next most promising
node because it has a distance of one from
the start node, which is better than five.
from node two, we can take the sideways edge
to improve the best distance to node four
to be 13 by taking the current best distance
from node two, which is one plus the edge
cost of 12. To get to node four, for a total
cost of 13. We can update the best distance
to node one by taking the upwards edge from
node to notice that I did not insert a new
key value pair with a value of one comma four
inside the party queue, but rather simply
updated the existing value in the party queue
from five to four. This is the main difference
between the lazy and the eager version.
The next most promising node is node one.
When taking the downwards edge from node one
to node two would discover that node two has
already been visited. So we cannot improve
it's already best distance. We also cannot
improve the best distance note form by taking
the diagonal downwards edge since the total
cost of 24 outweighs the best distance of
13, which is already known for that note,
however, we can improve the best distance
node three by taking the edge from node one
to node three with a cost of three. I'll let
the animation play. And as it does try and
predict what the next move for the algorithm
will be.
So that's the ingar version of Dykstra algorithm,
which I would say is the more proper way of
implementing texturas algorithm. Now let's
look at some pseudocode and see what needs
to change. First, notice that we're using
an indexed priority queue instead of a regular
priority queue. Also, notice that we no longer
need to wrap our key value pairs as tuples
in an object because index partly queues have
first class support for key value pairs, as
opposed to a priority queue, which you would
find in your programming languages standard
library. The other thing that needs to change
is how we insert key value pairs into the
queue. If the key or note index does not yet
exist in the index primary queue inserted
otherwise invoke the decrease key operation
to update the best distance to that node in
pirna queue. The operation is called decrease
key instead of update because it only updates
the value if it is strictly less than the
current value in the priority queue. All right,
we've looked at several Dykstra optimizations
already, but there's one key last optimization
I want to talk about and that is is improving
the heap we're using. Currently, we're probably
using an indexed binary heap for our priority
queue. But we can do better. The thing to
notice is that when executing dextrose, there
are a lot more update operations, especially
on dense graphs than there are removal operations.
A dare heap is a heap variant in which each
node has at most D children instead of two,
this speeds up the decrease key operation
at the expense of more costly removals. So
if we look at an example, real quick, this
is a dairy heap with D equals four. Suppose
we want to perform an update operation, say
we want to perform decreased key for node
at index six with a value of one, then we
can do the update. And then we reposition
the key value pair inside the heap. So we
bubble it up, and we bubble it up again. And
now it's in the correct position. So that
only took a total of two operations. While
in contrast, suppose we want to remove the
root node, then we swap it with the bottom
right node. And then we need to reposition
the purple node so that it's in position.
So we need to look at all the children find
the one with the least value and swap it and
the purple node is still not in its correct
position. So again, we need to look at all
the children find the one the smallest value
and swapping. So that took a total of eight
operations, which is clearly more expensive.
But remember, there are a lot more decreased
key operations and Dykstra than there are
removals. So this might be beneficial overall.
So the question then becomes what is the optimal
dairy heap degree actually used to maximize
the performance of Dec Shor's algorithm? And
the answer in general is that the value of
d should be equal to the number of edges divided
by the number of nodes. This is the best degree
to use the balance removals against decreased
key operations. In turn, This improves Dykstra
time complexity to be a big O of E times log
base e divided by V of V, which is better,
especially for dense graphs, which have a
lot of decreased key operations. The last
thing I want to mention is the current state
of the art when it comes to choosing the right
heat for dextrose algorithm. And right now,
the best heap we know of is the Fibonacci
heap, which gives Dykstra has algorithm Believe
it or not a time complexity of big O of E
plus v log V, which is extremely fast. However,
in practice, the Fibonacci heap is very difficult
to implement, and also has a large constant
amortized overhead. So it makes them slightly
impractical in practice, because your graph
has to be very large, or you to see the benefit.
I have yet to implement one of these. So I
cannot say whether they're that good, but
this is just what I've read from other sources.
Today we're going to have a look at some source
code for Dykstra is shortest path algorithm.
All right, here we are in the source code
for Dec shows shortest path algorithm implemented
in the Java programming language, let's have
a quick run through. So in this class, I define
an edge class which represents a directed
edge, you'll notice that this directed edge
has a certain cost of taking this edge. And
it also has a destination node, which I call
to the node which this edge comes from will
be implicitly represented in our adjacency
list. So we don't need to take care of that.
So when you go and create an instance of this
class, you need to specify the number of nodes
that are going to be in this graph. And that's
the variable n. Once you know the number of
nodes in your graph, you can go ahead and
create an empty graph, this simply initializes
our adjacency lists. So as you see here, I
create an empty ArrayList with n nodes. And
then for each position in the list, I create
another list. So this is just an empty recency
list. This will help us add edges to our graph,
which you can do by calling this add edge
method. So when you want to add an edge, the
graph you specify the node, the edge starts
at the node the edge ends at and the cost
of taking that edge. Remember that the cost
of taking edge cannot be a negative value.
All right, and then there's the just this
convenience method to retrieve the constructed
graph. If ever you want to have a look at
that, then here comes the interesting method,
which actually executes Dykstra is shortest
path algorithm. So in this implementation,
I provide a start node and the end node. This
means we're going to try and go from a starting
node index to an end node index. Note that
we can also modify dextrose to give us the
shortest distance to every node and not just
a specific end node. So there is a way we
can just remove this parameter, we don't really
need it. But providing the end node allows
us to do a small optimization, which is to
stop early if we know we've reached that end
node. So let's keep it in for now. So in the
slides, in the last video, I mentioned that
we can use an indexed priority queue to speed
up dexterous algorithm. And this is exactly
what I'm doing below, I have an implementation
of a min index Dr. heap, which allows us to
avoid duplicate nodes in our priority queue,
I won't be going over the details of the min
indexed theory per se, because I already have
another video on that in my data structure
series, I'll make sure to have a link to that
in case you want to check it out. But to construct
a min index theory heap, I compute the degree
of how many children each node should have
in the heap by dividing the edge count by
the number of nodes. And finally, inserting
that the optimal distance to the start node
at the beginning of the algorithm has a distance
of zero, which makes sense, then I just initialize
a few arrays. So this is the distance array,
which is going to keep track the minimum distance
to each node. So initially, I fill that with
a value of positive infinity, and I set that
optimal distance to the start node has a value
of zero, perfect. And then these are just
two supporting arrays that track whether node
II has been visited. And this prep array is
going to be used to reconstruct the shortest
path should we ever need to Alright, let's
look at this while loop which contains the
bulk of the Dykstra algorithm implementation.
So while the priority queue is not empty,
we're going to first get the ID of the node
with the shortest distance. And we're also
going to get the minimum value associated
with that node. So while we're at it, we're
going to mark that this node is visited so
that we don't revisit it again in the future,
this line right here, which says that the
min value if the minimum value we got from
the priority queue is greater than the already
optimal distance, and the distance array for
the node we currently pulled out of the queue,
then we can continue this is because we already
found a better path of routing through another
set of nodes. Before we got to processing
this node, which is fine. The next thing we
want to do is get all the edges going outwards
from this node. So we can reach into our adjacency
list and get all the edges coming out of the
current node, then we check if the node this
edge wants to go to has already been visited,
then we can skip that we don't want to revisit
an already visited node, then we compute the
new distance of going from the current node
to the destination node. And we do this by
reaching into the distance array grabbing
the already optimal distance for that node
and adding the edge cost then we try and relax
the edge. So we check if the new distance
is better than the distance already in the
distance array at the node we want to go to
remember that originally, all the indices
in the distance array are set to positive
infinity. So the first time we visit any node,
this condition will always be true, then we
just do some housekeeping stuff. So Mark that
the optimal distance to get to a certain node
came from the current node we're at and also
update the distance arrayed have the new optimal
distance, then we update our index priority
queue. We do this by inserting the cost of
going to a node for the first time or we try
and employ a decrease key operation to update
the current best distance to that node to
be even better than after that loop. We can
check if we've reached our end node and if
we have we can return the optimal distance
to it. So this is the optimization of returning
early Otherwise, if we've reached the end
of the algorithm, and the while loop has terminated
and the priority queue is empty, then return
a positive infinity. The rest of this class
contains the reconstruct path method in the
event that you want to actually reconstruct
the shortest path from the start node to the
end node. And this is pretty straightforward,
simply give it the start node you want to
start at the end node index, then run Dykstra
algorithm, make sure that the end node is
actually reachable from the start node, then
simply loop through the previous array and
reverse the path and return it as simple as
that of all the shortest path algorithms in
graph theory. Bellman Ford is definitely one
of the simplest, yet I struggled as an undergrad
to trying to learn this algorithm, which is
part of the reason I'm making this video.
So what is the Bellman Ford algorithm? In
short, it's a single source shortest path
algorithm. This means that it can find the
shortest path from a starting node to all
other nodes in the graph. As you can imagine,
this is very useful. However, Bellman Ford
is not ideal for single source shortest path
algorithms, because it has a much worse time
complexity than Dykstra his algorithm. In
practice, Bellman Ford runs in a time complexity
proportional to the product of the number
of edges and the number of vertices, while
de show can do much better at around big O
of E plus v log V with a binary heap.
So when would we ever use the Bellman Ford
algorithm? The answer is when Dykstra does
fails. And this can happen when the graph
has negative edge weights. When a graph has
negative edge weights, is possible that a
negative cycle can manifest itself. And when
it does, it is of critical importance that
we are able to detect it. If this happens,
and we're using Dykstra is to find the shortest
path, we'll get stuck in an infinite loop
because the algorithm will keep finding better
and better paths. A neat application of Bellman
Ford and negative cycles is in finance and
economics when performing an arbitrage between
two or more markets, I'm not an expert. But
this is when prices between different markets
are such that you can cycle through each market
with a security, such as a stock or a currency,
and end up with more profit than you originally
started with, essentially getting risk free
gains. Let's look at how negative cycles can
arise. Because this seems important. Here
is a graph I made with directed edges, some
of which are negative. I've labeled our starting
node to be node zero. And our goal would be
to find the distance from zero to every other
node in a single source shortest path context.
But right now, we are only interested in detecting
negative cycles, I will label blue nodes as
regular nodes, red nodes as nodes directly
involved in a negative cycle, and yellow nodes
as those reachable by a negative cycle. One
way negative cycles can emerge is through
negative self loops. What happens is that
once we reach a self loop, we can stay in
that loop for a near infinite amount of time
before exiting. As a result, everywhere reachable
by the cycle has a best cost of negative infinity,
which depending on your problem may either
be good or bad. In this graph, nodes 234 and
five are all reachable by node one. So they
all have a best cost of negative infinity
with regards to the single source shortest
path problem. Let's look at another example.
In this graph, a negative cycle manifests
itself but not as the result of a negative
self loop. Instead, through a cycle of nodes
whose net gain is less than zero. If you add
up the edge values one four and minus six,
attached to the nose, one, two, and three,
the net change is minus one. If we look at
where this cycle can reach, we can see that
the entire right side of the graph is affected.
So hardly any notes are safe from this negative
cycle. Now let's look at the actual steps
involved in the Bellman Ford algorithm. First,
we'll need to define a few variables. Let
e be the number of edges of the graph. Let
v be the number of vertices. let S be the
ID of the starting node. In this case, S is
short for start. And lastly, let D mean an
array of size v that tracks the best distance
from S to each node. The first thing we'll
want to do is set every entry in D to positive
infinity. This is because the distance to
each node is initially unknown, and we have
no idea how far each node is. Next, we'll
want to set the distance to the starting node
to be zero, because we're already there. The
last part of the algorithm is to relax each
edge v minus one times relaxing edge simply
means taking an edge and trying to update
the value from where the edge starts to where
it ends. In terms of code, this is all we
need to do. We loop v minus one times, then
for each edge, we relax the edge. In the relaxing
step, what we do is we look at the value of
where the edge starts at the edge cost and
see if that's better than where we're trying
to go. And if so, update with the shorter
path value. To actually detect negative cycles,
we don't do anything too special, all we do
is run the algorithm a second time, what we're
doing in the second pass is checking for any
nodes that update to a better value than the
known best value. And if they do, then they're
part of a negative cycle, and we want to mark
that node as having a cost of negative infinity.
Let's look at a full example. Here is a graph
I made. Again, we will start on node zero,
and find the shortest path to every other
node. On the right, I have illustrated the
distance array D. Watch the values in this
array change as the algorithm executes. Right
now, all the values in the array are set to
positive infinity, as per the first step of
the algorithm. In the second step, we set
the starting nodes value to zero. Now the
algorithm starts and we are on the first iteration
where we attempt to relax each edge. But before
we continue, I have an important note at the
bottom of the screen, which says that the
edges do not need to be processed in any particular
order, I may process the edges with one ordering,
and you process them with another ordering.
And we may not end up with the same values
on each iteration. But we will get the same
result in the distance right at the very end,
I will highlight the edge currently being
processed in orange and update the distance
array whenever appropriate. Right now, the
best value to node one is five, because a
distance of five is better than a distance
of positive infinity, then nerd who gets its
value updated to 25, because node one had
a value of five from the last term, and the
edge from node one to node two is 20 for a
total of 25. Then a similar thing happens
to node five, and node six as well. By the
way, an edge is dark gray if it has already
been processed in this iteration. Next up,
node three gets its value updated from infinity
to 35. Because the best value in node two,
so far as 25 plus the edge cost of 10 is 35,
then the edge from two to four updates to
a best value of 100. Up next is an interesting
edge because it was able to update node two's
best value from 25 to 20 by taking the value
in Node three, which is currently 35, adding
a weight of minus 15 and giving us a better
value of 20. So this is all the algorithm
does, it processes each edge performing relaxation
operations. I'll let the animation play for
the rest of this iteration.
So iteration one is over and there are eight
more iterations to go. But for simplicity,
I'll just play one more iteration. To give
you an idea of how the algorithm works. We
reset all the edges and start processing the
edge Again, you'll notice that a lot less
updating happens in the distance array this
round, particularly because I unintentionally
selected the edges to be processed in a more
or less optimal way. So that's the end of
the second iteration. If we fast forward to
the end, here's the resulting distance array.
However, we're not done, we still need to
find the negative cycles. Let's execute the
algorithm a second time, same procedure, as
usual, just relax each edge. But when we are
able to relax edge, update the nodes value
to negative infinity Instead, let's process
some edges until something interesting happens.
So it appears that when we went from node
two to node three, we are able to relax the
edge and obtain a better value for note three
than was previously there. So note three is
part of some negative cycle, therefore, I
will mark it as red. Similarly, note four
is connected to a negative cycle, although
indirectly, in the distance table, I do not
distinguish between nodes which are reachable
by a negative cycle, and those which are primarily
involved in one. So those no way to tell them
apart, feel free to add some logic in the
Bellman Ford algorithm. If you need to make
this distinction. Continuing on, new two is
also trapped in the cycle. And the last node
also affected by the cycle is no nine on the
right. Let's finish up with this iteration
by processing the rest of the edges.
So that's it. For the first iteration, there
are another eight iterations to perform. In
this example, we happen to detect all cycles
on the first iteration. But this was a coincidence.
In general, you really need another eight
iterations. This is because you want the negative
cycle minus infinity values to propagate throughout
the graph. The propagation is highly dependent
on the order in which the edges are being
processed. But having v minus one iterations
ensures that this propagation occurs correctly.
Alright, now I want to have a look at some
source code, you can find a link in the description
below. Or you can go to github.com slash William
fiza slash algorithms. Here we are on GitHub
in my algorithms repository. Now if you scroll
down and look for Bellman Ford, under the
graph theory section, you can see that currently
there are two different implementations, one
for graph represented as an edge list, another
one for a graph represented as an adjacency
list. Today, we'll have a look at the edge
lists implementation. So in the edge lists
implementation, first thing I do is I define
a directed edge. And a directed edge simply
consists of an edge that goes from a node
to a node with a certain cost. Next, let's
have a look at the actual algorithm itself.
So from Bellman Ford, what we need is, well,
a graph. So since this is an edge list, we
just pass in all the edges. I'll also need
the number of vertices in the graph and some
starting node. And what we're returning is
that distance array. All right, so let's initialize
the distance array, and then populate it with
this special value double dot positive infinity,
then set dist of start to be zero. And then
just as the pseudocode said, just loop v minus
one time, then for each edge, just to relax
the edge. So that's what we're doing. And
here. Now this second pass of the algorithm
is to detect negative cycles. So run the algorithm
a second time, so loop the minus one times
for each edge, relax the edge, but this time,
instead of updating the edge to a value, we
set the value two double negative infinity.
And this is a special value defined in Java
that represents negative infinity and no matter
what value you add to double dot negative
infinity, it will still be negative infinity.
Unless you add double dot positive infinity
then I think gives you double dot, not a number
or something like that. And that's the entire
algorithm, then we just return the distance
array. If you look in the main method, it
shows you how to actually create a graph,
add some edges, and then run Bellman Ford
and find the distance from a starting node
to all other nodes in the graph. And that
is Bellman Ford. Today's topic is the Floyd
warshall. All pairs shortest path algorithm,
we will be covering how the algorithm works,
how to reconstruct shortest paths, the handling
of negative cycles, followed by some code.
So let's get started. In graph theory, the
Floyd warshall algorithm is an all pairs shortest
path algorithm. This means it can find the
shortest path between all pairs of nodes.
This is very important for many applications
across several fields. The time complexity
to run Floyd warshall is big O of V cubed,
V being the number of vertices in the graph.
This makes the algorithm ideal for graphs
with no more than a couple 100 nodes.
Before we dive too deeply into the Floyd warshall
algorithm, I want to address when you should
and should not use this algorithm. This table
gives information about various types of graphs
and or constraints in the leftmost column,
and the performance or outcome of common shortest
path algorithms. For example, you can see
in the second row that a breadth first search,
and Dykstra is can handle large graphs with
lots of notes, while Bellman Ford and Ford
warshall not so much. I suggest you pause
the video and really go through this table
and make sure you understand why each cell
has the value it does. What I want to highlight
is the rightmost column since we're talking
about the Floyd warshall algorithm, the void
washout algorithm really shines in three places.
And those are on small graphs, solving the
all pair shortest path problem and detecting
negative cycles, you can use the algorithm
for other tasks, but there are likely better
algorithms out there with Floyd warshall.
The optimal way to represent our graph is
with a two dimensional adjacency matrix, which
I will denote as the letter M. The cell m
ij represents the edge weight of going from
node i to node j. So in the image below, I
transformed the graph with nodes A, B, C,
and D into an adjacency matrix on the right.
And important note, I should mention is that
I assumed that the distance from a node to
itself is zero, which is usually the case.
This is why the diagonal has all zero values.
When there is no edge between nodes i and
j, set the value in the matrix M ij. To be
positive infinity. This indicates that two
nodes are not directly connected to each other.
A very important note to make is that if your
programming language doesn't support a special
constant in its standard library for positive
infinity, such that infinity plus infinity
equals infinity, and infinity plus x equals
infinity, then you should avoid using two
to the power of 31 minus one as infinity.
If you do so, then you will likely get integer
overflow, simply use a large constant instead,
as we will see the main idea behind the Floyd
warshall algorithm builds off the notion that
you want to compute all intermediate routes
between two nodes to find the optimal path.
Suppose our adjacency matrix tells us the
distance from a node A to a node B is 11.
Now suppose there exists a third node C, if
the distance from A to C and then C to B is
less than a distance from A to B, then it
is better to go through node C. Again, the
goal is to consider all possible intermediate
paths between triplets of nodes. This means
we can have something like this where the
optimal path from A to B is first going to
C, then going from C to B, but in the process,
we actually route through another node, which
I labeled with a question mark, because we've
already computed the optimal path from C to
B and I know that it involves an intermediate
node. Similarly, we can get through Longer
paths with more intermediate nodes between
A and C and C and B with a smaller cost. We
are also not just limited to one intermediate
node in between A and C, and C and B, we can
have several like in the graph below.
Now the question comes up, how do we actually
compute all intermediate paths? The answer
is we will use dynamic programming to cache
previous optimal solutions. Let dp be a three
dimensional matrix of size n by n by n, which
acts as our memory table, we're going to say
that the cell dp at K IJ in our table gives
us the shortest path from node i to node j,
routing through nodes zero through Kyt. What
we'll do is start by computing k equals zero,
then k equals one, then k equals two and so
on. This gradually builds up the optimal solution
rounding through zero, then all optimal solutions
writing through zero and one, then all optimal
solutions writing through 01, and two, and
etc. Up until we covered all nodes, at which
point we have solved the all pairs shortest
path problem. Let's talk a bit more about
how to populate the DB table. In the beginning,
the optimal solution from i to j is simply
the distance given to us in the adjacency
matrix. So when k equals zero, dp of K ij
is equal to m ij, the value of the edge from
i to j. Otherwise, in general, dp, k, i j,
can be summed up with the following recurrence
relation, I'm going to break it down so that
we can understand all its components. Because
this may look scary to some people. The left
hand side of the recurrence simply says, reuse
the best distance so far from itj, routing
through nodes, zero to k minus one, it's important
to note that the solution using nodes, zero
to k minus one is a partial solution. It is
not the whole picture. This is part of the
dynamic programming aspect of the Floyd warshall
algorithm. The right hand side of the recurrence
finds the best distance from i to j, but routing
through node k, reusing the best solutions
from zero to k minus one. If we analyze the
right side of the min function in English,
it basically says, Go from itk then go from
k to J. Visually, this is what it looks like.
You start at I route through some notes and
get to K and then from K route back to J.
Currently, our algorithm uses big O of V cubed
memory. Since our memo table dp has one dimension
for each of k, i and j. This isn't particularly
great. Notice that we will be looping over
k starting from zero, then one, then two,
and so forth. The important thing to note
here is that previous results build off the
last, since we need the state of k minus one
to compute state. Okay. That being said, it
is possible to compute the solution for K
in place, saving us a dimension of memory
and reducing the space complexity to big O
of v squared. Now we have a new recurrence
relation which no longer involves the K dimension.
This has been replaced by the fact that we're
computing the k plus one solution in place
inside our matrix.
Okay, that's all the theory we need. For now,
let's get our hands dirty and look at some
pseudocode. Below is the function that actually
solves the Floyd warshall algorithm or rather
executes a Floyd warshall algorithm. But before
we get into that, let's look at some of the
variables I have defined in the global or
class scope, which I will be using throughout
these functions. The first variable is the
number of nodes in our graph, then is the
2d memo table that will contain our all pair
shortest path solution. Last is the next to
D table that we will use to reconstruct our
shortest paths. Now moving on to the Floyd
warshall function, you see that it takes one
parameter. This is the 2d adjacency matrix
representing our graph. The first thing I
do in the method is call the setup function.
So let's take a look at that real quick. So
here we are inside the setup function, the
first thing I do is I allocate memory for
our tables, the DP matrix should have the
same type as the input adjacency matrix. What
I mean by this is if your edges in your input
matrix are represented as real numbers, then
your dp matrix should also hold real numbers,
the next matrix will contain indexes of nodes
to reconstruct the shortest paths found from
running the Floyd warshall algorithm. It is
important that initially this matrix be populated
with null values inside the four loops, all
I do is copy the input matrix into the DP
matrix. Think of this as the base case or
rather the K equals zero case. For the next
matrix, if the distance from i to j is not
positive infinity, then the next node you
want to go to from node i is node j by default.
Now we're back inside the Floyd warshall function.
In here after the setup, loop over k on the
exterior loop, it's important that k is on
the exterior loop. Since we want to gradually
build up the best solutions for k equals zero,
then k equals one, then k equals two and so
on. Followed by this loop over all pairs of
nodes i and j. Inside the main body actually
tests for our condition to improve the shortest
path from itj going through K and update the
value at dp ij. If there's a better route
through K, also inside here, update the next
array at ij. to point to the next index. At
next ik, the last thing I want to do is to
detect and propagate negative cycles. This
is an optional step if you know that negative
cycles will not manifest themselves within
your graph. Although I still recommend you
keep this function around. But before we get
too far, I want to discuss negative cycles
and what they entail because it isn't entirely
obvious. So consider the following graph.
There are basically two types of nodes to
consider here. Nodes directly involved in
negative cycles, and nodes unaffected by negative
cycles. This red node is the cause of a negative
cycle because it can endlessly loop on itself
and obtain smaller and smaller costs. While
these blue nodes are not directly in a negative
cycle. This however, doesn't mean they're
not necessarily safe from negative cycles.
As we will see, negative cycles can also manifest
themselves as groups of nodes working together
like the following. So an important thing
to ask ourselves is does the optimal path
from node i to node j go through a red note.
If so, the path is affected by the negative
cycle and is compromised. For example, the
shortest path from zero to five is negative
infinity. Because I can go from zero to node
two, an indefinitely loop in the negative
cycle consisting of nodes, one, two and three,
obtaining better and better costs before eventually
going to five. This is a consequence of traversing
a red node on the way to five. Some shortest
paths however, avoid red nodes altogether,
consider the shortest path from four to six.
This doesn't involve any red nodes, so we
can safely conclude that the shortest path
from four to six is indeed two. So to identify
whether or not the optimal path from i to
j is affected by a negative cycle, rerun the
Floyd warshall algorithm second time, if the
best distance is better than the already known
best distance stored in our table dp, then
set the value in the matrix from it j to be
negative infinity, also mark the index at
ij in the next matrix with a minus one to
indicate that the path is affected by a negative
cycle. We will use this shortly. Back in the
Floyd warshall function, all we need to do
is return the matrix dp which contains the
shortest distance from any node to any other
node. This is the solution to the all pairs
shortest path problem. The last thing I want
to cover is how to reconstruct the shortest
path between any two pairs of notes. This
method returns the shortest path between the
start and end nodes specified or know if there
is a negative cycle for Check the distance
between the start and end nodes is positive
infinity, if so then return an empty path.
Then to reconstruct the path, I create a variable
called act to track the current node. And
then I loop through the next array, adding
the current node to the path as I go. During
this process, I check if the current node
has the value minus one. If it does, then
this means that the optimal path encountered
a red node and is trapped in a negative cycle.
So return null. Notice that in reality, this
method has three key returned values, and
empty path, which means that the start and
end nodes are not connected, a null value
meaning a negative cycle was encountered.
And lastly, a non empty path or node indices
to mean an actual shortest path was found.
Today, we're going to be looking at some source
code for the Floyd warshall. All pairs shortest
path algorithm. Here we are in the source
code for the Floyd warshall algorithm. So
let's get started. Let's start by looking
at an example of how to use this Floyd warshall
solver class to actually find all pairs shortest
path. So here in the main method, the first
thing I do is I actually initialize a graph
with n nodes, where n is set to seven. And
I create our adjacency matrix by calling the
Create graph method. And if we look at up
here, this is the Create graph method. And
all it does is it initializes a matrix of
size n by n, it fills the matrix with the
special constant positive infinity. And it
also sets the diagonals have all zero nodes,
by default, because I assume that this is
the behavior you want. If it's not, then that's
not an issue, because you can just override
it when you add some edge values to your adjacency
matrix. Alright, so we created a matrix, we
added some edge weights. And then what you'll
want to do is create an instance of the solver,
give it our adjacency matrix, and then call
get all pair shortest path matrix function,
which will return the all pair shortest path
matrix as a matrix called just for a distance.
And then here, all I do is I loop over all
pairs of nodes i and j. And I print what the
shortest path from node i to j is. Here's
a sample output of what that looks like. So
there can be roughly three different kinds
of outcomes, we get a concrete shortest path,
there does not exist the path between the
two nodes, they'll be infinity, and we encounter
a negative cycle. So that is negative infinity.
Similarly, if we want to reconstruct the paths,
this is how we're going to do it. Don't be
scared by any of this, it's just text being
printed on the screen. So here, I want to
reconstruct the shortest path between all
pairs of nodes. So I loop through all pairs
of nodes i and j. And then on the server,
again, I call reconstruct shortest path from
itj. And that returns a list of nodes. And
here, I just print three different options
depending on when I get back. If the path
is no, then there does not exist. Or rather,
sorry, there exists an infinite number of
solutions. If the path has zero length, there
is no solution. And otherwise, I just do a
pretty formatting of the output. And this
is what that would look like. So just prints
what the path would be between all pairs of
nodes. So for instance, the shortest path
from node to our node zero to no two in our
graph, goes through nodes, 01, and two, and
it does, it just prints all this information
for all nodes in our graph, which is really
useful. Okay, so what is this Floyd warshall
solver actually doing and that's what we're
going to look at right now.
So inside that class, we have for instance
variables, and the number of nodes in our
adjacency matrix, a boolean value called solve,
which just tracks whether we've solved the
all pair shortest path problem or not our
dp matrix, and a next matrix which is used
to reconstruct the paths, and, oh, there's
also this constant, which I just initialize
to minus one so we can identify when we've
reached naked cycles. Okay, so looking at
the constructor, you just pass in the input
adjacency matrix, and then I do some initialization.
So simply allocate memory for our matrices
that we're going to need, and then populate
the DP matrix with whatever is given to us
for our input. And also make sure to initialize
the next matrix to contain j as the next value
going from i to j. And that's all you need
to do for the setup, nothing too complicated.
Let's look at some of the methods that are
provided in this class. The first one is get
all pair shortest path matrix, which is the
first method we called. And what that does
is it looks if we've solved the all pair shortest
path problem already, and if not a call is
the solver. The reason I do this is so that
if we want to get the all pairs shortest path
matrix, multiple times that we don't want
to run the solve method several times. So
the solve method is what actually solves or
rather executes the Floyd warshall algorithm.
And here's what we're going to do to compute
all pairs of shortest paths. First, we iterate
through k on the exterior loop. And then we
loop through all pairs of nodes, and then
we check for our condition. So if the path
going from i to k and then k back to j is
less than the path from i to j, then update
the value of i to j to route through that
node k. And a while doing this also update
the next matrix so that we can reconstruct
the path later on. So it's is now shorter
to go through igk than i to j. So update the
indices for ij.
This next loop is if you want to identify
negative cycles, identifying negative cycles
means that we need to propagate the value
of negative infinity throughout our graph
for every part of the graph that reaches a
negative cycle. So basically, if we can improve
upon the already optimal solution, then we
know that we are reaching a negative cycle
somehow, and that that particular edge is
compromised, so simply market with negative
infinity. That is again one of the special
constants provided by Java. Similarly update
the next matrix to also mark the node as being
contaminated by negative cycle. But since
next stores integer values, we can't give
it the value negative infinity, which is a
double. So give it the value minus one stored
in reaches negative cycle. And once that is
done, we have fully executed the Floyd warshall
algorithm. And we can mark our boolean value
of salt as true. Now if we look at reconstructing
the shortest path, from the start node to
some ending node, what we want to do is if
we haven't done so already, run the solver
and then initialize a value called path to
an empty ArrayList. Look at if it's even possible
to reach the end node from the start node.
And if it's not return an empty path. Otherwise,
populate the path with the current node which
I noted. Note denoted as act and for each
current node, check if we reach into a negative
cycle. And if we do return null, because the
best value or sorry, the shortest path doesn't
exist, because there are an infinite number
of shortest paths. And also make sure to check
the edge case where the last note is part
of an infinite loop and simply return the
shortest path. Today we're going to talk about
how to develop an algorithm to find bridges
and articulation points in an undirected graph
from a computer science perspective. For starters,
let's talk about what a bridge is a graph.
bridges are sometimes also called cut edges.
Essentially, if you have a graph, which is
a connected component, a bridge is an edge
which if removed, increases the number of
connected components in the graph. The name
bridge makes sense because if you think about
connected components as islands, then a bridge
is what separates them. So For example, in
this graph below, there would be three possible
bridges, which are those edges in pink, because
if you remove any of them, the graph is divided
into two components. And articulation point,
also called a cut vertex is very similar to
a bridge, and that the criteria for being
an articulation point is that it needs to
be any node whose removal will increase the
number of connected components. As an example,
on this graph, there will be three articulation
points, since removing any of these vertices
will divide the graph in tip. As we start
to think more about bridges and articulation
points, we realize how important they are
in graph theory. In a real world situations,
bridges and articulation points often hint
at bottlenecks, or vulnerabilities or weak
points in a graph. Therefore, it's important
to be able to quickly find and detect where
these occur. We'll begin by investigating
how to find bridges and then slightly modify
that algorithm to also find articulation points.
In the simplest way I can explain it. This
is the algorithm we'll be following up to
find bridges in an undirected graph. First,
start at any node in the graph and begin doing
a depth first search traversal labeling nodes
with an increasing ID as you encounter them.
During the traversal, you will need to keep
track of two variables. The first is the nodes
ID, which I just mentioned, and the other
is the nodes low link value. During the depth
first search and bridges will be found. Where
the idea of the node your edge is coming from
is less than the low link value of the node,
the edge is going to
the lowest value of a node is defined as the
smallest node ID reachable from the node you're
currently at when doing the depth first search,
including the ID of the node itself. This
is an interesting concept we'll get back to
later. For now, let's look at an example.
Suppose we have the following graph we've
been looking at and we want to find out where
all the bridges are. Let's begin our depth
first search on the node at the top left corner.
As we do our first search, we're going to
label each node with a unique ID which I will
place inside the node i will also mark nodes
which are visited as yellow and the nodes
which are blue as unvisited. So let's finish
off our depth first search. So explore all
nodes transforming undirected edges into directed
ones and marking off edges or nodes rather
as visited.
So that will conclude our depth first search,
I want to take a moment to think about what
all the low link values would be for these
notes. As a reminder, the low link value of
a node is defined as the smallest ID reachable
from that node. For now initialize all lowing
values to be equal to each nodes ID. I placed
the low link value of each node on the exterior
of that node. If you inspect node one, you
will notice that it's low link value should
be zero because there exists a path of edges
going from node one to node zero and node
zero has an ID of zero. So we can update node
one's low link value to zero. Similarly, node
two is low link value should also be zero.
Because node two to node zero there exists
a path however, nodes three, four and five
are already at their optimal low link value
because there's no other node they can reach
with a lower ID. However, node sixes lowering
value can be a bit to five since there is
a path from node six to node five via these
sequence of edges. And we can also update
node seven and eights low link value by the
same logic. So in general, when we look at
all the directed edges we have traversed,
the ones which form bridges in our graph are
the ones where the ID of the node you started
that is less than the low link value of the
node, you're going to take a moment to think
about why this is true. Let's look at where
these bridges actually occur. In each instance,
the idea of the node with a directed edge
started at is less than the loading value
of the node, it's going to rephrasing that
in another way, it means there was no edge
connecting back to the start of the component,
which is really the definition of what a bridge
is. Otherwise, if there was an edge connecting
backwards to the start of the component, the
loading value of where the edge is pointing
to, would be at least as low as the idea of
the node, you started that because it would
be reachable. For example, if I have an edge
from node eight to node two, suddenly, the
edge from node two to node five is no longer
a bridge, because the loading value on node
five got updated to and our bridge property
highlighted in teal no longer holds. Let's
take an aside and think of the time complexity
of the algorithm I just presented. Right now
we're doing a depth first search to label
all the nodes plus v more depth first searches
to find all the low length values for roughly
v times v plus e in the worst case, if you're
really pessimistic and careless about your
programming.
Luckily, however, we can do much better than
this, and instead update all the loading values
in one pass for a linear time complexity.
Let's look at some pseudocode. on how to do
this in linear time. I'll show you some actual
code in the video that follows. But let's
get started. In the global or class scope,
I define three variables. The first is ID,
which I use to label each node with a unique
ID number, then I have an undirected graph
G. The last is n, which is the number of nodes
in the graph. Following the top level variables
are three arrays, which tracked information
about each node in the graph, index i in each
of these arrays represents node i in the graph.
So the first array tracks the ID of node i.
The second array tracks the load link value
of node i, and the visitor array keeps track
of whether or not we have visited note I.
Moving on the Find bridges function is what
actually finds the bridges. In the method
I iterate over all the nodes which have not
yet been visited by our depth first search.
This is to ensure that we find other bridges
in our graph even if our graph consists of
multiple connected components. Let's dive
into the depth first search method which is
where the real work is happening. The first
argument is the current node you're at, which
is node i then is the parent node which I
set to minus one because there is no previous
node. And last is the bridges array which
we are populating. So here we are in the depth
first search method itself, the arguments
to the method or just as I describe them to
you. The first variable is at which is the
current node ID, then comes parent, the previous
node ID, and the array bridges, which stores
pairs of nodes which form bridges in a flat
rate. In the first three lines of the method,
I simply do some housekeeping stuff which
is mark the current node as visited increment
the ID value variable and assign the current
node to have a default ID and low land value.
Then we get into the actual depth first search
traversal bit. So we iterate over each edge
from the node we're at and attempt to go to
To each node, which I've labeled two, since
this is an undirected graph, there is bound
to be an edge that directly returns to the
node we were just previously at, which is
the parent node, which we want to avoid doing.
So we continue on those cases. If the next
node we're going to is not visited, then we
recursively call the depth first search method.
The two key lines in this method are the main
functions which differ ever so slightly, the
first one happens on the callback, and is
what propagates the low link values, while
the second one is when you try to visit an
already visited node, which has a chance of
having a lower ID than your current low link
value. Then the last bit just checks if our
bridge condition is met, and appends a pair
of node IDs to the bridges array. All right,
now let's look at an example of all this in
action. Suppose we have the following graph
again, and we start our depth first search
somewhere. Let's start at node zero and explore
from there. So now is the first instance of
something interesting happening, we're trying
to visit an already visited node. Since node
two is able to reach node zero from where
it is, we can update its loading value. And
that was the second main statement executing.
Continuing on our depth first search, which
takes us downward. Now we get to explore the
other branch we have not visited.
Again, we have in an edge which reaches out
to find a node with the lower ID, so we need
to update our loling value for the current
node, which is node eight. Now we can update
node sevens loling value to five, on the callback
of the death for search method. This is an
instance of the first main function actually
doing something just to put everything into
context. The red box is the line which was
just invoked. And now that statement, we just
saw, it gets executed for every node on the
call back all the way back to the root node.
And now we have the same result as before,
but we did it with just one pass. So again,
here are all the bridges that we found.
Perfect. Now let's move away from bridges
and started discussing how we can find articulation
points by modifying the algorithm for bridges.
A first simple observation we can make about
articulation points is that on a connected
component with three or more vertices, if
an edge UV is a bridge, then either u or V
is an articulation point. This is a good starting
point because it allows us to easily find
where articulation points occur. For example,
consider the following graph, you will notice
that there is a bridge between nodes zero
and one, meaning that either node zero or
node one is an articulation point. Unfortunately,
this condition is not sufficient to capture
all articulation points. There exists cases
where there is an articulation point, but
there is no bridge nearby. For example, in
the following graph, node two is an articulation
point because its removal would cause the
graph to split into two components. So the
new question is, when do these cases occur?
And the short answer is that it has to do
with cycles in the graph. To understand why,
let's look at an example. Suppose you're traversing
a graph and eventually, you somehow arrive
a node zero. Initially, suppose node zero
has a low link value also zero and like in
any depth, Research, you would continue on
to explore the graph. And eventually, if you
ever encountered the node that started the
cycle with an edge, its ID gets propagated
throughout the cycle during the call back.
So the depth first search. This is the case
because we're reassigning the new loling value
to equal the men of the current loading value
and the ID of the node we were just visiting.
You see now that node five has a loading value
of zero, acquired from the ID of node zero.
This gets spread or propagated as I like to
say, throughout the cycle.
Now, what you'll notice is that the ID of
the node you started that is equal to the
loading value of where it's going to this
indicates that there is a cycle. What is key
here is that the presence of a cycle implies
that the node is an articulation point. This
is because a cycle and a graph corresponds
to a strongly connected component. and removing
the node which started the cycle, who is also
connected to another component will sever
the graph in two. However, there's just one
exception to this. And this is when the starting
node you choose has either no outgoing edges,
or as part of a cycle and only has one outgoing
edge. This is because either the node is a
singleton standalone node. That is the case
with zero outgoing edges, or the notice trapped
in a cycle where it only has one outgoing
edge. To be an articulation point, you need
to have more than one outgoing edge. For example,
in the graph on the right, we start a node
zero the green node and is not an articulation
point, despite our condition of the ID equaling
the low link value. However, as soon as we
add another edge to our starting node, it
becomes an articulation point. So this is
something to watch out for and is unique to
the starting note. Let's now take a quick
look at the changes we need to do to our finding
bridges algorithm to find articulation points.
To begin with, we'll need a way to track the
number of outcoming edges, the storing node
has so I define a new variable called out
edge count. Next I define a Boolean array
called is art, which has true or false depending
on whether or not note i is an articulation
point. Ultimately, this will be the return
value of the find art points function. In
the body of the find art points function,
I reset the edge count variable for every
connected component. And after the depth first
search mark, the starting node is either an
articulation point or not based on how many
outcoming edges were found. Inside the depth
first search method, all I added was an if
statement to increment the number of outcoming
edges from the starting node. Besides that,
I added the equals case to drag articulation
points found via cycles and kept the less
than keys to find articulation points found
via bridges. In a real implementation, you
can merge these two if statements into a single
clause. However, I want to distinguish finding
articulation points from bridges via those
from cycles. In today's video, we're going
to look at the algorithm to find articulation
points in bridges, but this time with actual
source code. All right, here we are in the
source code find bridges, we will look at
the source code to find articulation points
shortly. So this source code is written in
the Java programming language. And here I
have a class which will find all the bridges
and an undirected graph stored as an adjacency
list. But before I get into the details of
the code actually want to show you how the
code works and how we're supposed to use it.
So this is the main method that will set up
the graph. But before we even do that, I'm
just going to scroll down here and look at
some of the methods used to actually create
the graph and make something useful. So this
first method will create a graph with n nodes.
So I create a list of lists. type integer,
which is basically an adjacency list with
directed edges. So all I do is I create a
new ArrayList. And then fill that list of
lists with empty lists, and then return the
graph. That's our graph for now. And then
later on, what we'll do is we'll call this
add edges method to add directed edges into
the graph. So you see, first we add an edge
from a node to a node and then to that node,
from that node, the naming is a little confusing
from into, I use from to mean the the node,
the edge starts out and to to be the node
the edges going to.
So in this example, I have a graph with nine
nodes. So I initialize n to be nine, then
I create the graph and then add all my edges,
you will notice that this graph is actually
the graph from the slides in the last video.
And then what we're going to do is we're going
to pass this graph and the number of nodes
into the class above, which is going to be
our solver. And then the solver is going to
be able to find all the bridges and return
all the bridges as a list of integers. Then
once you have this list of bridges, and bridges
are going to be stored as pairs. So every
two integers that are adjacent and, and pairs
are going to be bridges. So I pull those out,
and I print them, and this is the result you
would expect for this graph. Alright, great.
Now you're wondering how does the magic happening
here. So let's scroll up to the constructor.
And, actually, let's look at the instance
variables. So we have n, which is the number
of nodes in the graph, ID, which is that ID
number to label each node. So we're gonna
give each node A unique ID. And we need to
keep track of well, what was the last ID,
then I have two arrays, which track information
about the nodes. So low is for the low link
values and IDs is to track the ID of each
node, we gave a node with the ID variable,
then just a Boolean array to track whether
or not the node was visited. And finally,
the graph. So in the constructor, of course,
get the graph and the number of nodes, it
checks some conditions to make sure the graph
is legit. Okay, so now we've constructed the
object, or the solver object. And the method
we're interested in is find the bridges. So
the find bridges just initializes all of our
variables. So set ID to be zero, initialize
or allocate some memory for the low link values
and the ID values and the visited array. It's
good practice not to do this work into the
constructor, just because if you just create
a bunch of these objects, but never use them,
you might surprise the person initializing
the object, why they're having so much memory
usage, then initialize the bridges array to
be initially empty. And then we pass that
into the depth for search method. It gets
populated and then returned afterwards. So
for each node, or node ID right now, loop
through all the nodes. And if that node hasn't
been visited, yet started depth first search
on that note, and called depth first search
method with eyes The first argument so the
current node minus one for the parent, and
then pass in the bridges array. So some housekeeping
stuff, like any usual depth first search,
visit the node, and then we're going to do
is we're going to initialize the load link
value, and the ID of that node to just be
a unique ID, which we increment. All right,
then we visit from from the current node,
all the nodes, we can reach and skip, skip
the node that we were just at. So that is
the parent node. So we don't want to do our
depth first search and then immediately returned
to the node we just visited. So continue on
those cases. And we'll do this because we
have an undirected graph, remember. So if
you haven't visited the node yet, then recursively
call our depth first search method and keep
probing While if you have, if you're trying
to visit a node you've already visited, then
you want to take the minimum of the current
link value and the ID of the node you're going
to.
Otherwise, on the callback of depth first
search method is the other low link command
statement, which differs from this one slightly
in that we have, we're taking the minimum
now not of the idea of the node, but the low
link of the other node. And, as you saw in
the slides, the condition for bridge is if
the ID of the node we're at is less than the
low link of the node, we're going to this
means we have a bridge and removing that bridge
will cause the number of connected components
to increase. So append both at and two, which
are the node IDs of the bridge, and put them
in the bridges array, and fill that up, and
then eventually return that down here. So
that is all for bridges. Now let's look at
articulation points, which is really almost
the same algorithm. So if we look at this,
the only thing that's really different is
we have a variable to track the number of
outcoming edges from the start node or what
I call the root node in this script. And other
than that, differences are that we have another
Boolean array called his articulation point
instead of the bridges array to track bridges.
And that we have to reset the number of upcoming
edges for every depth first search we do.
That makes sense. What else is different?
Oh, yes, we have a less than or less than
or equal to, as opposed to just less than
two track cycles as well and mark off those
as articulation points. And I think those
are the major differences for didn't forget
anything between articulation points and bridges.
Oh, of course, we have to count the number
of upcoming edges from the root. That's pretty
important. And here's the same graph as before,
but instead of printing bridges, it prints
articulation points. So some very subtle differences
between finding articulation points in bridges,
but still very important ones. Today, I want
to talk about a fascinating topic, and that
is strongly connected components, and how
we can use Tarzan's algorithm to find them.
So what are strongly connected components
or es CCS? I like to think of them as self
contained cycles within a directed graph,
where for every vertex in a given cycle, you
can reach every other vertex in the same cycle.
For example, in the graph below, there are
four strongly connected components. I've outlined
them here in different colors. If you inspect
each strongly connected component, you'll
notice that each has its own self contained
cycle and that for each component, there's
no way to find a path that leaves a component
and comes back. Because of that property,
we can be sure that strongly connected components
are unique within a directed graph. To understand
Tarzan's strongly connected components algorithm,
we're going to need to understand the concept
of a low link value. Simply put, a low value
is the smallest node ID reachable from that
node including itself. For that, to make sense,
we're going to need to label the nodes in
our graph using a depth first search. Suppose
we start at the top left corner and label
that node with an ID of zero. Now we continue
exploring that graph until we visit all the
edges and have labeled all the notes.
Alright, now that we're done labeling the
nodes inspect the graph and try and determine
the low link value of each node. Again the
low link value of a node is the smallest node
ID reachable from that node including itself.
For example, the loading value of node one
should be zero since node zero is reachable
from node one via some series of edges. Similarly,
node for us low link value should be three
since node three is the lowest node that is
reachable from note four. So if we assign
all the loading values, we get the following
setup. From this view, you realize that all
nodes which have the same loading value Do
you belong to the same strongly connected
component? If I now assign colors to each
strongly connected component, we can clearly
see that for each component, all the low end
values are the same. This seems too easy,
right? Well, you're not wrong, there is a
catch. The flaw with this technique is that
it is highly dependent on the traversal order
of the depth first search, which for our purposes,
is at random. For instance, in the same graph,
I rearranged the note IDs, as though the depth
first search started at the bottom middle
node. In such an event, the loling values
will be incorrect. In this specific case,
all the low link values are the same. But
there clearly are multiple strongly connected
components. So what is going on? Well, what's
happening is that the link values are highly
dependent on the order in which the nodes
are explored in our depth first search. So
we might not end up with a correct arrangement
of node IDs for our loling values to tell
us which nodes are in which strongly connected
component. This is where Tarzan's algorithm
kicks in with its stack invariant to prevent
strongly connected components from interfering
with each other's low link values. So to cope
with a random traversal order of the depth
first search, Tarzan's algorithm maintains
a set often as a stack of valid nodes from
which to update low link values from how the
stack works is that nodes are added to the
stack as nodes are explored for the first
time, and nodes are removed from the stack
each time a strongly connected component is
found. Taking a step back if the variables
u and v are nodes in our graph, and we are
currently exploring No Do you then our new
low link update condition is that to update
node use loading value to node V's low link
value, there has to be a path of edges from
u to v and node v must be on the stack. Another
small difference we're going to make to finding
the correct loading values is that instead
of finding all the loading values after the
fact, we're going to update them as we do
our depth first search on the fly, if you
will. This will allow us to obtain a linear
time complexity.
We'll be doing an example in the following
slides. But this is Tarzan's algorithm nutshell.
Start out and mark each node as unvisited
start the depth first search somewhere and
don't stop until all the nodes are visited.
Upon visiting a node, assign it an ID and
a low link value. Additionally, also mark
the node as visited and add it to the scene
stack. On the depth first search callback
after the recursion comes back. If the previous
node is on a stack than men, the current nodes
is low link value with the last node is low
and value. This is essentially what will allow
loling values to propagate throughout cycles.
After visiting all nodes neighbors, if the
current nodes started the strongly connected
component, then pop of all nodes from the
stack which are in the strongly connected
component. You know, a node started a strongly
connected component if its ID is equal to
its loling value. I'll let you think about
that a bit more, and it'll start making sense.
Let's do an example. I'm going to mark unvisited
nodes as blue nodes for which the depth first
search is still exploring some neighbors as
orange and nodes, which the depth first search
has explored all of its neighbors as gray.
Note that if a node is orange, or gray, then
it is on the stack and we can update its loading
value. I will also be tracking the nodes which
are on the stack in the left column. So keep
your eyes peeled on that as well. So let's
start our depth first search. So just randomly
pick a node and start there. as we explore
unvisited nodes give each node an ID and a
low link value equal to the ID. So now we're
at node two and our only option is to now
visit node zero. Since node zero is already
visited, we don't want to visit it again.
So now we backtrack. All the backtracking.
Since node zero is on the stack, we take the
minimum of the current nodes, low link value
and node zeros low link value. Similarly,
now min, the low link value of the node we
were just at, which is node one with node
two. And also the same for node zero. Upon
returning back to node zero, we realize that
we've actually finished a strongly connected
component. Since we visited all the neighbors
have node zero and its ID is equal to its
low link value. This means we need to remove
all the nodes associated with a strongly connected
component from the stack. However, we're not
done exploring the graph, so pick another
node at random. Let's start at node three.
And go right. Now, our only option is to go
down. Now we're at node five, let's take the
edge to node zero. So node zero is already
visited. So we can't go there. On the callback,
we notice that node zero is not on the stack
at the moment. So we can't min node five is
loling value against node zero. This is actually
very, very good, because if we did, then we
would contaminate the strongly connected component
node five as part of with a lower low link
value, which node zero has to offer. So let's
go to node six. So now we have three edges
to choose from. Let's take the one on the
right, node two is not on stack. So don't
men with its low like value. Now let's take
the left edge to node four, node four is on
the stack. So we can make this low link value,
giving node six also a low link value of four
that the last edge we need to visit is the
one going to node zero. This is a situation
where node zero is not on the stack, so we
can't min with its low link value. On the
callback node five can min with node six is
low and value because it is on the stack.
Similarly, for node four. Coming back to node
four, we've visited all its neighbors and
its ID is equal to its lowest value. So it
marks the start of a strongly connected component.
So we now have to remove all associated nodes
in this strongly connected component from
the stack, these would be all of the purple
nodes.
Now coming back to node three, we cannot min
its loling value with node four, because we
just removed node four from the stack. You
will also notice that node threes ID is equal
to its loling value. So it should be the start
of a strongly connected component. However,
we have not finished visiting all of node
threes neighbors, so we cannot make that assessment
just yet. Now see the downward edge to visit
node seven. Now take the edge to node five.
On the callback, notice that node five is
not in the stack, so we don't mean with its
low link value. Now up to node three. On the
callback, we can min with no threes low link
since node three is on the stack. Also man
with node seven. So now we've finished with
the last strongly connected component, all
we need to do is remove all associated nodes
from the stack. And that's how tyrosianse
algorithm works to find a strongly connected
components. Very beautiful, isn't it? Let's
look at some pseudocode. For how this works,
I think it will solidify your understanding.
To get started in the global or class scope,
I define a few variables that we'll need.
The first is a constant to represent unvisited
nodes, then comes n the number of nodes in
the graph, and G an adjacency list of directed
edges. Both n and g are inputs to this algorithm.
Then comes two variables ID to give each node
an ID and s cc count to track the number of
strongly connected components. After I define
a few arrays which store auxilary information
about the nodes not graph. The first array
is IDs which As the ID of each node, then
is low to store the loling values. And finally
on stack to track whether or not a node is
on the stack, finally is the stack data structure
itself, which should at minimum support, push
and pop operations. Inside the find es CCS
method. The first thing I do is assign the
ID of each node to be unvisited. The IDs array
will be serving to track whether or not a
node has been visited, as well as what a nodes
ID is. In the following loop, I iterate through
all the nodes in the graph. There I start
a depth first search on node i, if node AI
has not yet been visited, at the end, I return
the array lo an array of Boolean values, which
will be the final output of the algorithm.
Now let's look at what's happening inside
the depth first search method which is really
where all the magic happens. So this is the
inside of the depth first search method. The
input argument to the depth first search method
is a variable called at which I use to denote
the ID of the node we are currently at. On
the first three lines, I do some housekeeping
stuff, which is add the current node to the
stack, mark the current node as being on the
stack, and give an ID and a little link value
to the current note thing comes to the part
where I visit all the neighbors of the current
node. To do this, I reach into our graph store
as an adjacency list and loop over a variable
called two which represents the ID of the
node we're going to the next line says that
if the node we're going to is unvisited, then
visit ID. Remember, the IDS array tracks the
ID of note I, but also whether or not node
AI has been visited. This next slide is very
important. In fact, it's probably the most
important line on the slide. The first thing
to notice is that this line happens after
the recursive call to the depth first search
method, meaning that this line gets called
on the call back from the depth first search
line says that if the node we just came from
is on stack, than men, the current loling
value with a node we were just at this is
what allows the loling values to propagate
throughout a cycle. So after we finish the
for loop that visited all the neighbors of
the current node, we need to check if we're
at the start of a strongly connected component.
To check if we're at the start of a strongly
connected component check if the ID of the
current node is equal to the low link value
for that node. After we have identified that
we're at the beginning of a completed strongly
connected component, pop off all the nodes
inside the stripe connected component from
the stack. As we're popping nodes from the
stack also mark off nodes as no longer being
on stack. One more critical thing we need
to do while we're removing nodes from our
stack is make sure that all nodes which are
part of the same strongly connected component
have the same ID. So here I just assigned
each note have the same ID as the ID of the
node which started the strongly connected
component. Last things are to start popping
off nodes from the stack once we reach the
start of the strongly connected component,
and also increment the strongly connected
component count. If you want to track the
number of connected components that were found.
Today, we will be looking over some source
code for Tarzan's strongly connected components
algorithm. Here we are in the source code
for Tarzan's algorithm to find strongly connected
components. You'll notice that this source
code is written in the Java programming language.
So to get started, let's have a look at the
constructor for the class. And you'll notice
that it takes a graph as an adjacency list
as an argument. But before we get into the
details of this actual algorithm, I want to
show you how the algorithm actually works
in practice if you're going to execute it.
So if we look at the main method, you'll notice
that here is how the algorithm is meant to
be used. You set up the graph and then you
run the solver. So to begin with, you declare
a variable called n which is the number of
nodes that are going to be in your graph.
Then you create the graph. So this initializes,
the adjacency list for n nodes. If we look
at that Create graph method up here, all the
does is it initializes, the adjacency list,
and then populates that with empty lists,
so that we can be ready to add edges to our
directed graph. So if you want to add an edge
to the graph, then you would call this method,
give it the graph, give it the directed edge.
So from a node to another node, and then it
will add that edge to the graph. So I believe
this graph is the one from the slides, the
very last graph, if I recall correctly.
So to actually find the strongly connected
components, you create an object of the solver,
you give it the graph, and then you run the
solver on the graph. So this is what actually
finds the strongly connected components. And
this will return the the array of low link
values, then what I do is I dump all of these
inside a multi map so we can know for each
connected component, which are the nodes associated
with that connected component. And then all
I do is I print out which groups which nodes
are part of. So you notice that I print that
there are three connected components. And
here are the nodes and what connected components
they belong to. So that's how you use the
algorithm. Let's see what it's doing. So we
already went over the constructor, which passes
in the graph extracts the size of the graph,
and caches the adjacency list. as other instance
variables, we have a boolean variable with
tracks whether or not we have already solved
the problem, then two variables to count the
number of strongly connected components and
assign an ID to each node, an array to track
whether or not a node is on the stack, and
then two integer arrays to track the ID of
each node and the low link values of each
node. And finally, a stack. So if we look
at the SEC count method, it runs the solver
if has not yet been solved and simply returns
the number of strongly connected components.
The get sccs method also simply runs the solver
if it has not yet been run, and returns the
loling values array. Now let's look at the
solver itself. So it returns if it's already
been solved, because we don't want to do more
work than we need to. Inside the solve method,
I initialize all our arrays, I also fill the
IDS array with the unvisited token. So we
can know whether or not a node has been visited
or not. Recall that the IDS array keeps track
of the ID of a node, but it also keeps track
of whether or not a node has been visited.
So iterate through each node and if node i
is unvisited then start a depth first search
at node i finally, mark that we have solved
the strongly connected components for this
graph. Inside the depth first search method,
it's almost exactly like the slides. So do
the housekeeping stuff, which is like push
the current node on the stack, mark the current
node as being on the stack, give the current
node and ID and the loading value because
the first time we're visiting it, then iterate
over all the neighbors of this node, do a
depth first search if the node we're going
to is unvisited on the call back check if
it's on the stack, and men that's low link
value with where we were just at. And back
here after we've visited all the neighbors
of the node, then we check if we're at the
start of a strongly connected component. And
if we are we want to pop off all the nodes
associated with that strongly connected component
which are on the stack. So I start with a
first node and my condition has to pop until
I return back to the start of that strongly
connected component. And as I'm popping off
nodes from the stack, I mark the node as no
longer being on the stack. And I also assign
every node part of that strongly connected
components have the same ID as the node which
started the strongly connected component.
Just so that we know after the fact which
nodes belong to it strongly connected component,
finally, increment the number of strongly
connected components in case we are interested
in that. And that's basically intelligence
algorithm in a nutshell. Hello, and welcome
to this tutorial on how to solve the Traveling
Salesman Problem with dynamic programming.
Today, we're going to look at two things.
First is how to find the cost of the best
tour, and then how to actually find that tour.
All right, so let's get started. What is the
Traveling Salesman Problem? In a nutshell,
it's when you're given a list of cities and
the distances between each pair of cities,
and you want to find the shortest possible
route that visits each city exactly once and
then returns to the city of origin. In some
other words, we can say that the problem is
given a complete graph with weighted edges,
what is the Hamiltonian cycle of minimum cost?
A Hamiltonian cycle is simply a path which
visits each node exactly once. In practice,
you will probably want to represent whatever
graph you have as an adjacency matrix for
simplicity, if an edge between two nodes does
not exist, simply set the edges value to be
positive infinity. So in the graph I had,
you can see that one optimal tour consists
of going from A to D to C to B, and then finally,
back to a, with a minimum cost of nine. Note
that it is entirely possible that there are
many possible valid optimal tours, but they
will all have the same minimum cost. As it
turns out, solving the Traveling Salesman
Problem is extremely difficult. In fact, the
problem has been proven to be NP complete,
meaning it's very difficult to find an optimal
solution for large inputs. However, numerous
approximation algorithms exists, if you want
to get an algorithm that runs very quickly,
even for large inputs. So the brute force
way to solve this problem is to actually compute
all possible tours. And this means we have
to try all permutation of node orderings,
which will take big O of n factorial time,
which is very slow. But as you can see, I've
listed all the permutation of nodes and highlighted
the ones which yield the optimal solution.
The dynamic programming
solution we're going to develop today is able
to improve on this naive approach, by reducing
the complexity to big O of n squared times
to the end. At first glance, this may not
seem like a substantial improvement. However,
it now makes graphs with roughly 23 nodes
give or take feasible for modern home computers.
Here's a table of n factorial versus n squared
to the N. At first, you notice that n factorial
is optimal for small numbers. But this quickly
changes favor to n squared to the n, which
can give a significant improvement over n
factorial. You can already see that how large
the numbers get for n factorial when we hit
n equals 15 versus the n squared to the N.
All right, time to talk about how to solve
this problem using dynamic programming. The
main idea is going to be to compute the optimal
solution for paths of length n, we will have
to reuse information from paths of length
and minus one. But before we get started,
there's some setup information we need to
talk about. The first thing we're going to
need to do is pick a starting node s, it doesn't
matter which notice picked, just make sure
that this nodes index is between zero and
n non inclusive. Suppose we have this graph
with four nodes, and we choose our starting
node to be node zero. The next thing we need
to do is store the optimal value from s the
starting node to every other node. This will
solve the Traveling Salesman Problem for all
paths with exactly two notes. The optimal
value for paths with two nodes is given in
the input through the adjacency matrix. And
this is all the setup we need to do. Visually,
if you want to look at it, we can see that
we store the value from zero to one, zero
to two, and finally zero to three. In the
last slide, I talked about storing the solution
for n equals two. But what is it we really
need to store, there are two key things. The
first is obvious. And that's the set of visited
nodes and the partially completed tour. The
other is the index of the last visited node
in the path. For each partially completed
tour, we need to save which node was the last
node we were on so that we can continue extending
that partially completed Tor. From that node
we were on and not from some other node. This
is very important. So together these two things,
the set of visited nodes, and the index of
the last visit node forum, what I call the
dynamic programming state. Since there are
n possible last nodes, and to the power of
n node subsets, our storage space is bounded
by big O of n times to the n. An issue we're
going to face when trying to store the DP
state is representing the set of visited nodes.
And the way and I mean, the way to do this
is to use a single 32 bit integer. The main
idea is that if the eighth node has been visited,
we flip on the eighth bit to a one in the
binary representation of the integer. The
advantage to this representation is that a
32 bit integer is compact, quick and allows
for easy caching in a memo table. For example,
on the leftmost graph, we have visited the
zeroeth and first nodes, so the binary representation
is 0011, if the least significant bit is on
the right, similarly, the binary representation
of the middle graph is 1001, or just the number
nine in decimal since nodes zero and three
have been visited. Now, suppose we're trying
to expand on our previous state. One particular
instance of a two node partial tour is shown
below.
What we want to do from our last node, which
in this graph is no three is expand to visit
all other unvisited nodes. These are the gray
nodes one and two, to make our partial tour
a little longer, with three notes. For this
particular stage, we were able to generate
an additional two states. But we would also
need to do this for all states with two nodes,
not just this one with zero, and three. In
total, this process would result in six new
states four partial tours with three nodes.
This process continues with gradually longer
and longer paths until all paths are of mine.
And the last thing we need to do to wrap up
the Traveling Salesman Problem is to reconnect
the tour to the designated starting note s.
To do this loop over the N state in the memo
table for all possible end positions, excluding
the start node, and minimize the lookup value
plus the cost of going back to s. Note that
the end state is the one where the binary
representation is composed of all ones, meaning
each node has been visited. It's finally time
to look at some pseudocode. For the Traveling
Salesman Problem. Just a heads up to everyone
who's still a beginner. The following slides
make use of advanced bit manipulation techniques.
So make sure you're comfortable with how binary
shifts ands ORS and x ORS work. Here's the
function that solves the Traveling Salesman
Problem. It takes two inputs. The first is
a two dimensional adjacency matrix representing
the input graph and s the index of the starting
node. The first thing we do Get the size of
the matrix and stored in a variable called
n, which tells us how many nodes there are.
Then we initialize the two dimensional memo
table, the table should have size n by n to
the power of n, I recommend filling the table
with null values, so that programmatic errors,
throw runtime exceptions. Then we're going
to call four functions set up, solve, find
min cost and find optimal tour. Let's begin
by looking at what happens inside the setup
method. The setup method is very easy, it
simply does what I illustrated a few slides
ago. by storing the optimal value from the
start node to every other node, you loop through
each node skipping over the start node. And
then you cache the optimal value from S to
AI, which can be found in the distance matrix.
The DB state you store is the end node as
I and the mask with bits s and I set to one,
hence the double bit shift. Visually, the
green node is the start node and the orange
node is node i, which changes with every iteration.
You notice now that the orange node is never
on top of the green node, which is why I have
a continue statement to skip that case. Now
let's look at how the solve method works.
The solid method is by far the most complicated,
but I've broken that down to be easy to understand.
The first line in the method loops over r
equals three up to n inclusive. Think of R
as the number of nodes in a partial tour.
So we're increasing this number one at a time.
The next line says for a subset in combinations,
the combinations function generates all bit
sets of size and with exactly our bits set
to one. For example, as seen in the comments.
When calling the combinations function with
R equals three and n equals four, we get four
different bits sets, each distinct and with
three ones turned on. These are meant to represent
a subset of visited nodes.
Moving on, notice that I enforce the node
s to be part of the generated subset. Otherwise,
the subset of nodes is not valid since it
could not have started at our designated starting
node. Notice that this if statement calls
the not in function defined at the bottom
of the slide. All it does is it checks if
if the bit in the subset is a zero. Then we
loop over a variable called next, which represents
the index of the next node. The next node
must be part of the current subset. This may
sound strange, but know that the subset variable
generated by the combinations function has
a bit which is meant for the next node. This
is why the variable state on the next line
represents the subset excluding the next node.
This is so we can look up in our memo table
to figure out what the best partial tour value
is when the next node was not yet in a subset.
Being able to look back and reuse parts of
other partially completed tours is essential
to the dynamic programming aspect of this
algorithm. The following variable to consider
is E short for end node. Because I ran out
of room this variable is quite important because
while the next node is temporarily fixed in
the scope of the inner loop, we try all possible
end nodes of the current subset and try to
see which end node best optimizes this partial
tour. Of course, the end node cannot be any
of the start node, the next node
or
not be part of their current subset that we're
considering. So we skip all those possibilities.
So we compute the new distance and compare
it to the minimum distance. If the new Distance
is better than the minimum distance, then
we update the best minimum distance. afterwards.
Once we've considered all possible end nodes
to connect to the next node, we store the
best partial tour in the memo table. And this
concludes the solve method. The only unanswered
question in this slide is how the combinations
method works. And I do not mean to leave this
unanswered. So let's see how this gets done.
This method is actually far simpler than you
might imagine, for what it does. What the
first combinations method does is it fills
up the subsets array using the second combinations
method, and then returns that result. So what
does the second the combinations method do?
I already covered this in more detail in my
tutorial, backtracking the power set if you
want more detail, but I'll give you a quick
rundown of what this recursive method does,
basically, starting with the empty set, which
is zero, you want to set r out of n bits to
be one for all possible combinations. So you
keep track of which index position you're
currently at, and then try and set the bid
position to a one and then keep moving forward,
hoping that at the end, you have exactly our
bits. But if you didn't, you backtrack flip
off the bit, you flipped on and then move
to the next position. This is a classic backtracking
problem, you might want to research. This
is how you solve it. But I don't want to focus
on this in this video, per se. So I want to
get back the Traveling Salesman Problem. Watch
my backtracking video on the power set for
more guidance. If you're lost, I'll try to
remember to put a link in the description.
So right now in our memo table, we have the
optimal value for each partial tour with a
nose. So let's see how we can reuse that information
to find the minimum Torah value. The trick
is going to be to construct a bitmask for
the end state and use that to do a lookup
in our memo table. The end state is the bitmask
with n bits set to one which we can obtain
by doing a bit shift and then subtracting
one.
Then
what we do is look at each end node candidate
and minimize over the Tor costs by looking
at what's in our memo table, and the distance
from the end node back to the start node s.
The last method we need to look at is the
find optimal tour function because what good
is our algorithm if it cannot actually find
you what the optimal tour is. For this method,
what we're going to do to find the actual
tour is work backwards from the end state
and do lookups in our memo table to find the
next optimal node, we will keep track of the
last index we were at. And the current state
which begins with all visited nodes, then
we loop over I from n minus one to one which
tracks the index position for the tour. to
actually find the next optimal node going
backwards, we're going to use a variable called
index which will track the best note the inner
loop loops over j which represents all possible
candidates for the next node, we must ensure
that j is not the starting node that is part
of the state meaning it has not yet been visited.
If this is the first valid iteration, the
variable index will be set to minus one. So
sell it to J otherwise compare the optimal
values of the best distances between nodes
index and J and update index if node j is
better. Once the optimal index is found, store
that as part of the tour and flip off the
bit in the state which represents the index
note. Finally set the first and last nodes
of the tour to be as the starting node because
the tour needs to start and end. On that note,
then simply return the tour. And that is how
you solve the Traveling Salesman Problem with
dynamic programming. Hello and welcome to
This video on the Traveling Salesman Problem
with dynamic programming. Today we're going
to have a look at some source code. All right,
here we are in the source code for the Traveling
Salesman Problem with dynamic programming.
This is the iterative implementation. If you
look in the repository, you should see that
there is also a recursive implementation if
you are interested in that this implementation
is in the Java programming language, but you
should be able to translate it pretty easily
to any programming language. So let's get
started. So if we want to solve this problem,
we're going to have to create this object
called TSB dynamic programming iterative and
it has two constructors, one with a distance
matrix as an input. And the other optional
constructor is the distance matrix, but also
with a designated starting node. So by default,
I have the starting node to be zero, but you
can set that to be whichever node you like.
And then I simply store how many nodes are
in the graph. And then check for some edge
cases, I haven't supported n equals two yet,
but that should be pretty trivial to do. And
then just check some edge cases, make sure
the matrix is square, you know, just that
kind of stuff. And then I cache the start
position and the distance in these instance
variables. And then here are the two methods
that you will be interested in the first called
Get a tour, and it returns a list of integers
representing the optimal tour for the input
graph. And this other method called get tour
cost returns the minimum tour cost. And notice
that they both call the solve method if the
solver has not been run yet. I could call
the solve method in the constructor. But that's
generally considered bad practice to do work
in the constructor. So I leave it up to the
methods to call the solve method. Or you can
explicitly call it yourself doesn't matter.
So the solid method is what basically solves
the traveling salesman person problem.
So the first thing I do is I initialize a
variable called the end state. And this is
the state with all nodes visited. So all bits
are set to one. Then I initialize a memo table
of size and times to the end, and it takes
type double. So initially, this entire table
is filled with null values. And then I do
an initialization step, where I add all edges
from the starting node to every other node,
which is not start node. So this is like the
first step in the slides, if you remember
correctly, and then you set it equal to the
value in the adjacency matrix. Then we start
the phase where we're trying to create tours
of path that are one a longer. So R is once
again, the number of nodes in the partially
completed tour. Then we loop through all subsets
with our bits set produced from our combinations
function, which is below. I guess I'll jump
to that right now. So that's right here. And
this method basically generates all the bit
sets of size and where our bits are set to
one. And then you can see that the result
is returned in this variable called subsets.
So this is the combinations method and then
this calls the private combinations method
down here. So ignoring this part, which is
just an optimization, if r is zero, meaning
we've selected exactly our elements, then
we find found the ballots subset and then
add it to our subsets array. Otherwise, we
flip on the ice bit recursively call the method
and then backtrack and flip off the ice bit.
Alright, so going back over here. Now we make
sure that the starting node is Inside the
subset, otherwise, we're not going to be able
to create a valid tour.
Next,
Next, we loop over the variable called next,
from zero to n. And the next node is going
to be our next slide target nodes, the one
we're trying to expand to, if you will. So
we make sure that the next note is not the
starting node. And we also make sure that
it is in the subset produced by the combinations
function. Otherwise, we're not interested
in it. Then we generate the mask, which is
called subset without next. And this is the
the state or the partially completed tour
without that next node. So we basically flip
off the next node and set it to zero. And
this allows us to do a lookup in our memo
table later on. So we can compute the new
distance. But before that, we initialize a
variable called min distance, which I initialize
to positive infinity. And this is the variable
we're trying to minimize for the next node.
Then, for every possible end node, every possible
end node, which is not the start node, or
the end node, and is part of our subset, we
calculate the new distance from the end node
using the subset without next, and then from
the end node to the next node. And then if
that new distance is less than the global,
or sorry, the just the min distance we declared
up here, then just update the min distance.
And finally cache that in the memo table.
So this is the bulk of the algorithm right
here. But we're not done yet. We still want
to calculate the minimum cost, like the overall
minimum cost of the optimal tour. And to do
that, we simply loop from I zero to n, skipped
over the starting node. And, and then do a
look up in our table for that end node, I
and the state and state. So we finished a
tour. And the tour ended on node i and then
go from I, which we ended on back to the start
node. So that's the tour cost. Now we just
minimize over this variable and update the
mentor costs, which if we go back, you can
see was one of our instance variables, which
had set the positive infinity. So we're minimizing
this. And this is why it gets returned on
the get tore cost function. All right. So
this finds the minimum tour cost. And this
section you see right here finds what the
actual torque is, which is really useful,
and does that by looking inside the the memo
table at the values we've computed. So we
initialize a variable called the last index,
and it initialized the starting node, because
that's essentially the very last node if you
want, when we do the tour, we end up at the
start node again. And the state is the end
state. So we're working our way backwards.
So we start at the end state and then we're
going to slowly, I guess, reduce our tour
until we're back to the starting node. So
So in our tour, we add that starting node.
And then we're going to loop n minus one times.
And this variable i is just for, for counter.
So it's not, it's not used anywhere in here.
So we loop n minus one times and for this
index variable, so this is like the, the node
we want to to go to next. So it's the best
as the index of the best next node. But define
that next best node, we need to look at where
we were last, which is the last index and
go to the next best node which is going to
be j so we loop over We're all possible j
nodes, if you will start j at zero and loop
up to n, and then skip over when j is equal
to the start or is not in the state, because
we would have already visited a node otherwise.
And if index is minus one, then it's the first
valid node we encounter. So set index equal
to J. Otherwise, look at the previous distance.
So for the node at index versus the node j,
and then if selecting node j gives us a smaller
value, then we know we want to update index
to be J. And, and doing this for all of the
nodes will find us the next best node going
backwards, then we want to add that nodes
index to the tour, and then toggle the that
bit off, and then set the last index to be
the current index. So we're going backwards
and basically starting from a fully completed
tour and like shrinking the tour down to just
the starting node again. And at the very end,
we want to add that starting node to the tour,
and then reverse the order of the tour. This
is because we're going backwards, we're starting
at the end state and then working our way
backwards. So our tour is in effect in reverse
order. So we want to reverse the tour order.
And then we can mark the solver as completed.
And tour if we look up here was just a list
of integers. And tour is the variable we return
when we call get tour. The only thing I did
not cover was this not in function, which
just checks if a bit or the element was not
set in subset, so you check if that bit is
equal to zero. Today we're going to talk about
oil arian paths and circuits. From a computer
science perspective. We're going to start
with discussing what Euler paths and circuits
are, how to determine their existence, how
to find them. And lastly, we're going to look
at some code to wrap things up. Let's begin
with what an oil arian path
is.
an Euler path, also called an oil area and
trail is a path of edges in a graph that visits
every edge exactly once. Suppose we have the
undirected graph below and we want to find
an Euler return path. First off not every
graph has an oil arian path this one does,
but even still, we need to be careful about
which node we start our path at. Suppose we
begin the path at the middle rate node and
decide to follow the path left Down, up up
began and finally left this completes the
oil arian path. However, suppose we start
at the top node. What happens if we decide
to find a path from this node? If we take
the edge going down, you'll notice that we
are now stuck. We cannot go anywhere else
from this node since there are no edges left
to follow. More importantly, the issue is
that we have unvisited edges that we still
have not used or traversed. So we'll see how
to resolve or rather avoid this issue altogether
later so that we always find an oil arian
path when we no one exists. Moving on let's
talk about oil arian circuits, also called
oil arian cycles and oil arian circuit is
an oil layer in path which starts and ends
on the same vertex. So similar to oil arian
paths, not every graph has an oil arian circuit,
but the following graph does. If you know
your graph has an oil arian circuit, then
you can begin the circuit at any note. I'm
going to begin the circuit on the orange note
and also end it on the orange note.
And that's the full circuit if your graph
does not contain an oil arian circuit, you
may not be able to return to the start node
or you will not
Be able to visit all the edges of the graph.
For example, let's start another circuit starting
from the same node on this slightly modified
graph.
So by randomly selecting edges to traverse,
we weren't able to make it back to the starting
node. Furthermore, we also have unvisited
edges, so that's double bad. Luckily for us,
we don't have to guess whether or not a graph
contains an oil arian path or an oil arion
circuit, we can inspect the graph we're dealing
with by counting the in and out degrees of
each node to determine whether or not the
graph meets one of the conditions. In this
table. There are four flavors of or Larian
paths and circuits that we care about. And
those are whether the graph is directed or
undirected, and whether or not we want to
find an Euler in path or an ordinary circuit.
All of these variants talk about no degrees.
So I want to have a quick look at that before
coming back to this table. The degree of unknown
means different things depending on whether
the graph we're dealing with is directed or
undirected. In an undirected graph, the node
degree is simply how many edges are attached
to a particular node, the blue node in this
picture has three edges attached to it. So
it's degrees three in a directed graph, there
are two forms have no degrees there are in
degrees and out degrees. Because the edges
are directed the end degree is the number
of incoming edges to a node and the out degree
of a node is the number of outgoing edges
from that node. So in the example on the right,
the end degree of the notice to while the
out degree is one pretty simple. Coming back
to the table, you should be able to understand
the constraints required for each variant
of the oil arian path and oil arian circuit
problem. However, let's go over them one by
one anyways, the simplest cases when we have
an undirected graph and we want to find an
oil layer in circuit the requirement for this
is that every node in the graph has an even
degree. The oil arian path problem on an undirected
graph is very similar, except that in addition
that every vertex has an even degree you can
also have exactly two vertices which have
an odd degree those two vertices, if they
exist, would be the start and end nodes of
the oil arian path I a directed graph, you
can have an Euler circuit if every vertex
has an equal internet degree. This is the
counterpart to the undirected graph version.
The last variant is finding an Euler path
on a directed graph for there to exist in
over there and path on a directed graph. at
most one vertex has an out degree minus and
in degree, which is equal to one and at most
one vertex as an indie GRI minus out degree
equal to one and all other verse vertices
have equal internet degrees. So it's now Quiz
time, and I'm going to make sure you've been
paying attention. I'm going to present to
you various graphs, and you need to determine
whether the following graph has an oil layer
in path and over there in circuit or both.
So we'll start with undirected graphs, and
then later move on to directed graphs. Please
feel free to pause the video to think things
over. So this graph has no oil arian path
or circuit you can tell because there are
too many nodes with an odd degree. How about
this graph? Again, feel free to pause the
video. This graph has an oil arian path and
the green nodes represent the valid Start
and End notes
for
the oil arian path. What about this graph?
This graph has both an oil arian path and
an oil arian circuit. As a side question,
true or false, if a graph has an oil arian
circuit, it also has an oil arian path like
give you a moment to think about the answer
is true. Any circuit is an oil arian path.
Here's another one, are there any paths or
circuits in this graph? This one is a bit
of a trick question, but there are no order
in paths or circuits here and the additional
requirement I have not yet mentioned is that
when finding paths and circuits is that all
vertices with nonzero degree need to belong
to a single connected component and here We
have two connected components. So we cannot
have an overlay or in path or circuit. Now
let's have a look at an example with a directed
graph. Does the following graph have any or
they're in paths or circuits? I'll give you
a moment to think about it. Yes, this graph
has both an Euler path and an Euler in circuit
because all in and out degrees are equal.
What about this graph? This graph has no oil
arian paths or circuits. The red nodes either
have too many incoming or outgoing edges for
an oil arian path or circuit to exist. What
about this graph, I'll give you a bit more
time because there are a lot of edges.
This graph only has an Euler path, but no
Euler in circuit, it also has a unique start
and end node for the path. Note that the singleton
node has no incoming or outgoing edges, so
it doesn't impact whether or not we have an
oil arian path. Today we're talking about
how to algorithmically find oil, Larian paths
and circuits on graphs. So finding oil arian
paths and or they're in circuits are actually
very similar problems for both directed and
undirected graphs. If you have an algorithm
that finds an oil arian path, finding oil
arian circuit comes for free, all you need
to do is feed the graph with the oil layer
in circuit into the oil area and path algorithm
and outcomes the oil arian circuit. For that
reason. Today we'll be looking at an algorithm
that finds an oil arian path on a directed
graph. So the first step to finding an oil
arian path is to verify that one exists, because
maybe it's impossible to find an oil arian
path that traverses all the edges of your
graph. And it's good to know that before you
actually find your ordering path. So recall
that for now, or they're in path to exist,
at most one vertex has a degree minus in degree
equal to one and at most one vertex has in
degree minus out degree equal to one and all
other vertices have equal in and out degrees,
we're going to count the in and out degrees
of each node. By looping through all the edges,
we'll be needing two arrays, which I've called
in and out to track the in and out degrees
of each node. So for each edge, increment
the integral of a node if a node has an incoming
edge and increment the out degree if it has
an outgoing edge, and
so on for all the other edges. Once we've
verified that no node has too many outgoing
edges, or too many incoming edges, and there
are just the right amount of Start and End
nodes, we can be certain that our oil arian
path exists, the next step is to find a valid
starting node. Because we can't start the
algorithm at any node we choose necessarily.
node one is the only node with exactly one
extra outgoing edge, so it's our only valid
starting node. Similarly, node six is the
only node with exactly one extra incoming
edge so it will end up being our ended node.
Note that if all in and out degrees are equal,
then we have an oil arian circuit. And we
can choose to start the algorithm at any node
which has a nonzero degree. So we have everything
we need to find an oil arian path. Let's see
what happens if we try and do a naive depth
first search to traverse as many edges as
possible until we get stuck. Let's begin at
our starting note and execute a random depth
first search. Let's take a write another write
up, down diagonally up diagonally right. And
right again, you'll notice that even though
we started at the correct starting node, and
that we knew in oil arian path existed, and
furthermore, that we did end up at the correct
end node that we still did not find the valid
oil arian path since we didn't traverse all
the edges. So what's going on? Well, what's
happening is that we're doing our depth first
search wrong, we need to modify the depth
first search algorithm to force the depth
first search to visit all the edges of our
graph to illustrate this Consider this simpler
smaller graph. Suppose we start our depth
first search at node zero and try to find
an oil arian path. Suppose we take the edge
the right, then suppose the depth first search
takes us right. Again, this causes us to accidentally
skip the edges going to node two and back,
which we know will need to be part of the
oil era and path solution. For now let's not
worry about it and keep executing our depth
for search. So once we get stuck, meaning
the current node has no unvisited outgoing
edges, we backtrack and add the current node
to the solution. So four gets added to the
solution and we return to the node we were
just at. We are stuck again because node three
has no outgoing edges that are unvisited.
So we add three to the front of the solution
and backtrack when backtracking if the current
node has any remaining unvisited edges, that
is white edges, we follow any of them calling
our depth first search method recursively
to extend the ordering path, so we follow
the edge up to node two, and then there's
still another edge going downwards. So we
take that one too. Now we're stuck again,
because there aren't any unvisited edges anymore,
what we do is we backtracking add the current
node to the front of the solution. Effectively,
we do this until we return to the start node
and the recursion unwinds. So in summary,
how we forced the depth first search to take
all the edges is to keep taking unvisited
edges on the recursive call back until no
unvisited edges remain. Coming back to the
previous example. Let's restart the algorithm.
But this time, let's track the number of unvisited
edges, we still have left to take at each
node. In fact, we have already computed the
number of outgoing edges for each node in
the out array, which we can reuse, we won't
be needing the inner array anymore once we
validated that an Euler in path exists, so
we can ignore it. Let's begin at the starting
node once again. Now one thing we're going
to do slightly differently is that every time
an edge is taken will reduce the outgoing
edge count for that node. Doing this will
enable us to know when a certain node has
no more unvisited edges. So let's just follow
the same path we had last time until we get
stuck.
So now we are where we were last time, but
we're not going to terminate the algorithm
just yet. Instead, we're going to backtrack
because we're stuck and there are no more
outgoing edges to take from node six. One
way to know this without looking at the graph
is to check whether the outer array at index
six has a value of zero, and it does. So let's
backtrack and add six to the front of our
solution. Now we are at node four and node
four has remaining unvisited edges, those
are the white edges, which we still need to
take. So we call our depth first search method
recursively and follow all the unvisited edges
for note four, similar situation at node three,
and node one and node two. For node two, we're
going to take the edge going to the right,
which brings us back to node four. But this
time there are no more unvisited edges at
node four. So what do we do, we backtrack
and add four to the front of our solution.
Now we're at node two and node two still has
an unvisited edge since the outer array at
index two is not equal to zero. So what we
do is we follow that unvisited edge, which
brings us back to node two, and node two now
has no more unvisited edges. So we backtrack
and add to the solution. And we're back at
node two, and we backtrack now we're at node
one, and backtrack from node one. Now we're
at node three, and so on since all the edges
have been visited, and at this point, we're
just going to unwind the stack and add the
current note to the front of the solution.
I'll let the animation play.
And that's how you find an oil arian path
on a graph. In terms of the time complexity
required to find an oil arian path, we know
that it has to be big O of E. The reason is
that the calculations we're doing to compute
the oil arian path are all linear in the number
of edges. Think about computing the internet
degrees or the depth for search both of those
only take big O of a time. So the whole thing
is linear. And the number of edges. And now
let's have a look at some pseudocode. To find
an oil arian path, let's have a look at some
of the variables we're going to need. The
first three here are inputs to the algorithm,
which are n, the number of nodes in the graph,
M, the number of edges in the graph. And lastly,
g the graph itself stored as an adjacency
list. Then there's the in and out arrays I
talked about earlier to track the in and out
degrees of every node. Lastly, there's a variable
called path, which is a linked list which
is going to store the oil arian path solution.
You can also use an array or some other data
structure to store the solution. But I find
that a linked list simplifies the code to
actually find an oil arian path on our graph
G we're going to call the find oil arian path
method. The first thing we want to do is verify
that an oil arian path exists. To do that,
we first need to count the in and out degree
of each node. And once we know that, we can
verify that the graph is a good candidate
for nor Larian path. So here we are looking
at the methods which count the in and out
degrees of each node. And verifies that Euler
and path can exist. The count in and out degrees
method is very simple. Simply loop over all
the edges in the graph and increment the internet
degree arrays for incoming and outgoing edges.
The graph has Euler and path method checks
all the preconditions for an oil arian path
we're going to keep track of the number of
start nodes and n nodes that we encounter.
A start node is a node with one extra outgoing
edge and an end node is a node with one extra
incoming edge. If at any point we encounter
a node which either has more than one extra
outgoing edge or more than one extra incoming
edge, we know that this graph is not oil,
Larian. And we can return false immediately
because of symmetry I believe you only need
one of these checks. But to be explicit, I
put both conditions there. Next up, I check
if the current node is a start node or an
end node, you cannot be a start node and an
end node which is why this is an else if clause.
The last thing to do is check if we have a
valid number of start nodes and add nodes
for our path either there are no designated
Start and End nodes that is the oil arian
circuit case which is also an Euler path,
or there are exactly one start node and one
and nodes. Coming back to the main method.
The next step is to find that starting node
and perform a depth first search to actually
find the oil there in path. Let's begin with
finding the starting node. We're going to
start by assuming that the start node is node
zero, although this will likely change in
the future. Since we know that at this point,
our graph is an Euler area and graph. This
means that if we encounter a node with one
extra outgoing edge that this node must be
the unique starting node and we can return
that nodes index immediately. Otherwise, we
just want to ensure that we begin on a node
with an outgoing edge, our default node node
zero might not have an outgoing edge. In fact,
this check prevents us from starting the depth
first search on a singleton node, then return
the start node after the loop. The depth first
search method is where things start to get
interesting. This depth first search method
takes one argument and that is the current
node. We're at the while loop in the depth
first search loops while the current node
still has outgoing unvisited edges. It does
this by looking in the outer array at the
current node and checking if there are still
outgoing edges. The next line selects the
next unvisited outgoing edge from the current
node from our adjacency list. It also decrements
the number of outgoing unvisited edges from
the current node. So if you haven't caught
on already, the outer array is currently serving
two purposes. one purpose is to track whether
or not there are still outgoing edges and
the other is to index into the adjacency list
to select the next outgoing edge. This assumes
the adjacency list stores edges in a data
structure that is indexable and constant time
just like me, right? If not, say you're using
an adjacency list composed of linked lists,
then you can use an iterator to iterate over
For all the edges once we've selected the
next unvisited edge, we visit that edge by
calling the depth first search method recursively.
Once we exit the loop, append the current
node to the front of the solution. Returning
back to the main method. The last thing we
need to do is check that we have actually
found the correct number of edges for an oil
arian path. It might be the case that our
graph is disconnected and we found an oil
arian path on one of the many connected components
of our graph, in which case it's impossible
to actually have an oil arian path so we return
null in that case, otherwise, we simply return
our path Today we're going to look at some
source code for the oil arian path algorithm.
Awesome. Here we are in the source code for
the oil arian path algorithm. This code works
by first instantiating this oil Larian path
solver class and then calling a method to
fetch the oil arian path itself should it
exist. Let's begin by taking a look at the
class constructor in the constructor, what
you do is you pass in a directed graph to
the algorithm as input and then the constructor
verifies that you actually passed in a graph
that's not know and it also initializes a
few variables including n the number of nodes
in the graph and the path linked list. Before
we go too far. Let's have a look at some of
the instance variables for this class. We
already talked about n the number of nodes
in the graph. Next we have edge count which
we will compute dynamically from the input
graph followed by
in
and out which are integer arrays to track
the in and out degree of each node. Then we
have path which is the oil arian path solution,
as well as a reference to the input graph.
So once you create an instance of this class,
there's only one public method and that's
get or Larian path, which does exactly what
it says it will return to you an integer path
consisting of the nodes you need to traverse
to get a valid or Larian path or know if no
path exists. So there's a few things that
get Euler and path does which we'll cover
step by step. The first thing in the get Euler
and path method is the setup method. So let's
have a look at that first. All this method
does is loop through all the edges and increment
the in and out array degrees, as well as compute
the number of edges in the graph, which is
being tracked by the edge count variable.
Back to the get Euler and path method. The
next thing is to check if the edge count is
zero and return null if we don't have any
edges to work with. Following this I called
the graph has Euler and path method which
verifies that our graph actually has no relation
path because most graphs don't. The graph
has Euler and path method is also fairly simple.
What we want to do is make sure that no node
has too many outgoing edges or too many incoming
edges as well as ensure that there's the correct
amount of Start and End nodes for an oil arian
path to exist, the variables start nodes and
end nodes keep track of how many nodes have
either exactly one extra outgoing edge or
one extra incoming edge for an Euler and path
to exist, there has to be at most one start
and end node. So when we're inside the for
loop, we have three conditions. The first
is to identify if the current node has too
many incoming or outgoing edges, which mathematically
means that the difference between the in and
out degree or vice versa is greater than one.
In this case return false because the path
is impossible, there will be no oil arian
path in such an event. The other conditions
we care about are whether the current node
might be a start node or an end node. And
if it is, then we increment the start node
and node counters respectively. The last step
is to actually check that we have the correct
number of storage nodes and n nodes and return
the boolean value. Returning back to the get
Euler and path method. The next thing in the
algorithm is to actually find the earlier
and path now that we know what exists. To
do this, we find a valid starting node and
feed that as the first node to the depth first
search method. So let's have a look at both
of those. We don't want to start out or they're
in path anywhere as we saw in the first video,
because this doesn't ensure that we find an
Euler and path even though we know one exists,
the fine start node method does exactly what
it sounds Like it looks for a node which is
a valid starting node, meaning a node with
exactly one extra outgoing edge or in the
case of an oil arian circuit, just any node
with an outgoing edge, it's important that
we start at a node with an outgoing edge because
our graph might contain Singleton nodes that
have no outgoing edges, but another component
in the graph might have outgoing edges, which
is where we really want to start if we are
to find an oil arian path.
Next up is the depth first search method where
things get interesting. It turns out the depth
for search method is really short and could
even be shorter but at the expense of readability.
Remember that when calling this method the
first note is the starting node, which is
the at variable in this method, which if you
haven't guessed that yet is the current node
index we're currently at. In essence, what's
happening in this method is that while the
current node still has unvisited edges, we're
going to select the next node to explore and
call the depth first search method recursively.
Each time we take an edge, we decrease the
number of outgoing edges for that note, which
means that eventually there will be no more
outgoing edges for the current node and the
loop will terminate. Once this happens, we
can add the current node to the front of the
solution. The key realization In this method,
I think, is that you have to notice that the
out array is being used as both a way of determining
if there are any unvisited edges left at the
current node as well as an index for reaching
into his adjacency list to grab the next note
to visit. Let's go back up to the get oil
arian path method. Once we've finished executing
the depth first search, the next thing to
do is ensure that we found an oil arian path,
it could be the case that the graph is disconnected
into multiple components, in which case the
correct thing to do is to return null because
no oil arian path exists. Checking that the
graph is disconnected is not something the
graph has Euler and path method verifies.
And this is intentional, because it's easier
to do after running the depth first search
by ensuring that the solution actually has
a size equal to edge count plus one. The next
thing I do before returning the solution,
which is optional, is simply to empty the
contents of the link list into a primitive
integer array. just for convenience. I do
this because it's easier for the caller to
index an array than it is a linked list. The
rest of this file are just helper methods
for creating a directed graph and adding directed
edges to the graph. I also provide two examples,
one from the previous slides and another that
I made up, I encourage you to look them over
to understand how this program works. Today
we're talking about minimum spanning trees.
And in particular, we're talking about prims
algorithm and how it is used to find minimum
spanning trees. So what is a minimum spanning
tree on a weighted graph, a minimum spanning
tree or just MST for short is a tree, which
spans the whole graph connecting all nodes
together while minimizing the total edge cost.
It's important to note that your spanning
tree cannot contain cycles. Otherwise, it's
not a tree. Here's a weighted graph with nodes
labeled zero through six with various edges
of different costs. One possible minimum spanning
tree is the following edges highlighted in
green, whose edge costs some tonight, there's
no way to connect all the nodes together and
get a lower cost then this, note that even
though the minimum spanning tree in this graph
is unique, in general, it's possible for a
graph to have multiple msts of equal costs.
Alright, hopefully you've been paying attention
because now it's your turn. I'm going to present
to you some weighted graphs, and your job
is to identify any possible minimum spanning
tree you can find. Let's begin with this graph.
Take a moment, pause the video and find any
minimum spanning tree you can. So one possible
minimum spanning tree is the following with
a cost of 14. Again, minimum spanning trees
are not unique. So there could be another
valid minimum spanning tree here, but they'll
all have a cost of 14. Let's do another one.
Can you find a minimum spanning tree here?
I'll give you a moment. Here's one possible
answer with the minimum spanning tree. Hi
In green with a cost of 39. All right, one
last graph, I promise. This one is a bit of
a trick question. Because there is no minimum
spanning tree, all the nodes must be connected
on a single component for a spanning tree
to exist.
Let's change focus and start talking about
prims algorithm. prims is one of my favorite
minimum spanning tree algorithms because of
how simple and how intuitive it is. By nature,
it's a greedy algorithm, which always selects
the next best edge and adds it to the minimum
spanning tree. So it works very well on dense
graphs, which have a lot of edges. However,
a few downsides to prims is that it's not
easily parallelizable, or at least not as
parallelizable as other well known minimum
spanning tree algorithms. And it's slightly
harder but not impossible to find the minimum
spanning forest of a graph. There are two
well known versions of prims I want to discuss.
The first is the common the lazy version,
which runs in big O of E log e. And then there's
the improved eager version, which runs in
big O of E log V, but requires a slightly
different data structure. We're going to have
a look at both, but this video is primarily
going to focus on the lazy version. Let's
start by looking at the lazy version, just
because it's slightly easier to implement.
Here's the general idea, maintain a priority
queue that sorts edges based on minimum edge
cost. This prior queue is used to tell you
which node to go to next and what edge which
is used to get there. Then the algorithm begins
and we start on any starting node s and Mark
s as visited and iterate over all the edges
of s and add them to the priority queue. From
this point on, while the priority queue is
not empty, and the minimum spanning tree has
not been formed, dq the next best edge from
the priority queue. If the dq edge is not
outdated, which it could be if we visit the
node that edge points to via another path
before getting to the edge we just pulled.
Then we want to mark the current node as visited
and add the selected edge to the priority
queue. If you selected a stale outdated edge,
then you can simply pull again, then repeat
the process of iterating over the current
nodes edges, adding them to the part of the
queue. And while doing all this, take care
not to add edges, which already point two
visited notes. This will reduce the number
of outdated edges in the priority queue. Let's
have a look at an example. Suppose we have
this weighted undirected graph, and we want
to find any minimum spanning tree. An important
thing to keep in mind is that while the graph
above represents an undirected graph, our
internal adjacency list representation has
each undirected edge stored as two directed
edges. So the actual internal representation
typically looks something like this, which
is a lot easier to work with. Along with a
graph I will also be keeping track of the
edges currently in the priority queue on the
right, I will be representing edges as triplets
containing the start node of the edge, the
end node of the edge and the edge cost. Lastly,
I will be coloring nodes as either blue for
unvisited orange revisiting or gray for visited.
So let's begin prims on node zero. So iterate
over all the outgoing edges and add them to
the priority. The first edge we're going to
add to the priority queue is the edge from
zero to one with a cost of 10. Then the edge
from zero to two with a cost of one, and finally
the edge from zero to three with a cost of
four. Now we look inside our priority queue
and we pull the next most promising edge and
add it to the minimum spanning tree the edge
from zero to two with a cost of one has the
lowest value in the priority queue. So it
gets added to the minimum spanning tree. This
also means that the next node we process is
node two. So next we iterate through all the
edges of node two and add them to
the priority queue while iterating over the
outgoing edges of node to realize that we
may encounter edges which point to already
visited notes. We do not want to add these
to the party queue because they are of no
use the reason we Don't include edges which
already point to visited nodes is that either
they overlap with an edge already part of
the minimum spanning tree, as is the case
with the edge on the slide. Or they would
introduce a cycle in the minimum spanning
tree if included, which is forbidden. So the
next best edge in the priority queue is the
edge from two to three with a cost of two,
so it gets added to the minimum spanning tree.
This also means that the next node we process
is node three. The same process of adding
edges to the priority queue and pulling the
smallest edge continues until the minimum
spanning tree is complete. I'll let the animation
play until something interesting happens.
All right, notice that the next best edge
we pull from the priority queue is an edge
which already points to a visiting node node
one. This means that the edge is outdated
and stale, because we found a cheaper path
to node one. So we can safely ignore this
edge and pull again. The next edge is also
stale. So let's keep pulling.
So what happens when we have two edges with
the same cost in the priority queue, which
one gets pulled first, in practice, this doesn't
matter. So we can assume that edge 258 gets
pulled first because it was added first.
We can now start premise because the minimum
spanning tree is complete. We know the minimum
spanning tree is complete because the number
of edges in the tree is one less than the
number of nodes in the graph. This is precisely
the definition of a tree. If we collapse the
graph back into the undirected edge view,
it becomes clear which edges are included
in the minimum spanning tree. To find the
cost of the minimum spanning trees simply
sum up the cost of all the edges which were
selected to be part of the minimum spanning
tree and this totals to 20. Great, we now
understand the gist of the lazy implementation
of prims. Let's have a look at some pseudocode.
Let me first define a few variables that we
will need. First is n the number of nodes
and graph. The variable pq represents the
priority queue data structure, it stores the
edge objects based on minimum edge cost. Again,
each edge object consists of a start node
and node and an edge cost. Next is G which
represents the graph we're working with. g
represents an adjacency list of weighted edges
in G every undirected edge is represented
as two directed edges. As a side note, if
your graph is extremely dense, meaning it
has numerous edges, you should probably prefer
using an adjacency matrix instead of an adjacency
list for efficiency and space gains. And lastly,
a visited Boolean array of size n, which keeps
track of whether node AI has been visited
or not. So on this slide is the whole algorithm
for the lazy implementation of krems. Let's
go over it one step at a time. The function
takes one argument s which is the start node
index and by default S is set to note zero.
That I define a few more variables that will
need just inside this function. M is a constant
representing the number of expected edges
in the minimum spanning tree. Edge count is
the number of edges we currently have included
in the minimum spanning tree. This variable
is to make sure that the tree spans the whole
graph. MST cast tracks the total cost of the
minimum spanning tree and finally MST edges
is an array which holds edges which we have
in Included in the minimum spanning tree.
The first actual a bit of logic we do is add
all the outgoing edges from S to the priority
queue with the Add edges method. So let's
look at this method and see what's going on
in there. Alright, here we are at the Add
edges function, the first thing I do is mark
the current node as visited. Next, I iterate
through all the outgoing edges of the current
node. And if the destination node is unvisited
add the edge to the priority queue. So that's
all this method does is it goes through all
the edges of a node and adds them to the priority
queue, if appropriate. Once we've added the
first set of edges to the priority queue,
the algorithm really begins and we enter a
while loop while the priority queue is not
empty and the minimum spanning tree is not
complete, keep iterating then inside the loop,
we pull the next best edge out of the priority
queue and grab a reference to the destination
node index. This is a node the edge is pointing
at this next line is a very important it's
the logic that skips adding an edge to the
priority queue. If that edge points to an
already visited node again, edges can become
stale or outdated in the priority queue if
the node they're pointing at becomes visited
via another path.
Next,
actually add the edge to the minimum spanning
tree by adding it to the MST edges array.
And while adding the edge to the tree also
sum over the edge costs. The last thing we
want to do is call the Add edges method with
the new current node. Recall that this will
add all the outgoing edges pointing to unvisited
nodes to the priority queue. And the very
last thing is we make sure that we have actually
found a minimum spanning tree that spans the
entire graph. And we return the edges along
with the MST cost. Today we're talking about
finding minimum spanning trees with prims
algorithm. The lazy implementation of prims
inserts edges into a priority queue. This
results in each pole operation on the priority
queue to be big O of log e in the eager version,
we maintain the idea that instead of adding
edges to the priority queue, which can later
become stale that instead we should track
node edge key value pairs that can easily
be updated and pulled to determine the next
best edge we should add to the minimum spanning
tree. For this ultimate sense, there's a key
realization that needs to happen. And that
is for any MST with directed edges, each node
is paired with exactly one of its incoming
edges. That is except for the start node.
One way to see this is on a minimum spanning
tree with multiple edges leaving a node but
only ever one edge entering a node. Let's
have a closer look at what I mean. Suppose
we have this undirected graph. The equivalent
directed version of this graph looks like
this. A possible minimum spanning tree starting
at node zero might be the following highlighted
in green. Now notice that on this directed
MST, each node is paired with exactly one
edge except for the starting node. So in a
sense, there seems to be a relationship we
can take advantage of here, which is that
each node is paired with exactly one incoming
edge. In the eager version, we are trying
to determine which of a nodes incoming edges
we should select to include in the MST. The
main difference coming from the lazy version
is that instead of adding edges to a priority
queue, as we iterate over the edges of a node,
we're going to relax that is to update the
destination nodes most promising incoming
edge. So you might be asking yourself the
question, how are we going to efficiently
update and retrieve these node edge pairs?
Well, one solution is to use an index priority
queue, or simply IP queue for short, which
can efficiently update and pull key value
pairs. You can think of an IP queue as the
data structure you would get if a hash table
and a priority queue had a baby together.
It supports sorted key value pair updates
and pull operations in a logarithmic time.
Using this new approach would reduce the overall
time complexity from big O of E like E to
big O of E log V, since there can only Li
b v node edge pairs in the IP queue. If you're
interested in learning more about the index
priority queue data structure and how it's
implemented, I would highly recommend my dish
structures video on the subject. I will link
it in the description below if you need to
catch up, the implementation for the eager
version is slightly different and the algorithm
goes as follows maintain an IP queue of size
v that sorts vertex edge pairs v e, based
on minimum edge cost of he started the algorithm
on any node s. Marchesa has visited and relax
all the edges of S. Relaxing this context
refers to updating the entry for node v in
the IP q from V old edge to V new edge. If
the new edge has a better cost than the old
edge, then while the index priority queue
is not empty, and a minimum spanning tree
has not been formed, in dq the next best vertex
edge pair v e from the IP Q, Mark note v as
visited and add edge e to the MST. Lastly,
relax all edges of V while making sure not
to relax any edge pointing to a node which
has already been visited.
All right, I think
it's time to see an example. Suppose we have
the following weighted undirected graph and
we want to find any minimum spanning tree.
One thing to remember is that while we're
dealing with an undirected graph, we will
be internally representing it as a directed
graph, where each undirected edge is stored
as two directed edges, I will be keeping track
of all node edge key value pairs on the right
and update them accordingly as the algorithm
executes. So you can think of the red box
as the contents of the index priority queue.
Let's begin the algorithm on node zero, start
by iterating over all the edges of zero and
relax them during the relaxing process. Add
a node edge pair to the index priority queue
if it does not exist yet, otherwise update
the value if the new edge has a better cost
than what already exists. The first node edge
pair we add is node two with the incoming
edge from zero to two with a cost of zero.
And similarly for the rest of zeros edges.
The next best node edge pair based on the
minimum edge cost is node two with the incoming
edge from node zero. Now iterate through all
the edges of node two and relax all edges
character ignore edges pointing to already
visited nodes like the one on this slide.
The Edge 256 has a better cost going to node
five than the edge from node zero to node
five with a cost of seven. So update the index
party queue with this new edge I will denote
IP q updates with a purple box around the
edge being updated. The next best node edge
pair is no three with the edge coming from
node zero with a cost of five. Now iterate
through all the edges of node three and relax
all edges. The Edge coming from node three
offers a better value. So I update the value
for node one in the index party queue with
the new edge. Add a new key value pair entry
for node six since node six has not yet inside
the index priority queue. Update the value
for node five with the new better edge we
just found. And from this point on, I will
let the animation play please try and follow
along.
All right, and that's the algorithm you can
see that the minimum spanning tree we found
consists of the edges highlighted in green.
If we collapse the graph back into its undirected
edge view it becomes clear which edges are
included. In the minimum spanning tree, you
can also get the MST cost by adding the values
of all the edges in the spanning tree for
a cost of nine. Let's have a look at some
pseudocode. For the eager implementation of
prims. You'll notice that it's almost identical
to the lazy version except for a few key details
which I will highlight. First is n, which
is still the number of nodes in the graph,
followed by the variable IP Q, which represents
the index party Q. Instead of a traditional
priority queue which stores node index edge
object pairs edge objects are still represented
as start node and node edge cost triplets
with the node index being an integer. G is
once again our graph adjacency list of weighted
edges. Remember that in je every undirected
edge is represented as two directed edges.
There's also the whole story about whether
we should be using an adjacency list or using
an adjacency matrix to represent our graph
when running prims. Because we know that this
can greatly impact performance. I was curious
and did some analysis comparing the adjacency
list versus the adjacency matrix. And the
results I got were interesting. this dotted
line graph shows the performance of using
an adjacency list in blue versus an adjacency
matrix in green, and the x axis represents
the graph edge density percentage, and the
y axis indicates performance measured in milliseconds.
As you can see, for graphs with fewer edges,
the adjacency list outperforms the adjacency
matrix. But as the edge density increases,
the adjacency matrix becomes the obvious choice.
You may be wondering why the adjacency matrix,
his performance starts to increase after the
middle point where the graph starts to become
more and more dense. This is an excellent
question. And my guess is that the denser
the graph, the fewer relaxation operations
need to be performed, which is an expensive
part of prims algorithm. Since the time to
iterate over all the edges of a node is constant,
but fewer relaxation operations are needed,
performance should increase as a result, but
I may be wrong. Even still, the results are
interesting. And the takeaway is that the
graph representation you choose can greatly
impact the performance of your algorithm depending
on whether your graph is sparse
or dense. All right, back to the pseudocode.
The last variable is the visited Boolean array
of size n, which tracks whether node AI has
been visited or not. Now let's have a look
at the actual algorithm for eager prims. In
the first block, I define a few more variables
that will need m the number of expected edges
in the MST edge count the number of edges
we currently have included in the MST, this
variable is used to make sure the tree spans
the whole graph, then is MST cost which tracks
the total cost of our minimum spanning tree.
And finally, MST edges, which is an array
that holds the edges we have included in the
MST. After this, I call the relaxed edges
at node method passing in the start node as
an argument. Let's have a look at the relax
edges that node method to understand what's
happening in there. Alright, here we are,
you'll notice that this method takes a single
argument which is the current node we care
about. The first thing we do is mark the current
node as visited so we don't visit again in
the future. Then I reach into our graph adjacency
list and get all the edges going outwards
from the current node. As we enter the loop
and start iterating over all the outgoing
edges. The first thing I do inside the loop
is grab a reference to the destination node
index. This is the node the edges pointing
at next skip edges which point at already
visited nodes. Now here's the bit where we
actually relax the edge first check if the
IP q contains the key with the value of the
destination node. If it doesn't, then add
the edge to the IP queue for the first time.
Otherwise try and improve the cheapest edge
at desk node index with the current edge in
the priority queue back inside the main method.
Next up keep looping while the IP queue is
not empty. And we have not yet completed the
MST after extract the next best node index,
edge object pair From the IP queue based on
minimum edge cost, include the selected edge
as part of the MST and some over the edge
costs. Lastly, relax all edges of the current
node and repeat until the loop breaks outside
the main loop check if we have successfully
created a spanning tree. This might not be
the case if some of the nodes are unreachable.
But assuming that that is not the case, return
the MST cost and the edges which make up the
spanning tree. And that concludes the pseudocode
for prims algorithm. All right, here we are
on the source code for prims implemented in
Java. At the top here, I posted some instructions
on how to download and run the script in case
you want to play around with it a little bit.
Let's begin by taking a look at the main method
right over here. The first thing I do is set
up a graph we want to find the minimum spanning
tree of In fact, it's the same graph we had
in the slides in the previous video. To create
the graph I call the helper method create
empty graph and initialize an adjacency list
of size and and afterwards add various undirected
edges of different weights to the graph. Once
the graph is set up, I create a minimum spanning
tree solver and pass in the graph we just
created. The solver is able to tell us whether
a minimum spanning tree exists, what the cost
of the MST is, as well as get all the edges,
which make up the MST. The output of running
the script is illustrated below right here,
you can see that this particular minimum spanning
tree has a class of nine and it has these
six edges. If you were curious as to how the
adjacency list gets initialized and how I
add this to the graph, here's the code that
does exactly that. Next up is a class struct
which represents a directed edge used in the
graph. One important thing to note about this
class is that it implements the comparable
interface and overrides the Compare to method.
This simply means that edges are able to be
sorted in reference to one another. Based
on the minimum edge cost. This is important
for the index priority queue because it needs
to know how to compare edge objects with one
another to sort them.
After the edge class is the minimum spanning
tree solver, where all the interesting logic
happens. In this class, I store a whole bunch
of variables to help us out. The first two
inputs are n the number of nodes in the graph,
which I get from the constructor, and the
graph adjacency list itself. Internally I
store a Boolean solve variable to track whether
we have already computed the minimum spanning
tree so that we don't need to do it again.
Once we've already solved the problem, the
MST exists variable tells you whether a minimum
spanning tree was found in the input graph.
It's important to note that by default, this
value is false. The Boolean visited array
is used to keep track of whether node AI has
been visited or not. And lastly is the variable
IP queue, which is short for indexed priority
queue which is a data structure I have defined
below. The outputs to this class include the
minimum spanning tree costs and edges which
make up the minimum spanning tree if one exists.
After the constructor initialization there
are two important methods to know about there
is the get MST method for retrieving the MST
edges and get MST cost which gets the spanning
tree cost both of these methods work in the
same manner they both call the solve method
and then check whether the minimum spanning
tree exists and returns a value or no therefore
the real method we care about is the solve
method. So let's have a look at that.
The solve method is only ever executed once
because we mark the solve the boolean value
as true the first time solve is called and
the other times the method returns early.
The first thing I do in the solve method is
initialize some more variables and allocate
some memory for the arrays we will be using.
M is the expected number of edges in a minimum
spanning tree And edge count is the number
of edges we have currently included in the
minimum spanning tree so far. Next I initialize
an index the priority queue of size. And this
particular index barbecue is implemented using
a dare heap. So we need to provide a node
degree for the underlying supporting heap
structure, I arbitrarily choose the base two
logarithm of the number of nodes, which actually
seems to give a pretty good performance, although
Typically, this is an implementation detail
that you do not need to worry about. The first
actual bit of logic we're going to do is call
relax edges at node four, node zero, this
adds the initial set of edges to the priority
queue. Let's scroll down and take a closer
look at that method, which is right here.
The first thing we do is marked the current
note as visited so that we don't visit it
again in the future. Then I reach into the
adjacency list and get all the outgoing edges
from the current node. As we enter the loop
and start iterating over all the outgoing
edges. The first thing I do inside the loop
is grab a reference to the destination node
index, this is the node that edge is pointing
at next skip edges which point to already
visited nodes because we know that we don't
want to process those. Now here's the bit
where we actually relax the edge. First check
if the index priority queue contains the key
with the value of the destination node. If
it doesn't, then add the edge to the index
priority queue for the first time. Otherwise,
try and improve the cheapest edge at the destination
node index with the current edge in the priority
queue by calling the decrease function. So
that's all for the relax edges at node method.
Let's scroll back up to the main implementation
right here. So after we add the initial set
of edges to the index priority queue, we enter
a while loop and loop while the index party
queue is not empty and a minimum set burning
tree has not been formed inside the loop pull
out the next best node index edge pair. The
destination node can also be found by checking
which node the directed edge we just pulled
out of the queue is pointing at after that
add the pulled edge to the minimum spanning
tree by placing it inside the MST edges array
and sum over the edge costs. Finally, relax
all the edges of the new current node. This
process continues and we keep pulling the
next best edge and slowly start building our
minimum spanning tree until eventually the
loop breaks. For last thing we need to do
is set the MST exists variable to check if
we have actually found a minimum spanning
tree. If the edge count is equal to m, then
we have successfully computed a minimum spanning
tree Otherwise, the graph is disconnected
in some way and no spanning tree exists. So
that's all for the eager implementation of
prims. The only piece of the puzzle that might
still be unclear is how the index party queue
implementation works.
Here's the index priority queue implementation.
However, this data structure merits a video
on its own. Today we're going to start tackling
the field of network flow by understanding
what max flow is and in particular how we
can use the Ford Fulkerson method. To find
it, finding the maximum flow begins with having
what's called a flow graph. This is a graph
where edges have a certain maximum capacity
which cannot be exceeded. edges also have
a flow value, which is how many units of flow
are passing through that edge. Initially,
the flow is zero for all edges everywhere
until we run a max flow algorithm on it. There
are also two special types of nodes in the
flow graph the source node and the sync node,
usually denoted as s and t respectively. The
maximum flow problem asks with an infinite
input source, how much flow can we push through
the network without exceeding the capacity
of any edge and it's not at all obvious how
one should figure that out. maximum flow can
be used in numerous situations where edges
and nodes can represent any number of things.
For instance, suppose the edges are roads,
cars or pipes of water, wires with electric
current, and so on. Each of those has a certain
capacity value we can associate with the maximum
flow on the other hand would represent the
volume have water that can flow through the
pipe. So the number of cars the roads can
sustain and traffic or the net electric current
that your system can sustain. Effectively,
the maximum flow is a bottleneck value for
the amount of traffic your network can handle.
And that is going from the source to the sink.
Under all those constraints. The maximum flow
for this particular network is seven. And
you can tell because after running the maximum
flow algorithm, the sum of the flows attached
to the sink node is seven. Running a maximum
flow algorithm is used to determine how much
flow each edge should receive to achieve the
overall maximum flow. Note that there might
be multiple ways of achieving the maximum
flow by giving each edge different flow values,
but overall solutions will have the same maximum
flow value. Let's dig deeper into how to find
the maximum flow. To begin with, you will
need a flow graph which consists of directed
edges, which are also called arcs. Each directed
edge has a certain capacity which can receive
a certain amount of flow at all times the
flow running through an edge must be less
than or equal to the capacity. This intuitively
makes sense. Because if we allow more flow
than what the capacity permits, it means something
has to go wrong. When an edge becomes overcapacity
in some manner, in means that we've pushed
the system past its limit. In the context
of edges representing pipes with water it
means your pipe broke or it leaked. If your
edges a wire with electric current, it means
your wire literally fried or melted exploded
or something bad happened to it because there
was too much electric current. This is not
good. So this is why we don't allow more flow
than capacity. each edge in the flow graph
has a certain flow and capacity specified
by the two values separated by a slash adjacent
to each edge. Originally, the flow through
each edge is zero and the capacity is a non
negative value to find the maximum flow and
also the min cut as a byproduct. The Ford
Fulkerson method repeatedly finds augmenting
paths through the residual graph and augments
the flow until no more augmenting paths can
be found. So you're probably asking yourself
at this moment, what is an augmenting path?
What the heck is a residual graph? And what
do you mean by augment the flow? All right,
let me explain. We'll do them one by one.
an augmenting path is a path of edges in the
residual graph with capacity greater than
zero from the source s to the sink t in orange.
Here I have highlighted a possible augmenting
path. The key thing to remember about an augmenting
path is that it can only flow through edges
which aren't fully saturated yet. In fact,
you know you've achieved the maximum flow
when there are no more augmenting paths left
to be found. How to actually find an augmenting
path is a detail left unspecified by the Ford
Fulkerson method for flexibility. For now
let's assume that we're using a depth first
search. Something else to know is that every
augmenting path will have what I call a bottleneck
value, which is the smallest edge along the
path,
you can find the value of the bottleneck by
taking the difference between the capacity
and the current flow of an edge. For this
augmenting path, the bottleneck value is six,
we can use the bottleneck value to argument
the flow along the path. augmenting the flow
simply means to update the flow values of
the edges along the augmenting path. Here
you can see that I've increased the flow of
each edge along the augmenting path by exactly
six units. However, we're not done augmenting
the flow, we not only need to increase the
flow along the forward edges, but also decrease
the flow along the backwards edges, which
are called residual edges, the residual edges
or the dotted edges going backwards in the
reverse order of the augmenting path. The
logic behind having residual edges is to undo
bad choices of augmenting paths which do not
lead to a maximum flow effectively, we don't
know which are the best or even correct augmenting
paths to take. So this mechanism enables us
to freely find any augmenting paths without
having to worry about whether or not we'll
be able to achieve the maximum flow. It should
be mentioned that residual edges become valid
edges to take when finding an augmenting path
in later iterations. So if we take a step
back, you can think of every edge in the original
graph as having a residual edge with a flow
and capacity of zero, which is not usually
shown now that we know what residual edges
are. The term residual graph simply means
the graph which also contains residual edges,
not just the original edges given and flow
graph. So generally speaking, when I mentioned
the flow graph, I usually mean the residual
graph. So, here's a good question you might
have at this point, the residual edges shown
have a capacity of zero, aren't those forbidden?
How does that work? So here's the thing. With
this method of augmenting the flow, you have
to think of the remaining capacity of an edge
IE residual or not as the difference between
the capacity and the flow of that edge. That
is the difference between the capacity and
the flow is the true remaining capacity for
that edge. This ensures that the remaining
capacity of an edge is always non negative,
even if the flow can be negative. For example,
in the residual edges we have right now, zero
minus minus six is six, so we know that all
our residual edges actually have a remaining
capacity of six. So the algorithm proceeds
and the Ford Fulkerson method continues to
repeatedly find augmenting path after augmenting
path and to augment the flow until no more
augmenting paths from s to t can be found
the QE ideation to make at this point is that
the some of the bottleneck values that we
acquire with each augmenting paths will result
in the maximum flow. And that's the whole
premise of this algorithm. It doesn't matter
so much how to find augmenting paths. But
so long as you keep solving the bottleneck
values which they produce, you'll find the
maximum flow. So let's keep finding augmenting
paths. Remember that we can only select edges
whose remaining capacity is greater than zero
to be part of the augmenting path. So the
bottleneck for this augmenting path is four
since four is the minimum of all the remaining
capacities along this augmenting path. Here's
another augmenting path from the source to
the sink, you'll notice that we're actually
using one of the residual edges we created
earlier in this path. You'll also notice that
there are two purple edges in this slide.
This is just a coincidence, since both of
those edges have the same bottleneck value
of six, then we argument the flow as we do.
I'll let the animation play for this next
one. And at the end, we can see that if we
sum all our bottleneck values 646 and four,
we're able to achieve the maximum flow which
is 20. In terms of the time complexity, the
Ford Fulkerson method derives its complexity
from how we actually find those augmenting
paths, which as we know is left as an unspecified
detail. If you assume that finding augmenting
paths are found by doing a depth first search,
then the algorithm runs in a time complexity
of a big O of F being the maximum flow times
IE the number of edges in the graph. Here's
a graph where we can derive the time complexity.
Suppose that the side edges have very high
capacity values of 100. And the middle edge
has a capacity of one, you can clearly tell
that the maximum flow should be 200. Because
you can run two augmenting paths with the
flow values of 100 on the top and the bottom
of the graph from the source to the sink.
However, recall that a depth for search traversal
is essentially random. So it's possible for
you to pick that middle edge with a capacity
of one every single time. And what that'll
do is it'll limit flow, you can push from
the source the sink to be one, so one is always
going to be your bottleneck value, so you're
never going to be able to argument the flow
by more than one unit. This results in flipping
back and forth between the same two alternating
paths for 200 iterations, which really kills
your time complexity. Luckily, much faster
algorithms and better heuristics exist to
find the maximum flow value. One example is
Edmonds Karp, which is Ford Fulkerson. But
instead of using a depth first search, use
a breadth first search to find the shortest
augmenting path from the source to the sink
in every iteration. There's also capacity
scaling, which is the idea of picking larger
paths. First to reduce the number of paths
you need to find overall. And this turns out
to work really well, at least from my empirical
tests. Then there's dynex, which uses a combination
of a breadth first search to first find a
layered graph that guides edges towards the
sink, which you then use a depth first search
to actually find the augmenting paths. There's
also this idea of push relabel algorithms
which were differently than the algorithms
we've discussed here, which try and find augmenting
paths instead, push reliable algorithms maintain
this concept of a pre flow if you will, to
find the maximum flow of a network. Please
be mindful that the time complexities posted
here are very pessimistic and practice running
maximum flow if any of these operates much
faster. So it's very hard to compare the performance
of two flow algorithms solely based on the
complexity today, we're taking a look at the
source code for the Ford Fulkerson method
implemented with a depth first search. The
goal of this video is to show you how to set
up the following flow graph and find the maximum
flow through it. So after we run the maximum
flow algorithm, we should get a graph similar
to this one with flow running through some
but not all of the edges and achieving the
maximum flow of 23. The source code and the
example I have lined up for you today can
both be found on GitHub. There's a link in
the description for today, I encourage you
to check that out and also play along as we're
going over the source code. All right, here
we are in the source code written in Java.
This program has three main supporting classes,
an edge class, a network flow solver base,
and the Ford Focus in depth first search solver.
However, before we get into any of those,
I want to take a look at the main method where
I actually use the classes above to solve
the flow problem we just saw. I know a lot
of people struggle setting up the flow graph,
which is usually somewhat of a mystery. So
I want to clear that up. The first thing I
recommend you do every time you set up a flow
problem is initialize three variables, and
the number of nodes in your graph that is
including the source and the sink nodes. And
then what I recommend you do is you actually
label the source and the sink nodes and assign
them indices. And what I usually end up doing
is I say, the source node equals index n minus
one and the sink equals and minus two, the
rest of the nodes in your graph should then
have indices between zero and n minus three
inclusive, I've always found this to be the
easiest way to set up your flow graph. Next,
I create the flow solver by providing the
three variables n, s and t as inputs to the
solver so it knows how many nodes there are
and which nodes are labeled the source on
the sink. Then I use the solver to actually
create the flow graph by adding edges with
different capacities. The next step is to
hook up the edges to the source, those would
be the ones shown in this picture. Then I
carefully hook up all the middle edges.
And lastly, the edges leading into the sink.
It's usually always these three steps. And
for most of the time, your graph is bipartite.
So the middle edges are even simpler to set
up. After this I call the get max flow method
on the solver which actually runs the Ford
Fulkerson max flow depth first search and
returns an integer value for this graph, we're
expecting a maximum of 23 followed by printing
the max flow, I also display all the interesting
edges of the residual graph. First, I get
the residual graph from the solver after executing
the max flow and iterate over all the edges
and just display the flow on each edge. Let's
actually run this program and see what the
output looks like. So I just popped open a
terminal. And for those of you who also have
a terminal open and want to play along first,
you can just clone the GitHub repo by typing
git clone followed by the repo URL, which
is github.com slash William fiza slash algorithms.
You see that I've already cloned the repo
so I don't need to do it again. Then just
change directory into the algorithms folder.
So the file we're working with is called the
Ford Fulkerson example, dot java file. And
it's in the graph theory network flow examples
package. And luckily for us, it doesn't have
any dependencies yet. So we can just compile
it on its own with shafaq so if you type Java
c followed by comm, Wm is the algorithms graph
doing network flow examples. And then you
find that file Ford Focus, in example, that
Java, you compile it, it will produce a dot
class file in that directory. So you can execute
it by typing Java, and then the name of the
class and then pressing Enter and then you
get this beautiful output. So this prints
a lot of interesting information. Notably,
it prints the max flow of 23, and all of the
edges plus four columns. The first column
represents the start and end nodes of the
directed edge, then the amount of flow running
through the edge, the capacity of the edge.
And lastly, a boolean value indicating whether
the edge is a residual edge or not, which
is quite handy for debugging. So let's go
back to the code. So let's scroll back up
the code and take a look at the first of the
three classes which is the edge class the
edge class is composed of a few instance variables
in particular, every edge has a start node
called from and an end node called to each
edge in the flow graph has a certain amount
of flow and capacity, the capacity of the
edge is constant and does not change the flow
is dynamic and adjusts. As we argument the
flow when you create a new edge, it should
have a start and end node plus an initial
capacity, the flow defaults to zero, you might
notice that the residual edge instance variable
does not get initialized here or through the
constructor. The reason is that I initialize
the residual edge together with the forward
edge and hook them up together in a helper
method, which we'll see later. The next method
is the is residual method, which determines
whether an edge is a residual edge or not,
because forward edges are not permitted to
have a capacity of zero, you know an edge
is residual if the capacity is zero
pretty easy.
There is also the remaining capacity method
which can be used to determine the maximum
amount of flow that we can push through this
edge. This method works whether the flow is
positive or negative. Next is the augment
method which augments the flow for this edge
alone. All it does is it increases the flow
on the forward edge by the bottleneck value
we found along the augmenting path and it
also decreases the flow along the residual
edge. Last is the to string method which is
responsible for displaying those nice columns
we saw in the terminal. The next class we're
going to take a look at is the network flow
solver base. This class is a generic base
for max flow solvers, which all solvers should
extend to gain access to reuse variables and
setup methods and so on. For example, a simple
task like adding an edge to a flow graph should
be the same whether the max flow algorithm
is Edmonds Karp dynetics, some capacity scaling
algorithm, it shouldn't matter. Therefore,
it makes sense to abstract that behavior and
capture it in a base class. So there are many
variables in this class. The first one is
in short for infinity, which is just a handy
large constant that doesn't overflow. If you
add numbers to it, or at least they can handle
having large numbers added to it, then there
are the three input variables and the number
of nodes in the graph is the index of the
source node and T the index of the sync followed
by this are two special variables I usually
end up using because they greatly help boost
performance. So the rationale behind using
the visited token in combination with an integer
array that tracks the visited state of a node
is that when we are finding augmenting paths,
whether via depth first search or breadth
first search or whatever graph traversal method
you want to use, you generally want to ensure
that your augmenting path doesn't visit the
same node twice. Otherwise, that could result
in a cycle which we don't want. The way to
check if node AI is visited is to check if
the state in the visited array at index is
equal to the visited token. This is super
handy, because in the next iteration, when
we yet again want to find another augmenting
path, we can simply reset all the visited
states of every node simultaneously by simply
incrementing. The visitor token I know it's
kind of hacky, but it's super efficient and
really handy to have. The alternative is actually
to maintain a Boolean visitor array and you
fill that with false values every time just
before you find an automatic path. That's
not great because it requires an additional
order and work every time you want to find
an augmenting path. Next is a boolean variable
called solved, which indicates whether or
not we have actually run the network flow
solver, the solver only needs to run once,
because that always yields the same result.
So for example, if the user calls the get
max flow method multiple times the solver
only needs to run once. The next value that
we have right here is the max flow variable,
which is the value we're actually trying to
calculate. And finally is the adjacency list
representing the flow graph itself. Looking
at the constructor, we require the user to
specify the number of nodes along with the
index of the source and the sink nodes. Then
inside this method, I also take the opportunity
to initialize the flow graph. And as well
allocate some memory for the visited array
we'll be making use of later in the initialize
empty flow graph method I do is initialize
an empty array list of edges for each node
index so that we don't get a nullpointerexception.
When we try and add an edge to the graph.
Talking about adding edges to the graph, let's
have a look at the Add edge method. Here,
we need to provide the start node and the
end node of the directed edge and also provide
a positive capacity for that edge. If the
capacity is negative or zero, we throw an
exception because that is an illegal argument,
then what we do is that we actually create
the forward edge and the residual edge, you'll
notice that the residual edge actually has
a capacity of zero, then what we do is we
make the forward edges residual edge, the
residual edge and the residual edges
residual edge, the forward edge. And finally
we add them both to the flow graph. So in
effect, each edge is each other's inverse.
And this is exactly what we want, we want
a pointer that we can simply access when we
need to access and edges residual edge. The
remaining methods here are simply client facing
methods, they can be used to get the residual
graph after the solver has been executed.
And to obtain the maximum flow of the graph.
You'll notice that there's also this one special
method down here, which is the solve method.
And this is the method that the subclass needs
to override. This is the method which actually
solves the network flow problem and actually
pushes the flow through the network. And you
can see that every time the client goes and
calls on these methods like get graph or get
max flow, he calls the execute method, and
the execute method will run the solver. So
we will call this method if it hasn't been
executed already. So it's got that smart logic
built in. Now let's take a look at the Ford
Focus in depth first, or solver which you
can see actually extends the network flow
based solver so we know it actually implements
the solve method that we need for the get
Maxwell method. Awesome. Let's let's have
a look at this. So the first thing you'll
notice is that this method also takes the
inputs and s&t and all we do here is we call
the superclass constructor in the network
flow based solver which does all that nice
initialization that we know about. Next is
the most important method, which is that solve
method I was talking to you about. And you
can see that I actually overrides the method
in the superclass. So in this method, you
can see that I'm repeatedly calling the depth
first search method returns as output the
bottleneck value found along the augmenting
path, I store that value as F and increase
the max flow by F in each iteration, because
we know that the sum of the bottleneck values
equals the max flow, we do this until the
bottleneck value is zero, at which point we
know that no more augmenting paths exist and
the algorithm can terminate in between finding
each augmenting path you can see that increment
the visited token This is used to make the
state of every node unvisited. The depth first
search method itself takes two arguments,
the node ID and the flow. Initially, the starting
node is passed in as the node index and the
flow is set to be infinity. As we progress
through the flow graph, the flow value eventually
becomes the bottleneck value as we find smaller
and smaller edges with more restricting capacities
and we stopped the Alex Once the node index
equals the sink, so that's actually our base
case right here. Afterwards since we know
that the current node is not the sink, what
we do is we explore it by marking the current
node as visited. We do this by assigning the
current index or the current node index to
be equal to the visited token, then comes
the interesting part. First, we get all the
outgoing edges of this node residual otherwise,
and then loop over them. If the remaining
capacity is greater than zero, meaning we
can push flow through that edge and the next
know that we're going to is unvisited meaning
we don't risk creating a cycle, then we can
enter this inner if block right here, inside
the if block. The first thing I do is call
the depth first search method recursively.
What I do is I pass in the index of the next
node we want to go to and the new flow value
which should equal the minimum of the current
flow or the current edges remaining capacity.
Remember that that flow parameter is trying
to capture the bottleneck value that intuitively
makes sense. It's saying either keep the previously
found bottleneck value or if this new edge
is even smaller than it should be the new
bottleneck value, this process continues recursively
until a base case is hit and the sink was
reached. This returns the bottleneck of the
augmenting path, we can then use that value
to augment the flow of our augmenting path.
However, first check that the bottleneck value
is greater than zero, it could be the case
that we never actually made it to the sink,
and we hit a dead end. assuming that's not
the case, simply argument the flow by increasing
the flow in the forward edge by the bottleneck
value and decreasing the flow in the residual
edge by the bottleneck value. After that,
simply return the bottleneck value. This propagates
it up the stack so that all the other edges
along the augmenting path can also be augmented.
This also ensures that the bottleneck value
is returned to the solve method where the
max flow is actually calculated. So that's
about everything I want to cover for the Ford
Fulkerson method implemented with a depth
for search. Today we're going to start diving
a little deeper into network flow, we're going
to talk about unweighted bipartite graph matching,
and specifically how we can use max flow to
find a matching for us. Before we get started,
though, I should mention what a bipartite
graph is, a bipartite graph is one whose vertices
can be split into two independent groups,
u and v, such that every edge connects between
u and v. Other definitions exists, such as
the graph is too colorable, or there is a
cycle with an odd length. bipartite graphs
often arise when we're trying to match one
group of items to another in some way. Think
of situations such as matching suitable candidates
to jobs. There could be multiple jobs are
multiple candidates, but not every candidate
is suitable for each job. If jobs are red
nodes and candidates are white nodes, then
there would be an edge between the two if
the candidate is good fit. Another situation
could be matching surfers to surfboards. Suppose
there are multiple servers and multiple surfboards.
But the surfers have preferences and requirements
for the boards, such as color, size and so
on. Then the same thing happens we placed
an edge between the surfer and the surfboard
to indicate that they are able to be matched.
Generally when we're setting up a bipartite
graph, we're interested in what's called a
maximum cardinality bipartite. Matching. This
is when we've maximized the pairs that can
be matched with each other. For example, we've
maximize the number of candidates that can
be matched to jobs or the number of servers
to surfboards. Finding a matching is not unique
to bipartite graphs. However, you can also
have a matching on a non bipartite graph,
this variant is a lot harder to solve and
also much less common. Another variant is
finding a maximum matching on a weighted graph
where you can either maximize or minimize
the cost of the matching. This variant is
also much harder to solve than the unweighted
version in the unweighted version, no edge
is better in any sense than any other edge.
So it makes finding a matching much much easier.
We're mostly going to focus on the top left
box which is the easiest of the four variants,
but hopefully it will get poke around in some
of the other boxes as well. So if you want
to find a maximum matching on an unweighted
bipartite graph, you have lots of options,
you can either set the graph as a flow problem
and push flow through it, which is what we'll
look at in this video. But you can also repeatedly
find augmenting paths which maximize the matching
using a depth first search. Or you can use
the specialized Hopcroft Karp algorithm to
do the same thing a lot faster. If your edges
are weighted, and your graph is still bipartite,
you also have a lot of options, you can use
a min cost max flow algorithm, or you can
run the Hungarian algorithm. And lastly, there's
the more sophisticated network simplex algorithm
which uses linear programming. If however,
you graph is not bipartite, but your edges
are unweighted, you can use admins blossom
algorithm. And lastly, the hardest of the
four variants is when your graph is non bipartite.
And the edges are weighted. I didn't find
much information about this one online. But
the recommendation seems to be to use dynamic
programming on smart graphs. Now let's look
at an example. This is going to be for the
unweighted bipartite case, the easiest of
the four variants. So I want you to imagine
that there are five people and five books
in the library and that some people express
interest in some of the books. This results
in a bipartite graph with people on one side
and books on the other. So far, so good. Now
suppose we want to find the maximum cardinality
bipartite matching, or in other words, we
want to match as many people with as many
books as we can. Let's try the greedy approach
to this matching problem. Let's start with
person green. Their first edge connects to
the second book on the right side. The second
book is unallocated so person green is matched
with what is now book green. Next up is person
orange. The first book they want is the same
book as person green, which is already matched,
so we cannot select person greens book. Their
next choice is the third book which is unallocated,
so they get matched to that one. Next up is
person purple, they instantly matched to an
unallocated book on the right hand side. Now
person Read, read only has one edge, meaning
that they're only willing to read that one
book. However, that book has already been
allocated to person orange, so person read
cannot have it. Next up is person Brown. They
also want person oranges book, but they also
cannot have it. Fortunately, they have other
options of books they're willing to read.
So person brown gets one of those. So in the
end, the greedy approach only found a matching
of four, only four people were able to be
matched with books. But can we do any better?
Is this the true maximum cardinality matching.
Turns out that it's not a greedy approach
to the maximum matching problem will not work.
As we just saw, we need a more sophisticated
approach to ensure that we are able to get
that maximum matching. So we're going to solve
this maximum matching problem by turning our
problem into a network flow problem and finding
the max flow. The first thing we're going
to do is make every edge directed and add
one unit capacity to each edge. The zero slash
one besides each edge means zero flow and
a maximum capacity of one. Next we're going
to introduce two new nodes, the source and
the sink and hook up edges at words from the
source to the people with a capacity of one
and hook up edges from books to the sink also
with a capacity of one. Once that's all set
up, use any maxo algorithm to push flow through
the network. What this will do is show us
what edges get populated with flow with that
information, we will be able to reconstruct
the maximum matching. Here's a graph after
the flow algorithm has ran. You can see that
some of the edges have one unit of flow. Those
were the edges selected by the max flow algorithm.
The most interesting edges are the middle
edges with one unit of flow. These are the
edges which formed the maximum cardinality
matching if We call her in the middle edges,
which have one unit of flow, you can see that
this time everybody goes home with a book
and no one is left empty handed. Okay, so
now we understand how this basic setup works
and how it leads to a matching. Let's play
around with this model a little bit to truly
understand what all the weights here mean.
We originally set the capacity of each edge
from the source to each person to be one.
But what constraint is that really enforcing?
I'll let you pause the video and think about
that for a second because it's so important.
The answer is that that capacity of one ensures
that each person can get up to one book and
no more. If we increase this number. For some
people, we can allow them to possibly pick
up more than one book. If we rerun the max
flow algorithm through this network, we see
that it's now possible for one person to be
matched with multiple books. The next thing
we want to do is change the flow network to
allow a book to be selected multiple times.
Pause the video and think about how we can
modify this flow graph to support having multiple
copies of the same book in the library. I'll
give you a short moment. The number of copies
of a book is controlled by the capacity of
the edges leading to the sink T. Increasing
this value will allow more flow to run through
those designated edges. This effectively limits
or controls the number of copies of a book,
let's change the capacity of those edges leading
into the sink to allow having multiple copies
of the same book and see what happens. If
we rerun the max flow algorithm. Once again
through the network, we see that we now have
people matched with the same book multiple
times because multiple copies exist. For example,
Book Three and book five, both have two people
grabbing a copy of them, the actual assignment
of people to books would be as follows. I'll
let the animation play.
After the flow algorithm has ran, if you want
to know how many copies of each book were
actually given out, you can inspect the flow
value on the edge leading to the sink. Currently,
each person is only allowed to pick up one
copy of each book, even though there are multiple
copies of each book. How can we modify the
flow network to support this? You've guessed
it, we need to modify the edge capacity between
a person and the book to allow that person
to pick up multiple copies of that book. Today,
we're going to look at how to use network
flow to actually solve a useful problem. The
problem we're going to tackle is what I call
the mice and owls problem, which is a slightly
harder variation of another competitive programming
problem, which I'll link in the description.
I love this problem because of its simple
and elegant solution, but also it's realistic
real world application. Let's have a look.
Suppose there are m mice out on a field and
there's a hungry owl about to make a move.
Assume that the owl can reach every single
one of these mice. Further suppose that there
are h holes scattered across the ground, and
that each hole has a certain capacity for
a number of mice they can hide in it. We also
happen to know that every mouse is capable
of running a distance of are in any direction
before being caught by the owl. The question
asks, what is the maximum number of mice they
can hide safely before being caught. If you
want to give this problem a try, now's a good
time to pause the video and try and write
some code.
The first step is to figure out which holes
each mouse can reach. visualize this by drawing
a radius of our around each mouse. And if
inside the radius, there's a hole or the circle
touches a hole will assume that the mouse
can make it to the hole safely. So if we draw
an edge between a mouse and a hole, if the
mouse can make it to that hole, we get the
following graph. The next step is to actually
match mice to holes to maximize the overall
safety of the group. By doing a simple quick
inspection, it's clear that not every mouse
should be matched to any hole, for example,
this orange mouse should probably not try
and run to the hole with a capacity of three,
because it's the only mouse that can reach
the hole behind it with a capacity of one,
making any bad decision like this has the
chance to jeopardize the maximum number of
overall mice, they can hide safely. The key
realization with this problem is that the
graph is actually bipartite. And once we know
that, it actually becomes a much simpler problem,
because we can set up a flow graph and run
a maximum flow algorithm to maximize the overall
number of nice, which can hide safely, here
are the steps I would do to set the flow graph
and run a max flow. First, I would create
n mice nodes labeled zero through m minus
one inclusive, then on the other side, I will
create h nodes, each representing a whole,
I would label or index these nodes from m
to m plus h minus one inclusive to give them
a different ID than the mouse nodes, then
I would place an edge with a capacity of one
between the mouse and the hole. If the mouse
can reach that particular hole in time. After
that, I would connect an edge with a capacity
of one from the source to each mouse to indicate
that each node can have at most one maps.
And lastly, connecting edge from each hole
node to the sink node with the capacity of
the hole. The problem has now been transformed
into a maximum flow problem, we can run any
maximum flow algorithm to get the maximum
number of mice that can be safe. This is really
neat. And it's worth looking at some source
code to really understand how this setup works.
All right, here we are in the source code.
I have laid out some instructions on the top
here in case you wanted to download the code
and actually play around with it on your machine.
This program also uses the Ford Fulkerson
flow solver we saw two videos ago. So I highly
recommend you go and watch that video before
continuing. I'll link to it in the description
below, just in case you haven't seen it. So
let's get started. The first thing I do here
is I create a mouse class, which is essentially
a wrapper around a point object. Effectively,
a mouse is just the point on a plane. I also
do the same thing with the whole class except
that the whole class with addition to having
a 2d point object, it also has a certain capacity
because we know that holes can only contain
a certain number of mice. Next up in the main
method, I create a bunch of mouse objects
and place them in an array, I scour the mice
more or less randomly across the field. And
then I do the same thing with holes. The last
thing I do in the main method is called the
solve method which actually takes as input
the two arrays we just created and a radius.
The radius is how far a mouse can run from
its current position before being caught by
the hour. The sole method is where things
really start to get interesting. Let's define
some constants that will make our lives a
lot easier. First is M which is just the number
of mice then is h the number of holes we have.
Following that I compute n the number of nodes,
which is the number of mice plus the number
of holes plus two. The plus two is to account
for the source and the sink node. And as per
convention I always index s&t the source and
the sink two indices and minus one and minus
two to ensure that they are unique. After
that I initialize the network flow solver
base by providing and s&t the solver classes
defined below. It's the exact same one from
the Ford Fulkerson source code video. In short,
the solver lets you add edges with various
capacities to the flow graph and then find
the max flow. Once it's all set up. The goal
of this video is not to explain to you how
the max flow itself is found, or how the solver
works. I already discussed that previously.
What I really want to focus on in this video
is how to set up the flow graph for this problem
and push some flow through it when the graph
is bipartite. Like it is in this problem.
The setup is actually pretty straightforward.
The first step is to hook up edges from the
source asked to each mouse with a capacity
of one. Intuitively, this limits each mouse
node to represent at most one mouse. This
is necessary because we don't want a mouse
node to represent more than one mouse that
doesn't really make sense. The next part is
to hook up mouse nodes with holes. nodes in
the flow graph. This is the middle section
of the flow graph where we add an edge between
a mouse node and a hole if the distance from
a mouse to the hole is less than the radius.
In other words, if the mouse can make it to
the hole on time, add an edge connecting the
mouse and the hole. The last step is also
important, you need to remember to hook up
the edges between the holes and the sink.
These edges are slightly different, because
their capacity represents the number of mice
which can fit into each particular hole, say
a hole has a capacity of three. But there
are five mice which can make it to that hole.
Well, we cannot allow more than three of those
mice to fit in the hole. So we set the capacity
of the edge to the sink to be three, those
two leftover mice will need to find another
hole, or gets scooped up by the apple. The
very last thing we need to do to actually
get the max flow is to run the solver which
will return the number of safe mice, which
for this configuration happens to be four,
we're still talking about network flow. And
today's topic is one of my all time favorite
four problems, which is the elementary math
problem. This problem is so interesting, because
its solution uses flow. But it really doesn't
hit you as a flow problem to begin with. One
of the hardest things about network flow,
I believe is actually identifying that a problem
is a flow problem, and then setting it up
as so this is why I'm spending so many videos
solving some flow problems, so you really
start understanding how to approach them and
how they are solved. So let's dive into the
elementary math problem. This problem is actually
on caddis. Should you want to attempt it,
the link is at the bottom of this slide and
also in the description. Here's the problem
statement. Ellen is a math teacher who is
preparing and questions for her exam. In each
question, the students have to add, subtract
or multiply a pair of numbers. Ellen has already
chosen the N pairs of numbers, all that remains
is the side for each pair which of the following
three possible operations the students should
perform. To avoid students getting bored.
Elon wants to make sure that the end correct
answers on her exam are all different. For
each pair of numbers a B in the same order
as the input output a line containing a valid
equation. Each equation should consist of
five parts, a, one of the three operators
be an equal sign and the result of the expression.
All that n expression results must be different.
If there are multiple valid solutions, output
any of them if there are no valid answers,
output a single line with the string impossible
Instead, let's have a look at an example.
So Ellen goes and picks four pairs of numbers,
say one and five, three and three, four and
five. And lastly minus one and minus six.
She wants to assign operators either plus
minus or multiply to yield the unique answers
on the right hand side of the equation. One
assignment of operators might be the following.
However, this assignment of operators doesn't
quite work because the answers are not unique
on the right hand side. Here's another way
of assigning operators to the pairs of numbers.
This assignment does work because the answers
are unique on the right hand side, which is
one of the requirements for the problem. So
we just saw that not any arbitrary assignment
of operators yields a valid solution. But
it's also possible for no answer to exist,
consider the following pairs of numbers. In
this case, there can be no solution because
there are not enough unique answers that can
be produced using the operators plus minus
and multiply. As it happens, this problem
presents itself as a network flow problem,
even though that might not be obvious at first.
So take a moment and attempt to set up a flow
graph that can actually solve this problem.
It's actually a really great exercise along
the way. While you're doing this, there are
a few questions you should ask yourself, or
at least that I asked myself when I first
did this. The first is there a way that this
problem can be simplified into a bipartite
graph. I asked myself this because I know
that solving a flow problem when it's a bipartite
graph can be done very efficiently and also
because by Titan graphs are very easy to set
up, then I asked myself, how am I going to
detect impossible sets of parents? Will my
flow graph be able to handle that? Or do I
need to do some pre or post processing to
actually figure that out? And lastly, I'm
thinking about edge cases. So how, how do
I handle multiple repeated input pairs? And
how is I going to change the flow graph? These
are all super important questions you need
to ask yourself when solving this problem,
this slide deck explains the first two. And
the third is somewhat left as an exercise,
I don't want to give away the full solution
to this really awesome problem. So thinking
about how we're going to solve this problem
a little more, a key realization to make is
that for every input pair, at most three unique
solutions are produced, think of the input
pair, two and three. Well, for that pair,
we can either add two and three, subtract
two and three, or multiply two and three.
So there can be at most three unique results,
there may be less if there are collisions,
think of the input pairs 000, plus 000, multiplied
by 00. And zero subtracted by zero is also
zero. So we may end up with less than three
unique solutions, and that's fine. The great
thing about this is that we can easily set
up a bipartite flow graph from this because
we can have input pairs on one side and solutions
on the other side, let's see if we can set
the flow graph and solve the set of input
pairs, we have the pairs 1533, minus one minus
six, and finally to two so how we're going
to set up this bipartite graph is we're going
to have input nodes on the left side and answer
nodes on the right side, for our first input
pair one, five, if we compute one minus five,
one plus five, and one multiplied by five,
we get minus four, six, and five, which become
answer nodes on the right hand side, then
we want to attach an edge between that input
pair and the answer. Do the same thing for
the next input pair, make an input pair node
and attach edges to the answer nodes. However,
don't create another answer node if there
already exists one with the value we need.
In this example, you'll see that three plus
three equals six, and we already have an answer
node for six. So simply attach an edge from
three three to six do not create another answer
node. This is to ensure that our answers remain
unique. And do the same thing for the other
two remaining input pairs, you'll notice that
the last input pair only produced two outgoing
edges and not three. This is because there
was a collision in particular, two plus two
equals four, but also two multiplied by two
equals four, and this is fine. Just put one
edge don't put two edges. Then like every
bipartite graph you're trying to find a matching
for, you'll want to add the source s and the
sync T. And the matching is really what we're
after. Here, we want to match input pairs
to answers. And then we've actually solved
the problem. The next step, after adding the
source and the sink is to actually assign
capacities to the edges of the flow graph.
Let's start on the right side, the capacities
from the answer nodes to the sink should all
have a capacity of one since the answers need
to be unique and limiting the edge capacity
to one ensures that capacities for the input
pairs two answers should also have a capacity
of one since only one of plus minus or multiply
should actually be matched to enhance capacities
from the source two, the input pairs should
reflect the frequency of the input pair. In
this example, all frequencies are one. But
as we know, that's not always the case. Now
the flow graph is set up, let's run a max
flow algorithm on it. The flow algorithm does
its thing and some edges are filled with flow.
These are the edges that were selected to
be part of the maximum flow. From this, we
can derive what the matching was. More specifically,
we're interested in the middle edges. Those
are the edges which give us information about
the matching. every edge in the middle with
one unit of flow represents a matching from
an input pair a B to its answer. For example,
the input pair one five was matched to the
answer node six because there's one unit of
flow going through that edge. From this we
can even deduce the operator used for each
matching, which is actually needed for the
final output. This can be done by trying which
of the plus minus or multiply on Operator
results in the found matching. Basically,
we first solve the problem by figure out which
answers we get and then working backwards
to figure out which operator was used. In
theory, we could tag each middle edge with
what operator was used, but I didn't bother
doing that. It's, it's more work. Let's wrap
up this problem, the last thing we need to
do is look at the matchings and figure out
what operators were used. The first matching
is the input pair, one five matched to six.
So we ask ourselves, which of the three operators
plus minus or multiply our results in one
five equaling six? So we try all three options,
and we figure out that, hey, one plus five
is six. So the operator is the plus, then
we move on to the next pair, and then we do
the same thing.
If there are multiple operators that result
in the right answer, pick any of them. And
that's basically it, we can verify that all
our operators yield the correct result and
that all our answers are unique. I didn't
go into great detail on how to support multiple
repeated pairs, but I'll leave that as an
exercise to the listener. Today, we're going
to probe even further into network flow. We're
going to be talking about a specific implementation
of the Ford Fulkerson method, which is the
Edmonds Karp algorithm. Edmonds Karp is another
maximum flow algorithm, which uses a different
technique to find augmenting paths through
the flow graph. Before we get started, let
me give you a refresher on what we're trying
to do. We are trying to find the maximum flow
on a flow graph because we know that finding
the maximum flow is really useful for finding
bipartite matchings and also the solve a whole
host of problems. So far, we've looked at
one other technique to find the maximum flow,
which is to use the Ford Fulkerson method
with a depth first search. At a high level,
it says that all we want to do is repeatedly
find augmenting paths from the source to the
sink argument in the flow and then repeat
this process until no more paths exist. The
key takeaway here is that the Ford Fulkerson
method does not specify how to actually find
these augmenting paths. So this is where we
can optimize the algorithm. A few videos ago,
we saw that the Ford Fulkerson method can
be implemented with a depth first search to
find the maximum flow. However, the pitfall
with that technique was that the time complexity
depended on the capacity values of the edges
in the graph. This is because the depth for
search picks edges to traverse in such a way
that we might only ever be able to push one
unit of flow in each iteration. This is really
bad and can kill the time complexity even
though it's highly unlikely to happen in practice,
but it's absolutely something we want to avoid.
should it happen right now the time complexity
of Ford Fulkerson with a depth first search
is big O of E times f, where e is the number
of edges and f is the maximum flow. The idea
behind Edmonds Karp says that instead of using
a depth first search to find augmenting paths,
we should use a breadth first search instead,
to get a better time complexity. big O of
V times e squared may not look like a better
time complexity, but it actually is. What's
different is that the time complexity while
it might not look great, does not depend on
the capacity value of any edge in the flow
graph, which is crucial recall such an algorithm
that doesn't depend on the actual input values
a strongly polynomial algorithm and that's
exactly what Edmonds Karp is and why it was
so revolutionary at the time. Edmonds Karp
can also be thought of as an algorithm which
finds the shortest augmenting path from s
to t that is, in terms of the number of edges
used in each iteration. Using a breadth first
search during Edmonds Karp ensures that we
find the shortest path This is a consequence
of each edge being unweighted. When I say
unweighted, I mean that as long as the edge
has a positive capacity, we don't distinguish
it between one edge being a better or worse
than any other edge. Now, let's look at why
we might care about using Edmonds Karp. Suppose
we have this flow graph and we want to find
what the maximum flow is. If we're using a
depth first search, we might do something
like this. Start at the source Do a random
depth first search forwards.
So after a lot of zigzagging through the flow
graph, we are able to find the sink. As we
just saw a depth first search has the chance
to cause long augmenting paths and longer
paths are generally undesirable because the
longer the path, the higher the chance for
a small model neck value, which results in
a longer run time. Finding the shortest path
from s to t, again in terms of number of edges
is a great approach to avoid the depth first
search worst case scenario and reduce the
length of augmenting paths to find the shortest
path from s to t do a breadth first search
starting at the source and end to get the
sink while exploring the flow graph. Remember
that we can only take an edge if the remaining
capacity of that edge is greater than zero.
In this example, all edges outwards from s
have a remaining capacity greater than zero.
So we can add all the neighbors to the queue
when we're doing the breadth first search
step. And then we keep going forwards, so
add all reachable neighbors to the queue and
continue. And now the breadth first search
has reached the sink, so we can stop. In the
real algorithm, we would stop as soon as any
of the edges reached the sink. But just for
symmetry, I show three edges here entering
the sink, while in reality, we would stop
as soon as one of them reaches the sink. If
we assume that the bottom edge made it to
the sink first, and we retrace the path, we
get the following augmenting path. But we
didn't just find any augmenting path, we found
a shortest length augmenting path. So to augment
the flow, do the usual find the bottleneck
value by finding the smallest remaining capacity
of all the edges along the path, then augment
the flow values along the path that by the
bottleneck. So that was the first path however,
we're not done yet. Let's continue finding
paths until the entire graph is saturated.
Recall that while exploring the flow graph,
we can only reach a node if the remaining
capacity of the edge to get to that node is
greater than zero. For instance, all the reachable
neighbors of the source node in this case
does not include the bottom left node because
the edge from the source to the bottom left
node has a remaining capacity of zero. All
right, keep exploring until the sink is reached.
And now we've reached the sink once more.
So find the bottleneck value along this path.
Then use the bottleneck value to update the
flow along the augmenting path. Don't forget
to update the residual edges. And we're still
not done because there still exists another
augmenting path. So now there only exists
one edge outwards from the source with a capacity
greater than zero, so it's the only edge we
can take. So we follow it. There's also only
one edge to follow from the second node because
the other edges have a remaining capacity
of zero.
And now the breadth first search has reached
the sink, we can trace back the edges that
were used. We can find the bottleneck by finding
the minimum capacity along the path and also
augment the flow. And now you can see that
there are no more augmenting paths left to
be found because all the edges leading outwards
from the source have a remaining capacity
of zero. However, more generally, we know
to stop Edmonds Karp, when there are no more
augmenting paths from s to t, because we know
we cannot increase the flow anymore. If this
is the case, the maximum flow we get from
running Edmonds Karp is the sum of the bottleneck
values. If you recall in the first iteration,
we were able to push five units of flow in
the second iteration 10 units and in the last
iteration, five units for a total of 20 units
of flow. Another way to find the maximum flow
is the sum the capacity values going into
the sink, which I have circled in red. In
summary, this is what we learned using depth
first search on a flow graph can sometimes
find a long, windy path from the source to
the sink. This is usually undesirable because
the longer the path, the smaller the bottleneck
value, and the longer the runtime. Edmonds
Karp tries to resolve this problem by finding
the shortest length augmenting paths from
the source to the sink using a breadth first
search. However, more importantly, the big
achievement of admins Corp is that it's time
complexity of big O of the times e squared
is independent of the max flow. So it doesn't
depend on the capacity values of the flow
graph. And that's admins carp in a nutshell.
Today, we're going to have a look at some
source code for the Edmonds Karp algorithm.
Alright, here we are in the source code written
in Java, I've laid out some instructions here
in the header in case you wanted to download
the code, play around with it and run it yourself.
If I scroll down, you can see that we still
have the same setup as before with the edge
class, right here and the network flow base
solver. But there is one important change
I have made since the Ford Fulkerson video.
And that is I have added three new methods.
If we scroll down, you can see that three
new methods are right here. The three methods
I added abstract away visiting nodes and marking
all known says unvisited now, this is all
done efficiently internally, through the network
flow based solver class using a visited token
you don't have to worry about it also helps
readability for anybody who's new to the code.
Alright, now let's have a look at the Edmonds
Karp solver which is the only thing different
in this file. First, notice that the Edmonds
Karp solver extends the network flow solver
base. In doing so we get a whole bunch of
things for free, including the ability to
construct a flow graph, before we push flow
through it. In the constructor for the Edmonds
Karp solver, all I do is call the superclass
constructor. This performs various initializations,
including allocating memory for the flow graph
and registering which nodes are the source
and sink. The most important method and the
Edmonds Karp solver is the solve method right
here. The sole method is called just before
we get the maximum flow, this method is really
short. All we do is repeatedly find augmenting
paths from the source of the sink until the
flow we get is zero, at which point we know
that the graph is fully saturated and no more
augmenting paths can be found line by line.
And what we do is mark all nodes as unvisited
before each iteration, run a breadth first
search and get the bottleneck value, and then
some overall bottleneck values to calculate
the maximum flow. Now let's take a closer
look at the breadth first search method. The
first thing I do is initialize an empty queue
data structure. Because I know that we're
going to need one to do a breadth first search
after the creation of the queue. What I do
is I visit the source node and add it to the
queue so that the breadth first search starts
at the source.
Then do your standard breadth first search
loop. While there are still nodes in the queue,
remove the first node found in the queue.
If it's the sink, stop, otherwise iterate
through all valid adjacent neighbors, we can
add a node to the queue if it is not already
visited, and the edge leading to the node
has a capacity greater than zero. However,
before we add the node to the queue, we visit
it and track where it came from by placing
an edge in the prep array to rebuild the augmenting
path later on. Alright, so moving on, we know
that the breadth first search did not actually
make it to the sink if we have no entry at
the index of the sink in the prep array, so
we can return early after this point. We know
that there exists in augmenting path. Since
we know an augmenting path exists, we can
find the bottleneck value that is the smallest
remaining edge capacity along the path. We
do that by starting at the sink and reconstructing
the augmenting path going backwards by repeatedly
reaching into the prev array until we are
back at the source, then we need to update
the flow along the augmenting path to adjust
the flow values. So once again loop through
the edges forming the augmenting path, then
the I've met method takes care of increasing
the flow along the forward edges and decreasing
the flow along the residual edges. The very
last thing to do is to return the bottleneck
value so that we can sum the max flow and
the solve method. And that's basically it
for Edmonds Karp. to actually build a flow
graph. Have a look at the example right here
in the main class. It sets up the flow graph
from the previous video and pushes flow through
it. You can see down here where we actually
create the solver and run the solver to get
the maximum flow and then finally display
the resulting graph after the maximum flow
has been pushed through it. So this is really
handy to understand. So please have a look
at this in more detail. If you're struggling
to understand it and Karp, today, we're still
talking about network flow. And in particular,
we're going to cover something called capacity
scaling, which is really more of a heuristic
than it is an algorithm. Capacity scaling
is a heuristic which says that we shouldn't
attempt to push flow only through the largest
edges first, and then allow using edges which
have smaller capacities and do this to achieve
the maximum flow more rapidly. Just before
we dive into capacity scaling, I want to quickly
revisit finding the max flow using a depth
first search and the issues surrounding that.
I keep coming back to this because I think
it's important that we understand the intuition
behind why all these new max flow algorithms
were developed and why they came about. When
we're looking at finding augmenting paths.
The worst case is when we can only augment
the flow by one unit, and it goes something
like this, we start at the source node, we
take any edge with a remaining capacity greater
than zero. And we just keep going until we
reach the sink. And once we've reached the
sink, we find the bottle max value that is
the edge with the smallest remaining capacity
along our augmenting path, which in this case
happens to be one. Then we argument or update
the flow by adding the bottleneck value to
the flow along the forward edges and subtracting
flow by the bottleneck value along the residual
edges. However, we're not done. So we're going
to start once again at the source and start
finding another path. Suppose this time we
take the edge going down, then take the residual
edge going up and sideways, and then down
again. And now we have found another augmenting
path, and we can find its bottleneck value.
Recall that the remaining capacity of an edge
is calculated as the capacity minus the flow.
This allows residual edges with a negative
flow to have a positive remaining capacity.
Notice that yet again, the bottleneck value
for this path is only one unit of flow. Now
update or augment the flow. Do this by adding
the bottleneck value to the flow along the
forward edges and subtracting the flow by
the bottleneck value along the residual edges.
You could imagine the depth first search algorithm
repeatedly taking an edge with a capacity
value of one each time, which would ultimately
limit how much flow we can push through the
network in each iteration, as shown in the
next few slides. So it would look like this
we just keep alternating between the forward
and the residual edge with a capacity of one.
Capacity scaling is the idea that we should
prioritize taking edges with larger capacities
first to avoid ending up with a path with
a small bottleneck. If we adjust the size
of each edge based on its capacity value,
then we can more easily visualize which edges
we should give more attention to the capacity
scaling algorithm is pretty straightforward.
But first, we need to define two variables
that we will need. let u equal the value of
the largest edge capacity in the initial flow
graph. And also let Delta be the largest power
of two which is less than or equal to the
value of view. The capacity scaling heuristic
says that we should always take edges whose
remaining capacity is greater than or equal
to delta in order to achieve a better runtime.
But that's not everything to the algorithm.
The algorithm will repeatedly find augmenting
paths through the flow graph which have a
remaining capacity greater than or equal to
delta. Until no more paths satisfy this criteria.
Once this criteria is no longer met, what
we do is decrease the value of delta by dividing
it by two. And then we repeat this process
while delta is greater than zero. So the reason
you would want to implement capacity scaling
is because it's very easy to code up and it
works very, very well in practice. In terms
of time complexity, capacity scaling with
a depth first search runs in big O of E squared
log Q. And in big O of E times v log you if
the shortest augmenting path is found, which
is basically Edmonds Karp but with capacity
scaling, although I have found that to be
much slower, so I would recommend the depth
for search if you are going to implement this.
Let's do an example, let's find the maximum
flow of the following flow graph using capacity
scaling. First, compute you as the maximum
of all initial capacity values. In this example,
use the maximum of 614 157 10 111 and 12,
which happens to be 14. Next, compute the
starting value for delta, which is the smallest
power of two less than or equal to u, which
we know is 14. Therefore, the starting value
of delta is eight since the next power of
two after eight is 16. But 16 is larger than
14. Now that we have delta, we can start finding
paths from s to t, which have a remaining
capacity greater than or equal to eight, start
our search at the source from the source,
there's only one edge which has a remaining
capacity of eight or more, which is the edge
with the capacity of 14 going downwards, then
there's the edge sideways with a remaining
capacity of 10, we can take and finally an
edge with the remaining capacity of 12 going
upwards, which we can also take. Now we've
reached the sink. So we can find the bottleneck
value which is 10. Because 10 is the smallest
remaining capacity along the found path. Next,
augment the flow along the path, I scaled
down the size of each edge to reflect how
much remaining capacity they have left, you
can analyze the flow graph, but there are
no more augmenting paths from s to t which
have a remaining capacity greater than or
equal to eight. So the new delta is haften
two, and is now equal to four. One path we
can take with all remaining capacities of
four or more is the following. Start at the
source. Go up, sideways and sideways again,
then do the usual find the bottleneck and
augment the flow. There is also another path
with all remaining capacities rather than
four which we can take from stt, which is
down to one diagonally up to node two and
to the sink again, find the bottleneck value,
which we know to be four, because four is
the smallest remaining capacity along a path,
then we can augment the flow. If you now inspect
the flow graph, there are no more paths with
a remaining capacity with all values greater
than or equal to four from s to t, so half
the value of delta and two However, there
are also no paths with the remaining capacity
of all two or more. So we need to have the
value of delta again. So now delta is equal
to one, I believe there is one remaining path
we can take before the graph is fully saturated.
Let's start at the source and find it.
Alright, now we found the path. And we can
also find the bottleneck which has a value
of one. And now the last step is to augment
the flow. And now there are no more paths
from s to t which have a remaining capacity
greater than or equal to one. So the new value
of delta is zero, which terminates the algorithm,
we can compute the maximum flow by summing
up all the bottleneck values we found in each
iteration, which we know to be 10 Five, four
and one for a total of 20. We can also compute
the maximum flow by summing the flow values
going into the st highlighted in red. So in
summary of what we have learned about, we
know that Ford Fulkerson implemented with
a depth first search can result in having
a bottleneck value of one in each iteration,
which kills the time complexity. Capacity
scaling is when we push flow only through
larger edges first, to try and achieve a better
runtime. One approach to capacity scaling
is to maintain a decreasing parameter Delta,
which acts as a threshold for which edges
should be accepted and which should be rejected
based on their remaining capacity. This is
a pretty simple but extremely powerful idea
that greatly speeds up finding the maximum
flow. Today we're going to have a look at
some source code for the capacity scaling
algorithm. Okay, here we are on the source
code written in Java. I've laid out some instructions
here in the header in case you actually want
to get the code play around with it and run
it yourself. Scrolling down you can see we
have the familiar edge class here. This is
the class used to represent an edge that connects
two nodes with a certain company. If I scroll
a little further down, we have the network
flow solver base, which acts as a template
for all the different flow algorithms we have
been implementing. I have already covered
how these two classes work in the previous
videos linked below. So please have a look
at those before continuing. However, the class
we're really interested in is the capacity
scaling solver. Right here. The capacity scaling
solver is an implementation of the network
flow solver base, which uses capacity scaling
to find the maximum flow, you will notice
that I have defined one new instance variable
in this class, which is called Delta. This
is the same Delta that we saw from the slides,
it's the parameter we use to determine whether
an edge should be accepted or rejected based
on the remaining capacity relative to the
value of delta. The constructor for this class
simply calls the super classes constructor
to initialize the flow graph and allocate
some memory that will need to actually push
flow through the network. Just below is the
Add edge method. The Add edge method is particularly
interesting for capacity scaling to work,
we need to know the value of the edge with
the largest capacity in our flow graph. Since
we also need to construct the flow graph to
actually do anything interesting, we can capture
the largest capacity value as we build the
graph. The implementation of the Add edge
method is defined in the network flow solver
base, which we don't actually want to change
the functionality of. So inside this add edge
method, which I'm overriding here I do is
I call the super classes add edge method.
And I also initialize delta to be the largest
capacity we encounter as edges come through
simple enough. Inside the solve method, which
gets called to compute the maximum flow, the
first thing we do is initialize delta to be
the largest value of two less than or equal
to the largest capacity. And one way to do
this is to find the floor of the base two
logarithm and then raise that value to a power
of two or in Java, you can simply use the
built in function highest one bit to do that
for you more efficiently. Following that we
repeatedly find augmenting paths from the
source to the sink using only edges with the
remaining capacity greater than or equal to
delta. After each iteration, we have the value
of delta to allow taking smaller edges and
being able to find more augmenting paths from
the source to the sink until the graph is
fully saturated. Inside the inner loop, we
mark all the nodes as unvisited then we do
a depth first search and sum over the bottleneck
values to calculate the maximum flow we repeatedly
do this until delta is equal to zero.
Now let's have a look at the depth for search
method. The depth first search method takes
two arguments the current node and the minimum
flow found along the path so far, when we
initially call this method, the source node
is the current node and the flow is set to
positive infinity. This method performs the
depth first search recursively. And we know
we can stop searching when we have reached
the sync node t. If the current node is not
the sync node, then visit the current node
and iterate through all the neighbors of the
current node. However, here's the catch though
we cannot take an edge going to a neighboring
node if the remaining capacity of that edge
is smaller than delta because this violates
the capacity scaling heuristic, we must also
ensure that the node we're going to has not
already been visited. We do this to avoid
cycles in the flow graph. Inside the inner
if statement we call the depth first search
method recursively passing the node or going
to as the current node and the new flow as
the minimum of the current flow and this edges
remaining capacity, the depth for search returns
the bottleneck value along the augmenting
path. So after the depth first search call,
we are unwinding the call stack from the sink
back to the source. This is a perfect time
to augment the flow of each edge along the
augmenting path since we have the bottleneck
value right there. So if the bottleneck value
is greater than zero, this means we have found
a valid augmenting path and we want to augment
the flow, which is remember adding flow along
forward edges and subtracting flow along residual
edges. This is all done through the argument
method in the edge class and finally, return
the bottleneck value. If we scroll down even
more, you can see that this is the main method
right here. In here I set up an example of
how to set up a flow graph. Specifically,
this is the flow graph from the slides. So
I create a flow solver. I add all the edges
and then I push some flow through it and get
the maximum flow. I also display the resulting
flow graph after the flow algorithm has been
executed so you can see what happened. Awesome.
That's all I wanted to cover for capacity
scaling. Today, we're still talking about
network flow. And in particular, we're looking
at finding the maximum flow and a new, very
efficient method of solving the unweighted
bipartite matching problem. denix algorithm
is one of those extremely fast and revolutionary
algorithms, which really push the field of
network flow forwards. It was one, if not
the first algorithm to introduce a bunch of
new concepts like building a level graph,
combining multiple graph traversal techniques
together and the concept of a blocking flow,
all of which we'll get into. So what is the
next algorithm? It's a fast, strongly polynomial
maximum flow algorithm. The fact that it's
strongly polynomial is important, it means
that the run time doesn't depend on the capacity
values of the flow graph for which all we
know could be very large. What's remarkable
about dynex is that not only is it fast in
practice for general graphs, but it boasts
performance on bipartite graphs running and
the time complexity of big O of square root
v times E. The importance of this cannot be
overstated. It makes it possible to handle
bipartite graphs of a ridiculous size. If
you're doing competitive programming. dynex
is the de facto standard algorithm to solve
maximum flow algorithms. The algorithm was
conceived in 69 by Ephraim Dennis and published
in 1970. The algorithm was later modified
slightly and popularized by Shaiman. Evan
mispronouncing denotes algorithm as demyx
algorithm. Let's start by talking about the
algorithm itself. But first, beginning with
an analogy. Suppose you and a friend are planning
to meet up at the coffee shop a few streets
east of where you are, you've never been to
this coffee shop, and you don't exactly know
where it is, but
you know, it's somewhere east. So how would
you get there? With the information you have?
Would it make sense to head south? What about
Northwest, the only sensible directions are
East, North East and Southeast This is because
you know that those directions in guarantee
that you make a positive progress towards
the coffee shop. This form of heuristic ensures
that we continuously make progress towards
whatever place of interest we desire to go.
So how can we apply this concept to solving
the maximum flow? In this analogy, you were
the source node and the coffee shop is the
sink. The main idea behind dynex algorithm
is to guide augmenting paths from the source
to the sink using the level graph. And in
doing so greatly reducing the runtime. The
way dynex determines what edges make progress
towards the sink T and which do not is by
building what's called a level graph. The
levels of a graph are those obtained by doing
a breadth first search from the source. Furthermore,
an edge is only part of the level graph, if
it makes progress towards the sink, that is
an edge must go from a node at level l to
another node at level l plus one, the requirement
that edges must go from L to L plus one prunes
backwards or what I call sideways edges. Those
are all the gray edges in the slide. So ask
yourself if you're trying to get from s to
t as quickly as possible, does it make sense
to take the red edge going in the backwards
direction on the slide? No, taking the red
edge doesn't bring you any closer to the sink,
so it should only be taken if a detour is
required. This is why backwards edges are
omitted from the level of graph, the same
thing can be said about edges which cut across
sideways across the same level since no progress
is made. It's also worth mentioning that residual
edges can be made part of the level graph
but they must have a remaining capacity greater
than zero. So that's the level graph the actual
steps to executing denix are as follows First
construct a level graph by doing a breadth
first search from the source to label all
the levels of the current flow graph. Then,
if the sink was never reached, while building
the level graph, you know, he can stop and
return the value of the maximum flow. Then
using only valid edges in the level graph
do multiple depth first searches from the
source to the sink until a blocking flow is
reached and sum over the bottleneck values
of all augmenting paths calculate the maximum
flow as you do this. Repeat steps 123 a blocking
flow is when we cannot find any more paths
from the source to the sink because too many
edges in the level of graph have been saturated.
This will all become clear with an example,
let's use the next algorithm to find the maximum
flow of this flow graph. If this were a bipartite
graph, we would also be able to get a maximum
matching as a result. All right, step one
is to figure out which edges are part of the
current level graph, you don't need to think
of the level of graph as a totally separate
graph, you can think of it rather as a subset
of the edges. So we start at the source and
do a breadth first search outwards. The first
layer includes all the red nodes, then this
is the second layer, and so on until we reach
the sink. Now, if we focus on the edges, which
formed the level graph, we can see that they
are all edges which go from L to L plus one
and level and have a remaining capacity greater
than zero. Step two of the algorithm is to
find paths from s to t until a blocking flow
is reached. That is, we cannot find any more
paths through the level graph. So we start
at the source and do a depth first search
on the edges of level graph until the sink
is reached. So we've found our first augmenting
path and the bottleneck value along this path
is five since five is the smallest remaining
capacity, so update the flow values along
the path by five. If you inspect the graph,
the blocking flow has not yet been reached,
since there still exists paths from s to t.
Start once again the source and do a depth
first search forwards. Now we found another
path, this one has a bottleneck value of 15.
So augment the flow along the path by 15 units.
Now let's try and find another path from s
to t.
What happens now is that we get stuck performing
the depth first search, there are no edges
in the level of graph with a remaining capacity
greater than zero, which can lead us to the
sink. So the blocking flow has been reached,
we just finished the first blocking flow iteration.
Now we reset and rebuild the level graph.
This time it should look different because
the remaining capacities of multiple edges
has changed. Start at the source expand outwards
taking all edges with a remaining capacity
greater than zero, which in this case is only
the middle edge leading us to the red node,
the top edge going outwards from the source
of saturated and so is the one going downwards.
We keep doing this and building the level
graph layer by layer. Awesome. So this is
our new level graph. You can see that this
time we have one extra layer to play with.
Let's try and find a path from s to t. Once
again, we start at the source and probe forwards
using only edges part of the level graph.
Oops, we have now reached a dead end in our
depth first search because we can no longer
go forwards. What we need to do is backtrack
and keep going until we reach the sink.
Perfect We made it to the sink the current
path has a bottleneck value of 10 now augment
the flow by 10 units. And now if you inspect
the flow graph, you will notice that the blocking
flow has once again been reached. Now no more
flow can be pushed through the network when
we build the level of graph, which means the
algorithm terminates. The maximum flow is
the sum of all the ball and x values which
if you recall were 515 and 10. For a maximum
flow of 30. The maximum flow can also be calculated
by looking at the flow values of the edges
leading into the sink highlighted in red on
the slide. However, one of the pitfalls of
the current implementation of Linux algorithm
at the moment is that it may encounter multiple
dead ends during a depth first search phase.
This is especially bad if the same dead end
is taken multiple times during a blocking
flow iteration. To resolve this issue in his
original paper denotes suggested cleaning
the level graph and getting rid of all the
dead ends before each blocking flow phase.
Then later in 1975. Shaiman Evans suggested
pruning dead ends when backtracking during
the depth for search phase, effectively getting
rid of dead ends on the fly as the algorithm
executes. This trick greatly speeds up and
simplifies the algorithm because that ends
are only ever encountered once. Awesome. So
that's basically everything you need to know
about Linux. So let's summarize everything
that we've learned. First, we talked about
the motivation behind Linux, and why having
a guiding heuristic can greatly speed up our
algorithm. Then we talked about the intuition
and practicality behind having a level graph
that directs edges towards the sink. Then
we talked about the concept of a blocking
flow, which is achieved by doing multiple
depth first searches on the level graph until
the graph is saturated.
Afterwards, we looked at the process of rebuilding
the level graph, and finding the blocking
flow and doing this process repeatedly until
no more augmenting paths exist and the maximum
flow is found. And lastly, we talked about
a critical optimization of minutes algorithm,
which is pruning dead ends so that we do not
encounter them again. Today, we're going to
have a look at some source code for dynex
algorithm. Okay, let's get started. Here we
are in the source code written in Java, I
laid out some instructions here in the header
in case you wanted to get the code play around
with it and run it yourself. Scrolling down
as before, you can see the familiar edge class
this class is used to represent an edge that
connects to nodes with a certain capacity.
It also has two important methods remaining
capacity, which returns the true remaining
capacity of an edge along with the argument
method, which updates the flow along this
edge and also the residual edge by a certain
amount. A little further down is also the
network flow solver base, which acts as a
template for all the different flow algorithms
we have been implemented. I already covered
how this class and the edge class work and
in previous videos linked below, so I won't
spend too much time here. But what you need
to know is that this class initializes the
flow graph, it allows edges to add the flow
graph, I like to call the get max flow method,
which is somewhere down here, right here.
Internally, they get Maxwell method calls
the abstract solid method, which we need to
implement by subclassing, the network flow
software base. So the part that we are really
interested in is this dynex solver right here,
you will notice that the dynex solver class
extends the network flow solver base network
flows or base gets initialized when we call
super by feeding it the three inputs n s and
t n is the number of nodes in our graph, S
is the index of the source node and T is the
index of the sinking node. Just after that
I initialize an array instance variable column
level to be a size and the level instance
variable keeps track of the level of each
note. Now we're a level graph. Moving on the
following method is the solve method. Recall
that this is the method that we need to override
and compute the maximum flow in. Remember,
what we're trying to do did an algorithm begins
by building a level graph using a breadth
first search that is the outer loop. And for
each level graph, we need to find the blocking
flow by repeatedly doing multiple depth for
searches from the source to the sink until
the level graph is saturated, and the blocking
flow is reached. Once that happens, rebuild
the level graph and repeat the process until
the graph is truly saturated. Let's have a
look at the breadth first search method. So
the breadth first search method really serves
two purposes. One is to build the level graph
and assign a level to each node in the level
array. And the other purpose is captured by
the return value of the function. And that
is to determine if we are able to reach the
sink during the breadth first search phase.
And if not, this means that the graph is fully
saturated and the algorithm can stop. The
first thing I do in this method is mark each
note as unvisited by setting each entry in
the level array to be
minus one. Then I initialize a queue data
structure that we will need when performing
the breadth first search. After that I immediately
add the source node to the queue. That's because
we're starting the breadth first search at
the source node. Since we're already at the
source node, we can mark the distance to the
source node to be zero. Once we start the
breadth first search loop while the queue
is not empty, each iteration we remove the
first node index we find in the queue and
iterate through all the adjacent edges of
that node. When building the level graph,
we want to ensure two things first, that the
remaining capacity of the edges We take r
greater than zero and that we are selecting
unvisited nodes. If both those cases hold,
then we can compute the level for that node
we're about to visit and add it to the queue.
This process continues until the queue is
empty and the entire level graph is built.
The last thing we do is return if we were
able to reach the sync node during the breadth
first search phase. Okay, coming back to the
solve method, now we understand how the breadth
first search method works and how the level
graph is constructed. Now let's have a look
at the depth research method. However, before
we do that, there's a key piece of information
you need to know about and that is the next
array in this method, the next array is part
of the Shaiman evon optimization, and it is
how we are able to prune dead ends efficiently.
The idea is that since our graph is stored
as an adjacency list, the list of edges going
outwards from each node is indexed. And we
can use this to our advantage to get the next
edge to to reverse and skip all the edges,
which we know lead to dead ends. Say we're
at node i and we take the first edge in our
adjacency list for node i suppose that this
turns out to lead us to a dead end. Well,
next time as in the next step, the first search
in which we encounter the same node, we should
not take the first edge in the adjacency list
for that node, because we know it will lead
us to a dead end. The next array is a way
of tracking for each node, which edge we should
take next, each iteration, you want to reset
the next array to allow taking previously
forbidden edges. All right, so we call the
depth research method and we pass in three
argument, the current node being the source,
the next array and the minimum flow along
the path, which starts at positive infinity,
then for each augmenting path that we find
sum over the bottleneck values to compute
the maximum flow. All right, let's have a
look at the depth first search method itself.
The depth through search method takes three
arguments, the current node, the next array,
and the minimum flow along
the path. So far, this method performs a breadth
first search recursively. And we know we can
stop searching when we have reached the sync
node t. Then I captured the number of edges
going out of this node, the for loop loops
through all the edges. While we have not tried
taking each edge for the current node, the
next edge to take is the next outgoing edge
from this node at the index in the next array.
The thing we have to watch out for is that
we must ensure that the selected edge has
a remaining capacity greater than zero, and
that it goes up a level. Remember that we're
always trying to make progress towards the
sink and taking an edge at the next level
guarantees that unless of course, it leads
to a dead end. But we end up pruning those
so it doesn't really matter. So if all goes
well, we get to enter the inner if statement.
Inside the inner if statement, we call the
depth for search method recursively passing
in the node, we're going to as the current
node and the next array and the flow as the
minimum of the current flow and the edges
remaining capacity. The depth for search returns
the bottleneck value along the augmenting
path after the this death research call, we
are unwinding the call stack if you will,
and we're going from the sink back to the
wards the source, this is a perfect time to
augment the flow for each edge along the augmenting
path. Since we already know what the bottleneck
value is. So if the bottleneck value is greater
than zero, meaning we actually found an augmenting
path augment the flow, which means to add
flow along the forward edge and subtract flow
along the residual edge. And once all that
is done, simply return the bottleneck value.
So assuming we were not able to take the selected
edge from the current node, because it did
not have enough remaining capacity, or didn't
increase in level or we hit a dead end or
whatever reason, we need to mark the selected
edge as invalid so we can prune it and future
iterations. This is exactly what the next
at plus plus line does, which gets executed
after the iteration of the loop. It increments
the index of the edge take at the current
node. If we scroll down to the main method,
you see that I show you how to set up a flow
graph by initializing the flow solver and
pushing some flow through the graph. In particular,
this is the flow graph from the slides last
video. So you can verify that the maximum
flow we get should be 31.